this is Jocko podcast number 357 with
Echo Charles and me Jocko willink good
evening Echo good evening
Sims kept moving
and I stopped him by shouting to his
back
sir anything you asked me to do I am
here you know that
Sim stopped slowly pivoting on the P
Stone
he walked back to me
I know that staff sergeant Bell I've
never once questioned that in you
I took a moment
it was a cool night The Silence of this
area
of open nothingness was now invaded by
giant generators humming
blasting lights brighter than a Texas
high school football stadium
an area that was essentially a path that
required night vision two weeks ago was
now amassed with army heavy equipment
trucks cranes and Conex trailers of
worker B contractors and soldiers
endlessly moving equipment 24 hours a
day for the big inter-theater move to
Fallujah
what do you got sergeant
I am more worried about losing people
now than losing people in 10 years
and I don't mean to disrespect where you
were coming from
I just can't think that way
we are going to lose people
we will lose some of these men
the reality of what he just said seemed
to impact him in real time as if he was
unaware of what was coming out of his
own mouth
he paused Sergeant I don't know if I'm
prepared for that either
we both looked at each other
all I wanted was the Fallujah fight
I dreamed for this test I was so excited
about the prospects of actually
impacting this war
now with Captain Sims the reality of it
seemed to hit me at once
he looked at me
bags under his eyes
stress
worry
his wet eyes seemed red from long hours
and late nights
no way around this
I need you this is going to be really
rough he said
we need you sir you got us here and you
will get us home
let's get as many back home as we can
yes sir
we walked in two opposite directions
that night
Captain Sims toured the glowing lights
me into the pitch Blackness of the
barracks
when I think of Captain Sean Sims I see
him in his dcus bright in that night's
glow of the light
with only a helmet on his head and a
sidearm on his leg
walking into the light
and that right there is a
excerpt
from a book called remember the ramrods
an army Brotherhood in War and Peace by
David bellavia
and that's a conversation that took
place just prior to the Second Battle of
Fallujah operation Phantom Fury
the bloodiest battle of the Iraq War
and the heaviest concentration of urban
combat since the Vietnam War
Captain sins Captain Sims was the
commander of Alpha Company second
Battalion second Infantry Regiment known
as the ramrods who were organized in the
third Brigade combat team first Infantry
Division
Dave bellavia was a squad leader in
third platoon of Alpha Company
and so that was a conversation
between an officer the officer the
company commander and one of his
non-commissioned officers as they
prepared for the worst combat
that they could imagine
in a short time after that conversation
they cross the breach into Fallujah
where they met the enemy
improve their medal as soldiers as
Warriors and as American fighting men
there was great sacrifice during that
battle
including over 500 wounded Americans
95 killed
and for his actions during one house
fight in that battle David bellavia was
awarded the Medal of Honor
and he has written about his experiences
in two books the first book called house
to house
and a new book that just came out
that I mentioned which is called
Remember
the ramrods and it's an honor to have
David bellavia here with us tonight
to share his experiences and his lessons
learned David
thanks for coming out man thanks for
having me appreciate it
that uh reading that section of the book
I remember when we were getting relieved
yeah in ramadi my task unit was getting
relieved in ramadi and uh
new task unit came to take our place and
we're giving them an in brief and
[Music]
the guys that were relieving us well
they were coming from San Diego
California Seal Team five
and
I remember giving them a brief and I was
telling them you are going to take
casualties
and you could see even though These Guys
these guys had been to to Mark Lee's
Funeral they'd been to Mikey Monsters
funeral a couple weeks prior
but you know they got on the ground and
there's me and I'm telling them hey you
guys are going to take casualties it's a
it's a rough thing to to face
and that conversation that you had with
Captain Sims
you know and and look how old were you
at that time
I was uh 28 28 years old and you have
that attitude like hey this is what this
is what I was born to do this is what
I've been waiting for I want to go fight
inclusion these guys from Team five God
bless them what they want to do they
wanted to get into it of course
and that reality check of hey this is
where it's going and This Is War
and casualties are going to come it's a
it's a heavy
it's a heavy thing to walk into
it I mean hearing you read that
I I it's it's so it's it's strange to me
because I I think of you know the guys
that get hurt are the ones that really
know
what you can get shot at repeatedly
a snap a hiss I mean you know when
you're first in country you always laugh
at the new guy it doesn't know the
difference between incoming outgoing
like hey what are you doing you're
running for the bunker right it's like
when a baby's born The Pacifier Falls
and you sterilize and steam it autoclave
it you know then after like the second
third kid you're like you know come on
put some more dirt on it it's good for
his immune system the reality is that
once you have been shot and you know and
you see your friends that have
experienced it
there's it's not real until that happens
and we remember the ramrods is a book
about
how we all are trying to
I used to think that I missed War
and that for my entire remaining adult
years after I left the military I missed
I missed adrenaline I missed the
ultimate I mean you go into a job
interview and it's like are you good
enough what's on your resume
you know what degree do you have your
credit score
um in civilian life we we
like before we trust
you go on a date are you worthy of my
time do I trust you in the military I
trusted before I still don't like half
these guys you know but I trust them you
know like it's a totally different and
so we look at those days and we think
that was the best time of my life and
and there's also we know that's weird
for civilians to hear right we know that
that's odd and I thought those were the
best days of my life and I realized it
wasn't the war it was the relationships
it were it was the people it was the
sense of validation and purpose every
day I woke up I knew what I had to do I
knew I was needed
and and being needed in a fight is the
great Leading Men is an incredible honor
but having a purpose in a fight
is the greatest experience ever when
you're being shot at and it's almost
like the enemy's only shooting at the
guys they want to take out of the
battlefield you don't ever want to be in
a fight and not getting shot at that
means they're they're willing to keep
you out there for a little while you're
not you're not exactly a threat to
anyone that that's a it's a great
feeling to to know that this my
generation every reason people are
divided today
our generation at War had all the
problems people have today
we had gay people we had people with
different ethnicity different religions
and yet we cancel each other's vote out
every year
so we've gotten the same debates
and then when the bell rang we went out
there did our job
and and and learned to live with each
other and respect each other and love
each other
and that to me is something that we
everyone talked well it's missing it's
our responsibility to remind our
citizens why we there's not a dental
plan in the world that's going to make
you do what you did I mean honestly
seriously is he college debt College
that's that bad that you're going to go
and do a vacation in ramadi
I mean it's ridiculous it's absurd to
say so do you grieve you know you have
have been able to do something with your
career
that to me is in I'm I'm tired of people
saying look what he did
I want people to say look what I can do
if it's not inspiring to see people like
you
then it's a waste because if it's just
about one individual and that's why this
award is so this award is ridiculous
because what do you do we're Team it's
all about us but however there's one guy
you know what I mean the only award for
the entire living for the entire War
it's not an honor it's it's a it's
disrespectful
I could I could name you seven names
from Fallujah alone that should have the
Medal of Honor so so now you put one
award on someone
what is are we going to go and just eat
shrimp for the rest of our life is now
the time to go and you know go off into
a e and start a TLC show my Medal of
Honor life you know what what am I
supposed to do with this can I no how
about we remember who we are
every single day I'm I'm still a soldier
I'm still an infantry man I will always
be a non-commissioned officer
and I'm an example of my leadership
and and the greatest compliment a leader
can have is when his subordinates
Eclipse them
and that's tough for that's tough for a
guy in his 20s running around with
people don't understand this about the
military but we get a lot of guys that
were division one studs that brought a
gun to football practice we get a lot of
guys that screwed up and and these are
these are guys that could be playing on
Sunday any sport they want
there are times that you want a
professional goaltend a little bit and
be like well that's a hard charger he's
smart and he's physically fit
I gotta destroy destroy his career he's
going to take my job I don't want to
give him a good report a good counseling
statement I want to give him an award
and then you start to realize that the
reason why our military is Elite is
because every generation is better than
the previous and and you have to embrace
that greatness
that's what a leader is a leader is
saying this is what I did look at what
my 12 guys did they're better men
they're better fathers they're better
citizens and they're better soldiers
than I was that's what you want to be
able to say and until you say that
you know you're you're playing paintball
with it with a with a college fund it's
not real this is what it's all about
it's making it's making it better for
the next group
well I think there's a lot in these
books that uh definitely are going to
help a lot of people be able to move
through these things
um
let's get into where you came from a
little bit just a little bit of
background on you sir you're born
born in uh what 1975. yeah and up in
Western New York uh how do you say your
town name lindenville yeah population
838. is that right that's yes 2010
census we're not going to get an arena
football franchise anytime soon but it
uh it's a real small town Apple town
right off uh uh farming Community off of
Lake Ontario and it's about an hour from
Buffalo and and your dad what'd your dad
do dentist
father was a dentist and he chose rural
instead of suburban he could have done
anything practiced anywhere that's where
he wanted to raise his family and what
about your mom she was working at the
practice she would stay at home helped
him out was a partner all throughout a
great family great I'm the youngest of
four
and everyone had has a master's double
Masters PhD I mean these are my dad was
all about education be a professional
how'd that work out for you I'll tell
you what it was weird that he as a
dentist his whole thing was you know he
had great empathy wanted to always take
people out of pain
and I would hang out my granddad was a
is still alive he's 102. and he was a
normedy vet he did Sicily North Africa
and Normandy and uh let's get him on the
podcast by the way I'll tell you what
that'll be a 12 hour he won't shut up
just give him Olive Garden and he'll
just keep talking he'll go but but my
grandfather would would uh my mom it's
my mom's dad and he had she had like 13
brothers and sisters
and I would get these stories at an age
that you probably shouldn't be talented
I remember there was a time I went
Target uh shooting with my dad I had a
22 rifle and I was he was like David
your grouping is good but let's try to
get it Center and I'm like because it
was low right and he's like why are you
shooting you know let's get it in the
middle
and I'm like but that's where the
femoral artery is it's by the hip bone
and Granddad says she's like listen no
more stories about where the bleeders
are you know that's not what we want but
but he would tell me these stories of of
combat
that were almost
um they were filtered they were
Victorian in the sense that there was no
better no nobility
but there was always this
contrast of don't ever think the enemy
is just Nazis are horrible Imperial
Japanese we're the worst people in the
world but they're human beings
and there's something that happens to
you
when you go to war that you'll never
ever look at life the same
but it wasn't as if it was a warning of
don't do this it was you can't ever
appreciate anything unless you're in
that environment with other people doing
something together against evil
so you know when I went to Kosovo and K4
Bravo no offense to the Clinton
Administration I didn't really find evil
you know that we didn't interrupt you
know ethnic cleansing we found the
ethnic cleansing we weren't a kinetic
Force standing up against milosevic or
the you know the the Greek Orthodox
against the uh ethnic albanians it was
just kind of like we're here we're just
hanging out
Iraq was
you know again it was I saw
evil I I saw it I saw people that wanted
to hurt myself my friends
it's a you know you can be victimized by
that trauma
or you can be empowered by it and you
could say listen there can't be a bad
day ever
after that right I mean there can't be
there's nothing you can't do so so your
grandfather made that impression on you
at the at a pretty young age it would
the stories were ridiculous he's like
I'm sleeping uh you know cold day and
bestowed and uh it was a dead pig a
frozen pig and and he would tell these
stories of how he would go into these
French areas that were friendly to the
Nazis
and and he's like my guys haven't eaten
in weeks do you guys have any eggs and
they're like no eggs no nothing he's
like you're a liar and I'm like this is
a French civilian you know you're like
they've been through hell he's like
you're lying you have eggs you've been
giving eggs to the Nazis haven't you
he's like we found barrels of champagne
we found ham salted ham we feasted on
that
and I was like what's the message here
the message isn't my grandfather was
pillaging of civilians the message is
salted ham and whatever luxury you could
find was the best meal of his life
because he didn't know if his day was
going to end tomorrow and I'm 12 and I'm
thinking you know that could you imagine
not knowing what tomorrow's going to be
like and just having this opportunity
for Fellowship camaraderie and a warm
meal and you will literally do anything
just for that moment and he's at the
time he was in his 80s now he's 102. he
still thinks about that meal it doesn't
matter five star four-star he thinks
about that meal in a barn you know next
to a blown up 88. like that's incredible
to me
so you got this on one side Meanwhile
your dad is all about education want you
to how you doing in school you know I
was my parents uh raised me right I had
a great school great teachers everything
was good this wasn't I went to college
and I I was checking the box and I
remember in my senior year I was in a
library and I was I was a goofball and I
was just trying to be funny and and be
popular and and the little TV on the
little you know roller cart TV they
plugged it in it was October 93 and I'm
watching Bill Cleveland
get dragged to the streets of Somalia
and I felt like a complete fraud
I've never felt like this it was an uh
the closest I've come to an out about
experience where I thought
I I we can't be funny we can't laugh
this is an American who dedicated his
life to protecting us and he's being
dragged by a truck and you know ripped
apart by kids and and Mogadishu and
Black Hawk Down
and I and I remember saying a prayer
that I didn't know what life I would
live I had no idea I was going to be a
dentist if I had 12 kids one kid never
married I'm going to avenge Bill
Cleveland
that's all I wanted to do was just give
me if it was a two-week missionary trip
I'd find a way to get into the
marketplace and Mogadishu but I was
going to stack up and just take a
Polaroid and send it to the Cleveland
Family to say we got them
and and the one thing that I never
understood about soldiering was how
important
avenging losses
and how what that means for your morale
what that means for a family
and again that's another disconnect with
civilians but knowing that the person
that destroyed your life and took
something away from you that we got them
when a war became Nothing by IEDs
nothing but you never saw the enemy
you're listening to music and you
disappear in the midst
in a war where you had the chance to see
the enemy fix them
and they're now afraid of you
that's why we fought and Fallujah ramadi
muktadaya bakuba those areas mosul they
gave us the opportunity to actually
fight back when so many of the losses in
Iraq at that point were
you know ghosts basically
um I want to get to the point where you
get done with high school but there was
a part of this book that I promised
myself had to be read so that everyone
could hear it
here we go
when I was 17 in the summer of my junior
year my my dad started a group for teens
whose mission was to wait until marriage
to have sex
the Fourth of July was the biggest event
in our small town
our population of 750 would balloon to 3
000 one afternoon the fireworks the
parades the chicken barbecue
the macrame plant hangers made this the
go-to location in Orleans County
inevitably there was going to be a float
for his new organization
my father came to me and explained how
difficult it was to get older kids to
join his group and this is group like I
said there's a group for people that are
going to stay virgins until they're
married
I was stunned how richly bizarre it was
that teenagers didn't want to ride
downtown declaring to all their peers
they were virgins and not open for
business
with a sober face and piercing eyes he
asked me David
I would like you to be the king of our
virgin float
not having read the bylaws of the group
to see if this sort of nepotism was
allowed it was quickly revealed that
this was an acceptable policy there was
no disqualification in being related to
an officer of the group and naming me
the king of all virgins
without a proper Vote or at least having
a board meeting
I was a good kid shy not exactly a
ladies man and in fact a real bona fide
virgin at 17.
I just really didn't want to be on a
float being pulled by a John Deere
tractor in my hometown declaring to my
entire community that my prom night
didn't end like I told all my friends
I was introduced to my queen
she was 12 years old
every other kid on the float ranged from
the ages of nine to a very mature 13 but
I love my father I could not let him
down
people like you and if people like you
and if they see you are waiting maybe
they will wait too he said to me
dad you are far overestimating my
ability to influence my peer group no
one cares this is humiliating
I rode on the float on a throne of
Chastity while girls who hadn't even
reached puberty tossed Tootsie Rolls to
my Laughing peers I wore that Crown I
wore that sash that read I don't until I
do
that was the most emasculating 25 minute
tractor ride of my life when the parade
ended my dad came up to me and said
something I'd never forgotten David that
was a very difficult thing I asked you
to do remember this if you live your
life doing things that are difficult but
that are right
you'll find the strength to do tougher
things when they count the most my hero
asked me to do it and I wouldn't have
changed a thing
because it made my father proud
I know you're a courageous guy that was
rough I can tell you when I was 17 years
old that wouldn't be happening for me I
would have ran away I think
uh you know I I just it to me it was
always obligation was uh you know your
your father
was your father and I love my dad and
there were times that you know when you
become a father you think oh I don't
know if I would have done that I don't
know if that lesson works out well today
but it it you know the toughest thing
I've ever had to do in my life was love
my Army when my Army treated me like
garbage
and and there's nothing more difficult
than that is to love your branch love
your chain of command when there's no
reason to do it
and that relationship with my officers
was very much like
my relationship with my father this is
these are the rules that you grow where
you're planted no one picked their unit
very few people get a chance to pick
their people and when they do it's
different but here I am and these are my
people and they're going to tell me
what's going and I'm gonna I'm gonna
knock it out
I'm gonna find something because I would
fear
the enemy can kill you the enemy can
hurt you the enemy can take your
eyesight and your body parts
but the shame of letting down someone
that was an officer in charge of me or a
senior NCO was far greater than what the
enemy I was more afraid of what they
could do to me than what the enemy could
do and it sounds stupid to say out loud
in your 40s
but I felt the same way about my dad I
mean I I this man was he was five foot
three
never told me to lie and yet I'd look at
his driver's license from New York state
I'm like it says five nine you're not
five nine what's going on here but but
that was my dad and I loved him and and
that was a ridiculous request
a ridiculous request uh but uh making
him proud was everything to me
do you play sports in high school yeah
what'd you play uh so we're a real small
school we didn't have football so we
were soccer which is very difficult to
get motivated for but uh we did the
basketball soccer baseball right those
are my three and then you say you end up
going to college yeah and what are you
planning when you go to college what
year is it what year did you graduate 94
94 uh went to college started off in New
Hampshire and again I want pre-med uh
biochemistry uh was the major but it was
the pre-med uh and then
I had no you know really sheltered in a
really small area and so I wanted to
meet you know uh girls I wanted to be
popular and so I figured all the guys I
met in the theater program just weren't
that interested in women it was really
strange to me and so I figured I'll uh
I'll see if maybe I could be like a
theater Miner and just kind of hang out
in this crowd
and uh I had no real ability to do
anything and and what's shocking that
they didn't care like nobody wanted to
see me dance or sing or even attempt to
act they were just like you want to be
in this group go ahead I'm like this is
like a degree don't you need to have
some semblance it was just like walking
around everyone like everyone just was
like go no put a turtleneck on you're a
part of the club
and you're going to spend money to get a
degree in something and we don't even
care if you're even good at it and it
really because even the science guys
cared I mean you had at least pass and
do well no one gave a damn about you
know the fact that I couldn't do
anything listen were you in plays or
something I mean you you have to be in
everything but it doesn't mean you're
good at it you know what I mean like you
have to be involved but it's and then
like that what you're graded on your
effort
like you're graded on how much you smile
like how this is confusing to you today
just like this is like I don't I don't
get it and so you wonder why there's so
many delusional people going to LA in
New York and it's because you know for
four years they're like you are really
trying hard I'm like well listen how can
I work can I get a job
we have a law a federal law on a credit
card that says if you pay the minimum
in 20 years is what you're going to pay
but you can walk into a college today
and get a degree in Shakespeare
Shakespeare on stage and no one has an
obligation to be like that's not a real
job by the way you're never gonna make
money what are you gonna make at the end
of 30 nothing how do you do a profit and
loss there were a lot of guys in theater
departments and film that just
you know what is Andy Warhol 15 hours of
a guy sleeping it's art
all right you know maybe you could be
like Andy Warhol you know so yeah it
didn't uh it didn't work so how long how
long did you stay in college for I
stayed in for the the remainder it was
my senior year of college second
semester and I had a professor tell me
uh and so I was getting more and more
rebellious in in the idea of I felt like
my friends were in the Army my friends
were doing cool things and I just was
like
I'm doing this for my father I'm doing
this for my mom I'm doing this for
everyone and then these professors were
just I'm like what have you done in
theater what have you done have you ever
been in a movie or written a movie or
anything and the guy's like
you leave this school you'll come back
with your tail between your legs and I
was like
and do what teach like do I have an
opportunity like what what am I gonna do
if I leave here I what have you like how
are you teaching listen I go to the
range someone I it's a guy who really
know how to shoot a machine gun teaching
me how to shoot a machine gun it's not
some guy who's like I have this crazy
dream about an 84 millimeter rocket let
me give you a lesson on it they actually
are subject matter experts I didn't
understand why these people were
professors and why they were doing and
so I I just my last year I just said I
don't I don't want to do this anymore I
want to leave I want to go and and you
know maybe I'll write a screenplay or
maybe I'll write a book or maybe I'll do
something to show that I don't need this
degree my brothers all had it my
brothers all did it it was like a check
the box this I'm serious about I went
into debt that's how serious I am about
being an adult like if you don't take me
seriously I got a piece of paper that
says I'm serious you know this is real I
put money into it I wasted time
I'm a real an adult I was like no I
don't I don't want to do that I want to
do something that you don't think is
intellectual but I think it's
intellectual
and I can't think of anything every time
I watch it I'm a big Buffalo Bills fan
every time I watch football in the
trenches I'd go to war with that guy
it's a war is always a metaphor
there just wasn't a war
so I came home from college One Summer
and we had a home invasion
now these two drug addicts broke into my
parents house
and I was like this is my time this is
my fun this is what I've lived my whole
life for I grabbed uh Remington shotgun
and I loaded it up
and I was I'm gonna shoot these guys
they're shirtless
shirtless guys just running around the
house cutting wires off of TVs throwing
them into their car moving in and out
I had a Rottweiler at the time I put the
Rottweiler in the garage because I was
afraid the Rottweiler would bite him
and I didn't want like there to be a
liability issue like maybe they were my
parents friends maybe it was a
misunderstanding but I was shook I was
scared and I grabbed this shotgun I
loaded it up I felt it just like I had
done previously
and I brought it up the stairs and I saw
these guys my mom had had neck surgery
my dad was taking care of her they were
on the other side of the house
and I just thought
you're gonna you're gonna murder these
guys you're gonna kill these guys
and everyone's gonna have to move out of
the house
no everyone's going to look at you
differently
and what I was really doing was just
buying time
right buying time for them to do
something and run away or and they
didn't and they looked at me with like
zero fear
and that hurt but that was that's you
know 3 A.M inventory no one saw that
but then my dad came out after these
guys roll off they get arrested they go
to jail the whole trial but right after
they drove off that day my dad looked at
me and he looked at me
in a way that was just that was
emasculating having your dad look at you
and say you're 22 23. and you're not
ready for the world
that was it that was it I'm like I'm
going to summer camp of bad haircuts I'm
gonna go I'm gonna get my PhD at the
University of Fort Benny to Georgia in
human studies and I'm gonna I'm gonna
I'm never going to be
if there's a noise
anywhere I'm at any situation I'm in I'm
gonna handle it any situation I'm in and
you know you could be bigger than being
stronger than me you could have more
skills in me I'm going to tear your eyes
out or shoot you repeatedly you know
there's going to be a a series of
escalation but the reality is I'm gonna
handle it I'm gonna handle it I had no
ability to control my destiny I had no
ability to handle anything
and the Army gave me the opportunity to
at least say we're going to teach you
enough
to get your abs kicked in a fight but
we're going to teach you enough that you
can control your your destiny and I
needed that desperately but there was no
war going I was 99 you know into the
late 90s and
it was just learn how to March and do pt
and that's what I thought I needed so
infantry they told me 11 x-ray met extra
special
and so when I get there for a band I'm
like I'm an x-ray they're like I'm a
Bravo and I'm like what's that they're
like that's real infantry I'm like no
it's not they lied to you but when I
when I got when I got to Fort Benny
Georgia the first night
there were kids like crying and nervous
I I slept the best sleep I've ever had
in my life in that because I knew this
is who I was
this is where I'd be safe this I'm there
was no stress
you know these kids were like 1918 I was
like this is nothing oh what are you
worried about like this this is what
we're this is why we're here we're here
on this Earth we were born to do this
now we don't get a war that's the part
that's going to suck is we're just gonna
end up with a bumper sticker on our car
we're gonna say we're a vet and get a
free meal at Applebee's but but listen
we we we offered there was nothing for
us to do so you're that you were that
fired up like day one of boot camp I had
no idea was I wore khakis and a
button-down shirt because I wanted to
impress I wanted to impress my drill
size I was a professional and they told
me that I was going to be there for like
15 weeks and so I didn't I knew I had to
shave my head but I thought I was going
to grow back so I brought a hair dryer
right and when they shook my bag they're
like one piece of [__] brought a hair
drug I was like this is my first
challenge like do I own it
and I'm like yeah that's my hair dryer
they told me
there was a couple months here I wasn't
aware that there was a a Payday haircut
you didn't tell me that you know but but
honestly I had no idea really what I was
getting into but the more I learned I
just I looked at these drill sergeants
and I was like
these are amazing the NCO became I'm so
glad I didn't go officer honestly
because I saw these ncos and I was just
like this is everything I've always
wanted to be if I could have a son and I
could see a person shoulders back
looking you in the eye and not you know
not waiting to speak but listening
hearing what's go and if you don't know
the answer you say I don't know like
wait a minute what is this magic if you
don't know something you actually admit
that
and then you make a mistake you say I I
did that but you know what it's not
going to happen again this was like
learning a new language
a new way to this was this was true
north
nothing else is north but that this is
right this is wrong and and Own It
accountable responsible and and ready
for more to show that you're ready for
more you take whatever I'm guarding this
little drinking fountain
but you know what no one is stealing
that drinking phone I'm 10 for 10. no
fire on my Fire Guard this is this is it
was the greatest thing in the world for
me
so you go to boot camp really no factor
for you you're kind of loving it loving
it AIT is that where you go next it's
all one one station one big thing yeah
so infantry is all whatever you want and
they said I was going to be mechanized
which
you know Fort Drum Fort Hood it didn't
matter I I just wanted to do you know
what's a bunker I mean it just blew me
away and then I thought to myself wait a
minute if a bunker is this this little
thing guys hang out in it and they shoot
you what's a window well I don't know we
have a different battle drill for that
but I'm like but it's really a bunker
isn't it and they're like wow this is a
thinker we got ourselves a thinker so
now these guys are saying let me let's
explain something to you a battle drill
is like an audible you see the the
linebacker come up you see that you're
not in man coverage now you're like I
think we're just gonna react to the
contact but in that reacting to the
context a million things can happen and
you've got to decide so I'm I didn't
even fundamentally understand I want to
get you I want to get close enough to
kill you that's the game right
so in order for me to get close up you
have to stop shooting at me so I can
move
I'm like wait a minute this is making
sense now all these movies are making
sense so
I got to keep your head down so plunging
fire is different than just shooting
over your head right I wanna I don't
want to hit you necessarily do what
would be great to take everyone out and
but it's not the way it works they're
moving too they're getting away too but
if I can give you something to think
about I can get closer to you and the
closer I get the more accurate I can get
and what's cover what's concealment
hey the only thing I would give one more
class if you're going down range
fighting in Europe or Asia or the Middle
East what cars have engines in the trunk
and what cars have engines in the front
because the first day you hide behind
what you think is an engine block and
those routes come flying through it like
like a knife through butter you're like
oh those damn Germans they put in the
back you know that's the one thing I
would change but covering concealment
I I understand this right so now I I get
education we have to be educated you
have to learn
and having what these young kids have
today would I didn't have all my drill
sergeants were making up stories about
Panama okay everyone was that everyone
was at the soccer stadium every you know
Bosnia let me tell you how bad no there
was not Haiti yeah I almost jumped
almost jumped into Haiti almost did this
almost to that Gulf War
these men and women today
they got stories these drill sergeants
these leaders are like let me tell you
why you want your chin strap on let me
tell you why that sappy Plate's
important why we get low why it's
important to bring the elbows in what
controlled fire actually is what do you
want hey there's no drywall in the
Middle East
that's all concrete so when you start
shooting inside of a close quarter that
is coming back to you it's a
tic-tac-toeing around right a grenade is
great right grenade throw the grenade
and everything's over
unless you don't have ventilation now
you just threw a smoke grenade in a room
and the only people that know you're in
there is the bad guy because you don't
know where they are you've never been in
the house before and now they all know
where the door is or where you are so
that frag let's hope it was a smart frag
hey God you know all of these lessons
learned that we never had and we learned
in the actual battle
and the ability to take information at
the highest level lowest level and share
that information I've never been in an
organization on the civilian side that
shares Lessons Learned like our military
does and it's a it's a it's a combat
multiplier without a doubt yeah no doubt
about that
uh so you're learning from from the from
the I almost jumped into Panama which
God bless them you know they were ready
they wanted to jump they were ready uh
and and so what's your what's your first
Duty station then where do you end up
what do you get where do you get
assigned when you get done with boot
camp AIT you're now uh what are you an
E2 at this point an E3 an E1 so
basically but the only advice I got from
the drills the uh recruiter was you're
you're you can be a spec you can be a
specialist E4 okay you're College don't
do it oh
you gotta earn that now I didn't realize
all I had to do was basically just not
get a DUI for 12 months and it happens
automatically but that first promotion
felt like you know I was Thor I mean
like getting promoted and seeing the
increase in your you know in your pay
and like this was a big deal so E2 to E3
to private I have a rocker on my little
private Wings this was I'm telling you
it was important it was special for me
so I got um
I got a duty assignment to uh Fort Hood
Texas
and in the process of doing that my son
is born and he's born with uh a kidney
issue and so the Army basically uh is
like hey there's no infantry Duty
station that has these pediatric
nephrologists that you need you've got
one at home we're going to put you on a
compassionate reassignment
I didn't know what that was and they
were like so go be a recruiter
you got a good GT score we're going to
keep you for two years on a
compassionate reassignment until your
son is old enough to go where you need
to be uh and we'll keep you in Buffalo I
I was like you know they made up jobs
for me at a recruiting station and I
just was miserable I mean seriously
that's what they did that's what you did
that's what I did for the first uh 18
months of my Army Career I was in a
recruiting station I would have
volunteered to be a pow with that boy it
was absolutely there's no more difficult
job than being an army any recruiter
it's the everyone's disqualified it the
game should be if you finally find
someone
answering the phone
you know at the mall I mean you just
disqualified disqualified as well I mean
it's ridiculous everyone's disqualified
uh I remember one time I found a guy he
committed to the Army I brought his
packet in I had opened the door like on
like a you know one of those hoverboards
just floating through the office I'd go
to my station commander and he's like
hey this guy was born on Christmas day
and I'm like yeah people get born on
Christmas Day his name's Christopher
Kringle and I'm like that's a weird
coincidence he's like you're an idiot
you're an idiot you just talked to Santa
Claus and
again no idea that there were people out
there that would waste your time and
that
you know just you're in the with the
Corporal recruiting program where they
and then they give you an NCO Rank and
so at the time that September 11th hit
the Army obviously the military across
the poor let's move people you know get
on with your career were you in that in
there when September 11th yeah so from
99 until you know September 11th I was
in a recruiting and they said look here
three choices reclassify to another job
go back to AIT and get another job
that's near a place that the Army will
take care of the kid get out of the army
or go on what's an all others tour which
is 36 months away from dependence
and I'm like well which one gets me to
the war
and to be honest with you I love my
country I love my Army and infantry but
recruiting also will make you want to go
to war too I'll do anything to get the
hell out of that oven they're like
Germany uh and I'm like Germany what is
it the big red one and I'm like I've
seen the movie like I love the big I
want to be in the Big Red One
Afghanistan are they going to
Afghanistan they're like oh no no no
Big Red One hasn't done anything since
1996 we you are only in charge of the
very dangerous battleground of Kosovo
and I was like Coast was a war right and
they're like technically
technically it's a war I mean you're not
going to get combat paid but you get
like combat almost pay you know what I
mean it could be
so that was our big fight we were
peacekeepers forward deployed Germany
peacekeepers and the Big Red One really
hadn't been the big red one uh for a
long time since the gulf and even the
Gulf War we were the we were kind of
like the the fake barn door that Saddam
chased you know in the Gulf War so it
wasn't the Vietnam Big Red One or the
the World War II Big Red One or
obviously the first world war it was the
peacetime Peacekeeper you know stuff uh
and so uh I said sign me up I want to do
it I want to do anything that isn't
recruiting and that's what you did so
you go over there yeah and how did you
enjoy your time in Kosovo well it was a
six-month tour that became a nine month
tour and no offense to the Minnesota
National Guard but I don't think you got
to relieved by the Minnesota National
Guard did you you always know if if uh
listen National Guard units are
incredible and they're awesome but when
you know a group that had never ever we
got relieved by a National Guard unit
that was calling like their sergeant
major Phil and like I was like what it
was a totally different world I never
experienced it before so we were we just
felt like we were in the back water
everyone was getting Afghanistan but my
units in the second infantry uh two two
infantry uh the ramrods and first ID and
Alpha Company Captain Walter Captain
Sims together uh Colonel Newell sarmage
falkenberg Serge Bond these guys all
decided to take that nine months ago so
three months extended and make it the
practice for Co for Iraq
and I got to tell you what that saved so
many lives because not only were we
together for two years right 15 hour
patrols of watching dogs mate you know
in Kosovo nothing happening begging for
someone I mean nothing was going on but
after that 15 hours you're in the snow
and you're training for the debt for the
desert you're not going to wear that
baklava you're not going to wear those
boots get in your desert uniform get out
there in the snow and let's train for
Iraq in Kosovo we got all the rounds we
wanted whatever we wanted Claymore never
seen a clay Morrison's basic you know
whatever we wanted we had access to and
we blew up pallets and grenades Palace
of C4 we were ready for combat because
of Kosovo had Kosovo not happened we
wouldn't have got that training so we
graduated to a level that on day one we
could we could fight and that's why we
were successful and then you guys end up
getting word that you're going to go to
Iraq finally incos well we're told we're
in the in the shoot so it got real
serious uh we literally would we went
our nine months I think we refitted for
60 days but that's like leave and
re-qualifying and then right back to uh
to the fight so by the Fall we were in
Germany and then we were three months
maybe I think is what we had we went
right to Kuwait and got ready for Iraq
I'm going to take you to the book here
when the Army deployed the ramrods to
Iraq in February 2004 we had a basic
idea of where it would be going inside
the country we ended up at fob Normandy
which by the way I got corrected by uh
one of my Vietnam veteran friends that
they say he's like it's fob so I don't
know I've said fob the whole time so
there's been a transition tilt and the
saw guys from Vietnam we we say fob now
so fob Normandy in diala province
a section of Iraq between Baghdad and
the Iranian border are area of
operations included mooc what is it
a size a mid-sized city of about 150 000
fits one of your guys was wounded in an
urban fire fight in April 2004 only a
couple months after we arrived in
theater
to the north of the city lay open rugged
terrain when Americans think of Iraq war
the images conjured up are the street
scenes in Baghdad or the flat expanse of
open desert in the western part of the
country but our AO looked more like
Vietnam in 1968.
thick Palm Groves grew in low spaces
between gentle sloping Hills there were
canals and rivers that the local farmers
had harnessed to turn the land so
Bountiful that they'd become known as
the Bread Basket of Iraq among the heavy
vegetation and irrigated Fields small
communities straddled the roads leading
out they were ramshackle
impoverished places but seated among
them were wealthy sunnis connected to
Saddam Hussein's once uh ascendant bath
party below these Elites the vast
majority of the population were Shia
Muslims with strong ties to neighboring
Iran after the American invasion in 2003
a kernel of resistance formed to the
American occupation in one of these
rural towns called sinsil
in the early stages of the Insurgency
there were actually only a few locals
involved who forged ties within Iran to
secure important weapons explosives and
ammunition the Palm grows around sinsil
and its sister Village became ideal
places to cash those supplies when the
ramrods first arrived at Normandy the
fourth infantry division had been
battling this growing threat they had
identified six men as the leaders in the
Insurgency known as the sinsil 6. the
fourth ID's intelligence guys to put
their faces up on a wall map and then
connected them to various known hideouts
and accomplices with different colored
yarn the first time I saw their bad guy
map it reminded me of a Hollywood
stalker's lair
with sin still being the Nexus of the
insurgency's leadership it became one of
the most important sectors in Rao
Captain Sims frequently took us out
there to meet the locals drink tea with
their leaders and discuss the needs of
their communities classic
counter-insurgency when their hearts and
Minds stuff that came straight from the
Vietnam Playbook within 30 days of our
arrival the sinsil 6 had grown to the
sunsil 10. we tracked down and killed
two of the original members when the
Intel learned There Were Three Brothers
Moving between Syria and stencil to
arrange another flow of weapons to that
area they ended up on a young crossed
wall map too one of our special
operation teams located trapped and
killed one of the brothers the other two
escaped each time we thought we'd deal
with this we dealt with the sin cell a
crippling blow they emerged stronger
with even more support from the local
population it was like fighting a
contagious virus for every patient we
treated three more infections would crop
up the sinsil 10 gluta sin Sil 20 and
then 30 after that we just lost track as
a wave of recruits organizers and
well-trained Iranian operatives flooded
into the breadbasket that spring the
Insurgency erupted all over the country
between the first Shia Uprising that
displaced the Sunni ruling class
Rebellion nearly every Coalition unit
was inundated with insurgents planted
IEDs planning IEDs in their operational
area executing ambushes and launching
attacks at Key targets as the weeks wore
on our trips to sin Sil turned into a
kinetic version of Groundhog Day we'd go
out so Captain Sims could continue to
try to develop relationships with the
local Iraqi power base while he was
talking to them drinking tea the
insurgents would be alerted to our
presence and establish ambushes for us
so that just kind of takes a paints a
picture of what you guys rolled into
yeah a fourth infantry division you know
at the you know so we started to see the
extensions you had a stop loss that was
going on when Iraq kicked off and a lot
of people thought they were out of the
military and they were kept in and then
you had the first real extensions I
think it was karbala it was the first
Armored Division that did they were
supposed to do nine months everyone's
gonna do nine months and then it became
a year and then a year became 15. and
there were units that were doing 18 and
so we didn't really have with with the
kinetic Tempo that was going on
Afghanistan Iraq how are we going to
replace these units are they doing
sustainment
um you know
stabilization operations or are these
still kinetic you know I didn't we
didn't we were told don't you're not
getting a CIB you're not going to get a
commentative Tribune's badge and you're
not going to get a combat they told you
that when you got to iraction 2004. the
mission accomplished uh the war was over
you had to be engaged by the enemy that
kept changing what engagement was so
check this out so you got there in
February why I was there as well I was
wrapping up my first deployment so I got
there in 2003 I was in Baghdad and in
April of 2004 so just after you arrived
we went my task unit my is actually just
a platoon it's my platoon we went and we
captured
one of solder's top lieutenants down in
najaf yeah we were there okay so when we
did that
it it ignited everything in April of 04
in April so the big fight was supposed
to be in April of 04. fob Duke
which is the big fob that we created in
April of 04 where was it uh right
outside of najaf okay that is named
after my Brigade where the Duke Brigade
third Brigade First ID that was J I've
never so you talk about the terrain you
know a lot of vegetation uh humidity
najaf was straight up the oil bubbling I
mean it is just nothing but sand and uh
the the biggest cemetery in the world is
in najaf and after August of 04
they added a couple kilometers if I'm
not mistaken that was a horrible muktano
solder was this toothless self-defined
cleric you didn't have the street credit
to be a real cleric
but his dad ran that mahadi militia uh
solder City in Baghdad these mahati
militia guys it was weird to see the
gestation of the Insurgency the mahani
militia knew enough to get killed they
really were not they were wearing
uniforms that were like gold and black
they didn't really have a whole lot of
tactics when the Iranians started to
bring the Coots forces in Iranian
revolutionary guard got a whole
different their their indirect fire much
more accurate the the RPG 7 as opposed
to the five uh the way they were trying
to go after vehicles and tracks and the
efps and the IEDs but the other thing
was when we started to make Iraq the
Insurgent All-Star team yeah and
bringing in these boys from chechnya I
mean when you would go through Fallujah
and pick up passports and be like France
Italy
chechnya you know Bosnia there was a guy
in Dearborn Michigan
can you imagine that you were so
hell-bent that you decided to go to Iraq
I mean what but everyone from all over
the world najaftha was the first time
our unit was able to show what I
shouldn't say our unit armored first Cav
fourth ID before us third ID before us
but the first Infantry Division in that
oif one to two
showed that tanks
and Bradley Fighting Vehicles belonged
in an urban fight no one was using the
Abrams in the city no one thought what's
a Bradley Fighting Vehicle
the thing about a good and again all
infantrymen think the mechanized are
lazy and fat and they just want to eat
and watch TV and we hate the tankers and
Garrison we're beating up the tankers
more than we're training every you know
infantry hates tankers after Iraq
infantrymen and tankers are the best of
friends because if you can support that
again so many units they they take their
platform their support by Firebase
it's a it's a five-ton truck with a 50
cal it drops you off and it goes home
you carry that support by Firebase with
you you work in concert with the
Bradleys I'm providing security for you
you're blowing pieces into you know fun
sized pieces for the enemy that 25
millimeter high explosive Auto Cannon is
one of the greatest gifts the Pentagon
gods have ever given us and when you
wanna I don't need a clear house if I
can have a gun or put two he rounds in a
room
it's over we're feeling pretty good
about it we're we're we're we like
DraftKings has us you know as the
favorite yeah what made me think of that
is I could see your leadership telling
you in what would it be
in February or maybe even January of
2004 like hey you're not going to get
Combat Action right you know you're
gonna go it's gonna be but I guarantee
by April when that when when they when
this when the Modi militia militia went
berserk right you're you're gonna get
that Combat Action whether you like it
or not it's coming because they went I
mean it was like a 180 degree turn we
were I mean the I was up at Baghdad we
went down into Joff to grab this guy
yakubi who was one of his lieutenants
and we brought him back and by the time
we got back
you know the for us it was another
mission now we had been targeting solder
for a long time but they wouldn't let us
do it they finally said you know what
let's see what will happen let's see
what will happen if we grab one of his
guys so they sent us to go do that
it was total Mayhem I actually felt bad
I felt horrible because the conventional
forces got caught off guard they weren't
ready for it and like in Sauder City
went totally insane a lot of casualties
there and I remember the the Baghdad
where I was we we'd get an occasional
mortar in there all of a sudden the
front Gates getting attacked I mean it
was on it was a radical change that
happened when when after that mission
and it really fueled the Insurgency
there's a couple of videos we were
getting ready to go to najaf we saw I
think the polls uh the Polish Army was
at like a camp kilo which was right
outside of the city so the Easter
Uprising in April of 04 was the
insurgents attempt to cut Baghdad off
and yet Highway 5 which went from the
east in diala all the way across Baghdad
and you had Fallujah which was always
considered to be like the wild west of
Iraq even when Saddam was in power
and and they built their homes like the
Shia population vast majority of Iraqis
were Shia
Saddam had the Baptist party which was
Sunni but was weird about Iraq's culture
as opposed to any other Middle Eastern
countries that Saddam was able to make
pan-arabism
in the war against Iran he convinced
half of the country to die for Iraq the
flag
and so when he puts inshallah on the
this is like everyone was pro-iraq in
that war with Iran which was very bloody
and costly to the people over there and
so by the time you're building real
estate if you're in a Shia area you are
very insecure and you're building your
homes very thick walls you've got gun
slits on all I mean you're ready for any
minute that government's going to roll
up and take your house so you're it's
like Siege Warfare in a neighborhood
everyone is ready for what's going on I
mean the glass that was embedded in the
concrete when you crawled over the walls
I mean it was a very insecure culture
but najaf was that Easter Uprising if
you go to Arlington Cemetery in section
60 April 8th and 9th you will see
casualties from ramadi Fallujah
diala Province bakuba solder City mosul
that's really when everything started
was in that and that one week in April
from the Marines dealing with the
Vigilant resolve and what they tried to
do in ramadi and Fallujah they had to be
basically I mean they were why they were
successful they took the but you had Al
Jazeera and El Arabia TV and and the
idea of civilians everything became a PR
war and it started with unfortunately
with Abu
and and that horrific story uh where you
had a National Guard unit
abusing prisoners yeah and it just put
fuel on the fire what a what a freaking
horrible uh
IO loss for America with these
Knuckleheads right uh now you you you
remember the contractors the Blackwater
contractors March
um that happens where are you when that
happens
so first infantry division's first
brigade was brought in April of 04 for
the Fallujah fight with the Marines uh
and again ambar was you know 82nd
Airborne hands off in bar province in
April of 04. and the Marines take over
ambar
there's really no I'm the army that is
allowed they're there blocking positions
support it's not a it's not an army
Mission anymore when ambar is run by the
Marine Corps we've got the rest of the
country and there's a whole lot to do by
the way but all the attention is on the
I used to love that in 06 when I went to
ramadi when you were out there it was
you couldn't say Amber I promise you had
to say restive and bar Province the rest
of anbar Province everything's like
Amber Province like they're eight foot
Goliath they're different people they're
so tough
but ambar really is the first Domino to
fall uh with with the pacification of
you know when the Insurgency starts to
really fall back it's the sons of ambar
that area though uh in 04
the first ID's first brigade comes in to
help in Vigilant resolve which is April
and then they basically lose that
Fallujah Brigade they pull out of the
city and that was a policy too like just
catapult the dead cow over the wall let
them get sick and die we'll wait until
April yeah but because we had ninja and
we were able to pick up and move uh that
guy fits Colin Fitz was my peer he was
the first quad leader he got shot in
April 8th of 04 in book to die that kid
got shot by three different weapon
systems and what I used to love is when
a new guy would show up I'd be like
the AK-74 is a different ballistic let
me show you on his elbow and he got hit
by the 762 by three nine the PKM which
is the the bigger uh 762 by what five
one fifty five four fifty four and what
the 74 is what a five four five I think
so yeah yeah so that was a the baby yeah
but all three so we were getting popped
uh with and we we took out I think a
over two day period we took out 160. and
and they saw that that Bradley Fighting
Vehicle was not to play with it was not
to play with and coax
um 25 got into Joff show that we can
work well with marines that puts a pin
on a board where someone says Hey I want
to take Fallujah how are we going to do
it give me those Army uh 2-7 from armor
first cab and 2-2 and 163 from first ID
and so we were just there to help out
the Marines in a block you know One Wing
and ended up being you know something a
little bit bigger than that but uh
that's how we we got our our street cred
you got an interesting Exchange in here
in the book uh that I was very very
stoked to see uh you say that's the map
board hung on otherwise jailhouse bare
walls right beside my cot and the
homemade crucifix that held my helmet
and body armor no photos of home near my
space just the board with three maps of
our area of operations one depicting the
road Net One depicting the political uh
demographics and one topographic
surrounding them with the latest
satellite and overhead images that
Lieutenant Colonel Newell's Intel shop
had pushed down to us
hackworth says we need to outmooge the
mooge
the hell does that mean
work harder stay out longer be ferocious
never let them outwork us dig in
sometimes take The High Ground when
possible grab rooftops without turning
the lights on in a house never do the
same thing twice
I wish I'd never given you that damn
book
Lieutenant Colonel David hackworth had
been a staff guy in Vietnam writing
counter Insurgency manuals in the
Pentagon when he was ordered to put his
theories into practice he was sent to
Southeast Asia and given command to the
worst Battalion in theater he
transformed it into a Viet Cong
threshing machine known as the hardcore
recondos
they damage the enemy every time they
left the wire Fitz had given me
hackworth's memory Memoir steal my
soldiers Hearts before we left Vilseck
which is where you were in Germany
I read it and absorbed its lessons then
one day at Normandy I sent him a random
Fanboy email through his publisher and
agent
so you sent an email to hackworts you
know publisher
he responded he was in Mexico dying of
bladder cancer without violating
operational security I sketched out our
situation and asked what he would do he
offered excellent advice like a tactical
Dear Abby
we corresponded often
and this is what he wrote you never let
them outwork you and you will never be
ambushed again your men will [__] they
will hate you but in 20 years when you
are all older they will realize how much
they appreciated the attention you paid
to the details of War work harder do
your best to leave enemy where you
killed him if your command makes you
police up the dead make him bleed enough
for his buddies to know what happened
there send the message mess with us and
get wrecked they shall fear our ferocity
uh I don't know if you know but this
book right here
about face I ended up writing the
forward for the new release of that book
oh it's classic yeah I'm a huge and so
the fact that he responded yeah it was I
wish that was it would have been smart
enough to email my wife and and and and
his ability to because his whole thing
in Vietnam and again Vietnam we didn't
invent counter Insurgency obviously
that's what we're doing Vietnam out
moves the Moose is what he would say
because he was always talking about out
Kong the you know out enemy and out yeah
the G yeah exactly
and uh I was uh out gorilla the gorilla
and so you know they're disciplined
we're more disciplined but if you you
know again we were doing this thing
where I would Dismount out of a Bradley
and I would see an ID
and I'm like well we dismounted because
they saw the tracks there
so we're not just like they do with the
Blackhawks fake land fake land we're
gonna do that with the Brads you know
Dismount left ramp goes down no one gets
out we drive around for another couple
kilometers Dismount more no one gets out
sometimes we stay in the Bradley
sometimes we leave on the first the
third the fourth whatever never ever
egress the the you know leave the
battlefield the same spot that you
dismounted and you would walk up on
these guys and and the feeling you get
after you know you're cold I mean people
talk it's 50 degrees what was 120 during
the day I mean that's a huge drop in
temperature and you're cold and you're
miserable and even though the smokers
couldn't smoke we wouldn't let the
dippers dip you know everyone's gonna
suck together but when you get you know
you when you get the enemy and you knock
them cold and they don't even see you
coming there is Christmas day is a
beautiful day that we all love and get
excited about but when you can shoot a
terrorist that doesn't know you're there
it is the greatest feeling in the
universe to pop a guy who's like loading
a fuse on an RPG that is the greatest
experience in the world you're going to
try to hurt us kill us and you don't
even know we're there
that was I took I took the counter IED
counter Ambush missions
they were the most important part of my
life and I I was just absolutely almost
to a point where you know it was a
little bit of obsessed with compulsive
about hey the tankers got got hit over
here they were using propane and
bouncing a propane tank up to hit these
guys at Chef chess definitely
um there would be uh Mobility kills uh
but they would wait uh you would see a a
van with a bunch of camera equipment uh
we're doing a wedding
I want to see the video I don't think
you're doing a wedding a casket you want
to talk about the big
I remember the day that I pulled my my
testicles out metaphorically it was the
most Brazen thing I've ever done in my
life they didn't ever want us to
interact you know you're having a
funeral a wedding
women are respected respect the culture
it was the time I asked someone to open
up a casket
and that took as because I'm telling you
that could have been the end right there
but it just it didn't seem right it
didn't seem right what was in it
oh body unfortunately I I guessed wrong
on that one but but I I was I was
thinking this is where I carry munitions
yeah I would I would do a fake funeral I
do because they'd show up at the grave
yeah in the job you saw this in the
cemetery all the time you know are you
burying a body you know but you had to
think like that and you're gonna be
wrong and you're gonna you're gonna make
a mistake but your guys are not thinking
like that and and we had to think
outside of the box to be able to to
fight the enemy the way we had to but I
I guess wrong
on that one but I there wasn't a wedding
I got the wedding vote right they were
filming us at checkpoints I got that
right uh you mentioned Fitz you talk
about fits here I remember watching Fitz
get hit over and over again limping
dragging himself to cover still shooting
as he moved when he went down I thought
he was dying it was like a tectonic
shift seeing him like that my world
rocked when Fitz was gone back at a
hospital somewhere safe I'd never felt
more alone
no one gave us status reports on our
wounded healthy looking guys who got
evacuated died men like Tyler Pruitt a
tanker medic whose foot was mangled by a
rocket that struck his Humvees door
we raced to the scene cleared the LZ for
a dust off they loaded him onto the
Medevac there was no sense of sudden
urgency he was a medic and treated his
own wound the morphine-induced smile and
a go kill that piece of [__] thumbs up
he was fine Pruitt's war was over my
squad found the plastic chair the
Insurgent used to Ambush them my squad
went through hell to track this guy
murder Hornets Giant Orange wasps native
to that region stung Joey Swanson more
than eight times in the face as he was
clearing out of cash this guy had had on
standby we stayed well past night time
in a dense Palm Grove soaked to the Bone
Heads pounding from dehydration just to
maintain the promise of shooting this
guy for Pruitt the vegetation was too
thick the trail dried up
two days later I was drinking a cup of
coffee in the chow hall when his platoon
Sergeant told me that he died of a blood
clot
this made no sense
I would never have given up for the
night if I knew I was tracking Pruitt's
killer I would have lived out there for
weeks I was shocked and felt selfish for
quitting
when Fitz returned to us it was a
Lazarus moment for me a Lazarus moment
for me I just assumed he would be the
same as he was before he got hit
but that pipeline those hospitals the
physical debilitation it always changes
a person I couldn't understand what he
was going through I could see his
physical pain also he knew the sound a
bullet made when it smacked into bone
every round that cracked nearby reminded
him of that possibility he knew the
agony of lead mushrooming into your
muscle fiber he blinked with every shot
expecting impact
Fitz was right
he'd seen that side of war that I had
missed the combat support hospitals the
emergency surgeries as men bled out on
the operating room tables he'd woken up
surrounded by burned limbless men and
women clinging to life as the nurses and
doctors struggled to patch them together
his war was different
that was the root of his caution when he
came back to us it wasn't that he feared
that for himself
he feared it for us
Fitz feared it for me
so there's a Next Level badass right he
gets freaking shot with three different
types of ammunition gets kazov act out
of the country
and he's still wounded I mean he's still
messed up
and when they say you know hey where do
you want to go back to in America what
do you want to do for the you know for
the rest of your recovery he says no
send me back to Iraq I want to be with
my boys
yeah and and honestly uh you know at
this point in my life I'm you know 28
these kids are 18 19. uh there's huge
cycle of life that you go through at
that age and you know with a family and
responsibilities and young kids Fitz was
uh in the Army much longer than I had
been done more new to his tactical
proficiency you know watching him
there was always this uh when you have
two Dismount squads it's always a race
to the objective who gets there first
you know you don't want to be the
support elephant it's the worst you know
your local support and and in training
he they you know he was the guy the big
personality the senior squad leader and
every every you know uh rotation we did
his unit was the always the assault unit
and I second there and then I'd be in
the back of it I'd move my position in
the Bradley in the combo I want to be in
the back they're going to hit the back
they hit the front I never we never got
any action
and so when when I learned from him
though was his ability
to
um the elevation on an urban Battlefield
you know we talk about little round top
and Gettysburg that you're not going to
get that in the desert scape you're not
going to get that in the Middle East so
we're going to use our buildings but
we're also going to be careful not to
just go through the front door every
time right if we can go roof to roof
we'll try that uh but we can also find
ways that if I've got a outer cord on
inner cordon and I'm around a building
if I can have someone from the outside
just clear two corners
I could tell that guy coming through the
door worry about Corner three and four
one and two is good No One's Gonna Be
Right No One's Gonna Be Your left focus
on what's important uh also I was
obsessed with booby traps uh platter
charges uh doors that would blow up
grenades on a handle and he's like
listen
we had no time for that it's either
gonna happen or it's not gonna happen
I'm like [__] we just heard about a
special Forest unit that just had a
building contained ID they lost everyone
he's like you tell these 18 year old
kids that there are wires out there that
they're going to trip over they're going
to think about those wires the saw
Gunners aren't going to be looking
forward We're Not Gonna I would I would
go to the classes that Delta Force and
special forces would train they take
like two ncos per company and I guys
like you that are just you know hockey
helmets and they're talking about and
and they'd be like let's talk about this
rationally and you always had like one
intellect and one just like giant you
know he has like eight heads on his
bicep and he's just there and the
intellect guy would be like think about
this what's the easiest way to move
through a building and they put the
Flyers up right they would send someone
forward that's what Elite people do
small unit Elite folks that have the
training will do that we're not Elite
right we're not going you go into a
house and find a cookbook and leave one
guy is a bullet in his head there's a
family of seven they don't even know
Dad's dead and the cookbook is missing
that's what you do we don't do that
we're high intensity Know Your Role know
your lane know your skill level and
master it just Master what you do we
have to strong wall we have to have one
firewall keep all of our fire contained
and you know what if it takes a break a
20 you know do I I remember the first
time I got in a house fight
way before and thank God our Crescendo
to violence was graduated because if we
would have gone to Fallujah it would
have been over we had engaged At Close
Quarters we had taken targets out in
buildings and every single time to be a
new twist and we learned from those
twists and it allowed us to mature so by
the end of the rotation when Fallujah
happened we were ready but I remember my
uh my team leader took a shot uh saw
Gunner took a shot and I was saying I
was still giving the hand of our signal
right like clear clear clear like bro
you just dropped a guy you know
they know you're here you know after you
shot the the guy in the living room I
think the guy upstairs is aware maybe
the Americans are here you know there's
no point in Whispering there's no point
in you know uh the old days uh uh you
know a rolling tee in a hallway or you'd
see a couch or a refrigerator and it'd
be like okay I'm gonna open the one two
like opening the refrigerator door like
that you know what I mean this is what
they trade this is what they taught it's
all horseshit put a round through it
yeah put around through the couch put
round through the curtain don't even
bother with the crazy the other thing
was I found in a
in them they were Italian toe poppers I
never even seen a landmine in my life in
fact I thought they were RPG fins I
really thought someone had buried like
like a bunch of cigarettes in an ashtray
they just put RPG fins and there's wires
connecting them and I'm like
oh my God oh my God what do I do what I
do you know and so I'm going through
like at the range everyone turn off
their Electronics probe their way back
and I look and everyone's gone everyone
got out of the the danger I was still
there and I'm trying to get underneath
one of the mines and put some C4 down
there and I look over and there's Fitz
Fitz wasn't even near me he got to me
here's a guy that wants to be in a
Minefield with me only to tell me as two
you know ncos
that electronic stuff is [__] he
said listen man I love you I love what
you're doing you're by the book but but
listen we're not getting an eib here
this is no expert no one's watching us
who gives a [__] you know what you do
with Minefield avoid it get the hell out
of it and avoid it and then he sat me
down he's like obstacles why do you put
an obstacle out there I'm like well
you're watching it he's like yes you're
gonna I'm gonna put an obstacle down
because I'm gonna OverWatch the obstacle
so what does that tell us tell someone's
here someone wants us to go through that
now now let's start to box around these
open objectives let's think and and use
what we're learning that's what he did
he gave me like that right seat ride
every day and when he left
I'm just like I'm now I'm the guy and I
don't know what the hell I mean you know
I I didn't I I was learning a lot too
and how long was he gone for uh he so he
got hurt in April came back in August
so that's a you know a a pretty long I
mean that was a big chunk but
when he came back I thought we were
going to be the
you know Flying Eagles again I thought
we were going to be like a you know the
road warrior tag team and it was
noticeably different it wasn't that he
was afraid he was in the fight all the
time but it was like let's be smarter
about this
you know there's no need to you know I
would I love taking the Bradley and
bashing it through a building it was one
of my favorite things to do I mean look
we're gonna and he's like what happens
if we lose that Bradley and I'm like we
fix it he's like okay in three weeks
when you get the parts I just lost to
Bradley now guess what that's one less
six guys and I don't have that Firepower
we treat that thing with respect you're
not bashing it through anything I was
like all right all heartbroken over here
yeah I'm like well what am I supposed to
do like what so so we started to realize
that the guys laying IEDs didn't know
the people paying them
and the guys wiring it didn't know the
people laying it down so why don't we
start digging holes why don't we start
putting IEDs down why don't we intercept
this machine
the only difference was I wanted to Kill
the Bad Guy and Captain Sims wanted
Intel for Colonel Newell and the S2
shops and that's the part that broke my
brain because I thought we were going to
win the war by killing
and that's not necessarily the way you
win an Insurgency yeah so that's a a
point in the book that you talk about is
your differences with Captain Sims and
how you guys are reconciling those
differences you know he was of the Mind
hey we need to form relationships with
the local populace we need to learn from
them we need to support them we need to
keep them safe
you were like hey we need to kill all
these men kill all these bad guys and
you guys got some tension over that yeah
I mean if you could randomly go through
a Marketplace and you know every one of
these dead guys is on our bolo list well
isn't that something it could be that we
they'll always tell you like well two
percent of the population those are the
[__] the rest of them are good
people it's a city of 500 000 people
yeah it's a lot of [__] two percent
of that's a crazy disproportion amount
of [__] living in a zip code so he
was right and and I think history proved
that I think that the uh the
counterinsurgency model The Surge
occupy that the fob is one thing but the
Cobb was a very successful way to say
look we're not just gonna engage in a
fight and leave we're gonna live here
we're gonna stay here we're gonna own
the violence and only use the violence
when it's when it's necessary
I didn't grasp that I was still thinking
Old Testament I you know and and so all
the Iraq War in our year in Iraq
coward certainty was a huge part of what
we were doing it was very early in the
beginning of implementing that but
Fallujah was not a counter Insurgency
war ramadi was not that type of fight
now you had some incidents that really
kind of brought this two ahead a couple
incidents that really brought this to a
head with Captain Sims one was this
giant guy that comes walking down the
street you guys are in a position and
this guy comes walking some Iraqi he
comes walking down the street he's got a
freaking sword
and
talk us through talk us through what
happened there look I would always be
shocked that I would see a 12 year old
Iraqi and he looked like a six-year-old
back in the United States they wasn't a
well-fed population and you don't see
giant this guy was like six eight three
Thirty I mean he was a big the corn-fed
big dude
and he was just acting crazy now we we
knew people were doing drugs we'd gone
you know you deal with all of that you
got the the drugs whether their alcohol
policies or liberal or conservative
people are still drinking 100 people are
still doing drugs but this guy was at a
and we were getting so there was this
weird schizophrenia going on in the
military at that time at least in in the
Army where we wanted to kill the enemy
to get on a report
but you also wanted to win hearts and
minds and have a quiet area so if you're
going to have a loud fight that showed
up on some General's radar you wanted to
be a fight where
Americans were killing bad guys and not
getting killed you never wanted the
report of you know you lost 10 guys and
you killed maybe 20. you wanted to be
overwhelming so that if you got on a
general's desk it was because you guys
were badass and killing and the other
side was you wanted nothing on the
report because that meant you were doing
your job and there was nothing happening
so we found that the first Infantry
Division was
you know doing a pretty good job of
eliminating all I have too was when we
really started to see the Enemy being at
treated through Special Forces and and
other units of Marines and ambar and
everyone else
and there was this weird attaboy you're
making us proud you know Colonels are
going to get Stars based on that but
then you had the guys on the ground and
in the S shops and in the Intel and they
were like and the SF guys were like you
know
we're just going to stir the Hornet's
Nest I mean our Green Berets were like
I'm gonna go piss off about 500 people
and then we're gonna call you boys in to
just you know that's what they did they
would go into an area we took a bad guy
out we surgically removed someone but
they have like 40 friends hey you guys
go handle that and this was the
relationship
this giant it was a day when we had a
big wig fly in and was looking at the
area and they're like no contact just
this is going to be one night where
you're just gonna
New Testament you know orders are go out
there and just you know no gunfire don't
don't get in the gunfight don't give me
a fight can you do me a favor Belle no
don't don't gun fight tonight that's
where you get told and and it was legit
and it was all the way down and I had no
intention of getting a gunfight but the
guy's six foot eight I'm not you know
Grace he trained you know what I'm
saying I don't have the cauliflower ears
and I I don't have the but I learned
enough to know you know if I hit a guy
and I I pop him good or I use my helmet
um you know a butt stock something I
could I could subdue someone and I got
enough guys to zip tie them
this guy was like he was huge I mean he
was huge and it got to the point where
I had no choice I slung a Mossberg and I
had an M4 and when he was he had my
Mossberg and it was slung on my IBA so
when you know he hadn't he had positive
control over my shotgun and and we had
to put him down and and it was just uh
he was really angry and the guy had a
mental issue so he's he's a community
local guy that everyone loves and adores
he's a big gentle giant
but you know whether he was drunk or
high or both or who knows but
it destroyed the community it destroyed
our relationships with the community
and it's the weird juxtaposition of
combat where
a soldier could be honorable and protect
his people
and a bad guy could be beloved and a
really good guy too but when those paths
cross
it's what com it's why Wars you know
Wars hell yeah one of the terms I
learned from the count from my Army
counterparts and in ramadi was good shot
bad result
meaning like hey this guy whatever was
wrong he was drunk or whatever acting
crazy and it you wish it could go a
different way but here's this guy you
try and subdue him he fights now he's
fighting you now you're fighting a guy
that's six foot eight
whatever 300 pounds
now all of a sudden he has your shotgun
and there's just like this is this is
just what's gonna happen you have to
kill this guy if I walked away from it
now he's I mean how many times I've had
I'll we had kids that would give you
know numbers and four vehicles five pack
coming this way
and you know we had leaders that were
like under no circumstances will you
engage children at all
hey I don't want that on my conscience
no one does but they're also giving away
our position so if I'm not going to
engage him you know lethal we're going
to take this kid down and get him out of
if you let a guy in a battlefield you
know point out where everyone is and
you're giving away everything so he has
to be confronted whether or not what the
means you confront him are the are the
the way but when you when you're
throwing a sword around and you're
cutting soldiers and Swinging it
you know again I I got myself in that
situation I shouldn't have I did I found
myself in that spot I had to get myself
out of it we did uh but I learned a lot
of lessons and the lessons are that you
know when the orders are no shooting you
avoid it you're not in the open you go
and you take a house down you get on a
rooftop you're not standing in the
street you're not pulling security the
way we did had fits been there I don't
think that would have happened
but he wasn't and you know it happened
and again there's a look I'm reading
little excerpts of this book this book
is a is an Incredible Book just there's
so much in here there's there's entire
story lines in this book that we're not
even touching on in we're going to talk
about today so if you're listening just
get the book
um it'll really help you this part is
one of the stories one of the story
lines about this sort of uh differences
in thought between you and Captain Sims
and uh just just given some more about
Captain Sims here just to give some
background on him uh you say this Sims
walk like a man who had a boulder on his
back but was too proud and stubborn to
admit the weight was crushing him
upright shoulder Square he made his way
to us in some ways I suppose taking
Alpha Company into Fallujah was his
Destiny all along he was the son of an
army officer who survived two tours in
Vietnam his uncle also fought in Vietnam
completed two tours and was disabled by
wounds received there his grandfather
was a 36-year two-war veteran of our
beloved service Sean had been born in
Taiwan went to high school in Korea and
came home for college to the country his
family had given their lives to defend
Sims had been a high achiever never type
a but rather a devoted studious and
introspective officer with plenty of
grit he checked all the boxes
Pathfinder and Airborne School Ranger
school armor Officer school at infantry
officers basic he had been the platoon's
top graduate
along with the weight of leading a
company into the worst Urban hellscape
U.S forces had experienced since way
City Vietnam in 1968 Captain Sean Sims
carried the legacy of his family's
Heritage on his shoulders as well
it's a lot
uh a lot for this guy to be you know
doing
yeah you know I love West Point and
Annapolis uh great institutions but so
many of these ROTC guys you know they've
officers are officers and and the good
ones you know you learn a lot from Bad
leaders without a doubt you know you
learn what's what you don't want to be
but the good ones
sometimes that seed gets planted and it
grows and bears fruit 20 years later and
I guess having someone that's so
intellectual and forward-thinking
that he's like there's a way that we can
fight Wars and not lose our soul
I would have mortgaged my soul
I mean honestly if you would have told
me this is going to be the future but
you can control the present and save
lives and bring everyone home and be
successful
what would you be willing to give I
would have given you everything
everything I don't care about being 40.
I don't think I'm going to make it to
29. I you know no one's thinking about
you know no one's buying a 30-year
mortgage when they're deploying to
ramadi you're not you're not looking at
the future you're looking at now and
they have these people that were like
listen there's a way to do this there's
a way to do it
when a new Soldier came in I wanted them
to see the enemy especially if we killed
the enemy that that is that's something
that if you're not accustomed to you
know moving a body off the battlefield
why is that important it's a there's a
reference we're not out there cowboys
we're not disrespecting the enemy we
respect the enemy
there's a holy relationship between
combatants on the battlefield and you
have to respect the enemy but you also
have to acknowledge that there is
something special about what is going to
be needed for you to be able to go home
walk off more importantly win the
objectives that we're there to win
right so so I can't have a guy brand new
in the country who sees a body and
completely you know comes unglued this
this is a part of the business so here's
the deal I don't need you to be on point
for the first two weeks but I need you
to follow up
and I need to know what it's like to
have a rifle crack next to your ear I
need to know what it's like to be near a
firefight even if you don't do anything
because you're brand new but when that
when the aftermath and we go through
that limit of advance and we cross that
Battlefield I want you to pick them up I
want you to put them in the bag I want
you to own this because this is all of
our actions and and this is something
you're going to have to get accustomed
to and the reverence you show
the reverence you show because I nothing
would infuriate me as much as I would
want to poke you know I I'd end your
life if you disrespected one of our
fallen I mean that's that's unforgivable
but I also was highly uh uh defensive
over the way the enemy was treated as
well we're not Savages we're not
Russians we're not Chinese we're not
mujahideen we're American soldiers will
conduct ourselves that way we're
professionals and you will show respect
to the enemy we're gonna kill him and
and if they're dumb enough to raise kids
my boy's gonna kill your boy too that's
just who we are
but there's a way that you respect the
enemy on the battlefield and and
understanding that you know this idea
they're meat they're just you know leave
them out there to rot leave them out
there to be you know whatever there's a
a time when that's unacceptable
civilians have to know we're the good
guys we're always going to be the good
guys in any circumstance
so
now we're advancing through this
deployment and now you guys find out
you're going to Fallujah uh how's that
take place as far as are you starting to
prepare in any particular way and what's
the time frame between you guys getting
tasked with going to Fallujah and
actually getting there and and like what
what time frame
so first you get tasked we were supposed
to go to mosul uh that was the first
Rumor Mill and uh Charlie Company ends
up going instead of us uh but we know
that we're going to be used again I
understand you know April 04 najaf that
was ex supposed to be the fight the
fight didn't happen until August
so the Army command is realizing that
this is the year we got to start doing
something or we're just going to be
kicking the can down the road and
Fallujah was really depending on the
presidential election between Bush and
Kerry
uh the fight was supposed to happen in
October you know it's it's politics the
elect we're not going to fight a major
battle before an election it'll look bad
wait until after the presidential
election so that was November 8th that
year and so we knew that we had uh our
orders you know what's happening in the
Army by how good your food automatically
becomes and you know how you know
something shitty is coming because like
hey let's redo their chow hall let's
give these boys some toilets you know
they deserve cable they're and so all of
a sudden we start getting Brown and root
people and electricity we had an Empower
we didn't have water
and all of a sudden all these things
start happening and we're like uh-oh you
know and then like we had problems with
vehicles for a very long time and all of
a sudden like a gs-15 master Carpenter
it's like I can fix your rooms and you
know you want a new gun tube for that
Abrams I've got four in the truck you
know they were fixing everything every
and then everything I was like hey can I
uh we were at one point on a bullet
count right at one point we had to be
like how you gotta every day come up
with a certain amount of bullets so that
we're not you know we know who's
shooting what when
it was all part of the reporting and
then there was a time when they were
just like hey what do you want do you
want Claymores
I'm like do I want clear ones are you
kidding me pallets of C4 I have no you
know what I did I so we had Engineers
the new task force in the Army platoon
Engineers platoon attackers platoona
infantry let's go fight you know the
global Jihad we these Engineers are
Brill they're the intellects of the
combat arms guys right they have the
prescription glasses that are
fashionable you know what I mean they
they're super smart and our 82nd
Engineers are great but they're showing
me like a gatorade bottle and they're
like all right so we're gonna put the C4
on the bottom and put some cardboard and
what do you got links shell casings
whatever you have that's the metal we're
going to put a timing now listen dead
cord timing fuse they're different right
okay so I'm just there like you know
writing all this down no idea what the
hell I'm doing I'm like well these guys
said I could use shell casings and links
I want to just throw bullets in these
things I mean that would be a combat
multiplier right it explodes animal that
comes out wow that is a horrible idea
that is a horrible idea so now you got a
live round it's like you'll have to
throw it on a bonfire too while we're at
it you know just mindlessness but at the
same time I remember these Claymores I
had these CL and I'm like okay the cord
is way too short for a claymore and so
I'm like I wanted to start 100 mile an
hour taping Claymores to IEDs we found
right because I figured that'll be
you'll get it in a ditch clickety-clack
and blow up the IEDs I mean EOD was like
the Easter Bunny I mean we heard it
existed no one's actually seen the
Easter Bunny it was like a sasqua when I
saw Hurt Locker I'm like shut up where
were those dudes I have never seen an
EOD a robot a guy in a suit and they're
amazing God bless them but they were
always eods here you waited for two days
for EOD to show up and and I'm like I
don't got time for this let me just show
me enough I'll blow it up myself so I
got my C4 I got my blasting cap
and then I gotta crimp the blasting cap
and I'm like
it's a crimp when you say crimp do you
mean what now he's oh you crimped too
hard I'm like I crimped too hard he was
like just crimp it enough
how many you know ticks do I need you
know how many should I and so I'm
getting myself some really really stupid
I'm getting nervous so dumb it's so dumb
and you teach it's like you know give a
monkey a hand grenade you know what I
mean and so we got to the point where I
I had these Claymores and I thought you
know I've got all these alleyways
um I'm going to spray paint the backs
Orange
so I could see them I'm going to take
I'm going to take uh 100 mile an hour
chord and I'm gonna time to the top of
buildings
so if a guy is coming through an
Alleyway I'm not gonna wait I don't want
to pull Security in every alley on a
building where it's like the Alamo we
gotta defend ourselves
I'm just gonna clack a claymore when a
guy's running underneath it
right not realizing that the little
prongs and the Claymore actually
supposed to be in the ground for
stability right so it's like the
Claymore and then when you dangle it on
cord it's like
it's like and you can't it's nighttime
yeah which way is it facing
so the first time man it happened and
it's that's like
you know going to the zoo and you got
that two-hour window where the line is
awake you know what I mean you're like
super excited you're like Gathering the
kids and like hey hey so much when you
hear that like that the windbreaker
pants and you're just everything you're
like spidey sense everything's like God
this is real this is happening here they
come
the bad guys coming and it's coming
through the aisle and the the alleyway
and I'm like okay okay all right now
it's like do I hit it immediately do I
wait what's you know now you're nervous
and you're but you're the NCO so you're
trying to be like guys let's not get
nervous but you're the one that's not
enough you know you're like I'm my
command but just everyone okay everyone
drinking everyone's good how's home did
you talk to Mom you don't even like
wasted time I finally get the point I'm
like all right I'm ready go and this
thing just I mean there's 700 of those
32 calibers in that thing
700 and that thing just went flying in
the air I mean flying in the air like it
was it could have taken the satellite
out it was the dumbest thing in the
world and it was like throwing a bomb
yeah just like launch it like spin
decaying 40 millimeters right over your
head and they're like what did you think
was gonna happen but I thought it would
just like you know like a top attack
artillery round but I'll tell you what
Not only was that alarming for us that
guy was the [__] his pan that dude I'm
sure that guy's in dental school changed
his life around he got out of there went
back to the Philippines and there's a
productive memory but no
I think outside the box sometimes you
get a little too much knowledge and it
could burn you
all right let's get into uh let's get
into Fallujah a little bit
um
uh now so so for this I'm going to the
book house to house and and I'll tell
you what
um
The Arc of the writing and the thought
process between these two books is
amazing to see so you you had written
this one it came out in 2007 is that
right right so you'd written it maybe
2005 2006 something like that so you're
fresh off the battlefield and you're
writing this book
and it is an as an unbelievable account
it's really it's it's just an
unbelievable account of you and your
guys and then you know just to finish
what I'm talking about the the way that
Arc goes into remember the ramrods your
new book
you can see how much you've thought
about it how much well just the
perspective of getting older and time
and the way everything's impacted and
when you look back what it looks like
now uh but to be able to sit for me
and and read these two books
and just see that Arc is is incredible
um So for anybody that's listening both
books they're both incredible books get
them
um this is going to the book it's house
to house an epic Memoir of War
and you say this I meet with Sims E1 and
Fitz for a final briefing
we roll out and we'll roll out in the
morning and our mission is now to find
Sims details the assault plan and
explains our jobs with step-by-step
Precision each platoon will play a
different part in the initial attack
Fallujah is a city designed for Siege
Warfare and you talked about that
earlier architecture aside the
insurgents have had months to prepare
for this battle they've dug fighting
positions mine the streets booby trap
the houses built bunkers and cleared
fields of fire every road into the city
is strong pointed mined and blocked with
captured Texas barriers Fallujah is
shaping up to be the verdune of the war
on terror we Face a battle of attrition
fought within a maze of interlocking
fortresses attrition is such a sterile
word we'll be trading our lives for
theirs
Sims makes it clear that our initial
objectives will be heavily defended the
insurgents have deployed foreign
fighters on the city's approaches they
form the outer crust of their defense in
depth so we'll face them first
intelligence reports tell us that we'll
face syrians Iranians Saudis Filipinos
even Italians and chessions
they've they're well-trained
ideologically motivated and armed with
ample ammunition and equipment
they've trained for years to kill us
infidels some have cut their teeth in
cheshnia Afghanistan and Somalia they
are veterans just like us a regular
islamist All-Star team
we can expect possibly 30 percent
attrition at an urban breach like this
Sims tells us
I've been writing down everything Sims
has said now I pause and stare at the
initial casualty estimate 30 just to get
into the city there's no way we can keep
everyone alive once inside the city
obviously we will is we will not use the
main roads they are all heavily IED our
lead tracks must create their own paths
with help from the engineers
look over the maps we'll have to
improvise most of these routes I'm not
going to Rattle off what the acceptable
attrition is according to command
gentlemen we'll seize Highway 10 and
push into the industrial district expect
some of the heaviest fighting in this
area foreign jihadists will use hit and
run tactics but there are enough
fighters in the city for them to have a
mobile Reserve
we could face counter-attacks during the
first day the enemy has the forces to
mass against us
there will be no calling in Medevac
Choppers once you're in the city it'll
be too hot for Blackhawks we'll have to
ground a vac our casualties to this
Cloverleaf east of the Cities
east of the city
end quote the bad news continues as
Captain Sims closes his laptop and turns
to us
we expect the insurgents have stockpiled
drugs will be facing Fighters hopped up
on dope again
I look over at Fitz and I know what he's
thinking if this is true these guys are
going to be hard to kill
so that is a freaking
that is a that is about as a heart of a
brief to sit there and listen to bunkers
IEDs booby traps interlocking fields of
fire strong pointed buildings I mean
this is just for anybody that's not that
hasn't been in the military that doesn't
understand the the Litany of
enemy power that I just went through you
can't make it any worse it's not going
to get any harder than what what I just
read well and the thing goes it was that
day was the first day that we realized
we're actually going in I mean we
thought that the Marines were going to
do we had Iraqi intervention forces and
Marines
and we were just on the flanks you know
because it was the the fame the the fake
invasion seals had gone in uh on the day
that we were taken down Fallujah and
took the hospital out and once the
hospital was isolated there was a one
road that connects intersex uh Fallujah
highway 10. right and so you've got a
northern side which is these homes are
all like Honeycombs on top of each other
South of Highway 10 is all industrial so
there's two completely different ways to
do Mount and Industrial as dangerous as
as a living room because it's wide open
anything can happen
but it was so crazy that
he was giving us an attrition number and
then he was like I'm not going to tell
you what command is expecting so we're
starting to think this is a Normandy
Beach Landing this is the the Higgins
boats doors
you know the ramp is very similar to a
Bradley the Higgins boats coming down
and you're just going to get whatever if
you can get to a foothold hold it and
let the Marines come through and then
it's on it's on them right that's that's
pretty much the way
we're looking at this and I thought to
myself do I
share that with my guys do I take that
back to the platoon do there was a a
time early in the deployment my platoon
Sergeant is a guy from Missouri who it's
I mean if you went to Central Casting to
find a platoon Sergeant I I write in the
book a house to house that he learned to
kill anything that could [__] Outdoors
at like four you know everybody if you
if you took a dump outside this guy
could get a fair game yeah and he would
send these deer videos his mom would
send him deer hunting videos and a
deployment and I started watching them
and it there was a moment when a deer
hunter will will uh will be like hey and
the deer will be like and and they'll
take the shot I was doing that to
insurgents where you you couldn't get
the shot you wanted and just be like hey
and the guy would be like what and you
just you'd pop them and I'm like this
this works this is incredible you know
so he was he was always cool always like
you know I was a meatball I thought my
first name was Jesus and my last day was
Christ because that's what he said
before my name there was no rank it was
just Jesus Christ you know there was no
doubt who was you know running this show
it was him
and I remember there was a day that he
looked called me over his Bradley and he
was smoking a cigarette and he said hey
look at me and his face was white and he
was like I just got I've confirmed it
three times I had no time for [__]
we've got 200 to 300
white Hots coming through this Palm
Grove and they're expecting to be here
in about 20 mics
and I was like
[Music]
impossible he's like orbital platform
this is not a ground surveillance radar
this is orbital platform the tracking
them right now we've got 300 guys qrf 20
minutes fast movers 25. that's how much
time you've got sustain this area for 25
minutes
and I'm like this has got to be like a
Candid Camera you know what am I going
to do how am I going to react and I
remember thinking the guys always knew
when the spare barrels came out [__] was
it was going to be a bad day when this
when you had time to set up a t and E
and have a spare Barrel it was going to
be a bad one but I thought
I'm not gonna tell them
I'm not going to tell them
I'm going to prepare like the Battle of
and team is going to break out but we're
we're just going to have our mags ready
we're gonna have
I'm going to set this position up and
you know or knock it down there was a
guy stacked flower up there was like a
four rows of flower uh bags and I'm like
well there there's there's the position
one right and you know get elevation low
high ditches whatever I could find a
culvert here a thing
and and we waited and we waited and
finally the thing was like hey I got the
wrong 12 digit uh the you know this this
is a guy relaying from a sheriff Network
and like so someone else is getting
someone's getting messed up right now
but it's not you
and I thought to myself all right that's
an incredible lesson because you either
trained your guys and you're ready or
you're not do how important is drama
and as a drama major I can tell you that
I'm not very good at it but I can tell
you that if you're doing it for the
effect
because some leaders need that this is
going to be the worst day of a gentleman
prepare to defend yourselves right that
is that's the line you want to have a
John Wayne Moment is that weakness is
that strength do you re if you're really
doing your job
let 300 guys come
I'll eat ciao you give me 150 meters of
standoff distance and 30 seconds of
warning my guys can eat a burrito and
we're gonna we're gonna hold this ground
that's what I want out of my Force
that's why I want out of my guys so I
thought to myself do I take that
information back
and do I tell them look around the room
because you know they're talking you've
probably sat through a briefing look
around the room to your left and right
not all of you will make it out of this
meeting you're like what everything's
dramatic everything's life and death and
over time in a Road's trust it erodes
Fidelity in a roads Swagger
so the one thing I I wanted to be
careful is with families
you know the family running this group
and depending on what unit you're in
families are all about you know gossip
and you got groups of wives that are
going to the range and like you know
they know who's deploying who's dead it
could be if you don't have a command
unit at home willing to take these
casualties and and handling themselves
as Pros you can have some real problems
in a unit with just gossiping whatever
I hated the people that were calling
home
I hated the distractions of bills and
kids and I tried as much as I could to
just to get them away I know there's
Burger King at the other fob don't eat
it
don't eat it I know there's a Pizza Hut
at War Horse and I know they have really
good food and blue cheese don't eat it I
want you to be as miserable as possible
not because I hate you not because I'm
insecure and I want to show you my Alpha
I want us all that when we eat blue
cheese they have it we have a Whopper
it's going to be because there's no more
fighting you earned the Whopper I I know
your wife and your girlfriend want
updates and the kids are riding bikes
and trick-or-treating I don't give a
damn about any of that crap going on and
if you are thinking about your
girlfriend or your wife or what's going
on is Jody coming over what's happening
you are not in this game and you're no
good to me you're no good to me I you uh
you your focus is on that Moosh that's
cleaning his body of hair putting it in
a bag and saying his prayer because he
knows he's gonna die
he knows he's gonna die when I came home
from Iraq I'd leave I met a Vietnam guy
who was a tunnel rat that's a [__] job
that's like the worst job in the world
right
and I was complaining to him about how
I was mad that the UPS man was whistling
and happy
and we're going through all this myths
like I could see these kids grocery
stores
guys and their girlfriends at the mall
getting a latte and I'm like these
freaking dirt like you have no respect
you do you have a limp are you
stuttering why are you getting a haircut
why are you too good for your country
who the hell did he and I had an
inferior inferiority complex
and this Vietnam vet looks at me and he
says you're going back in a week and you
know what your problem is and I'm like
what he's like you think you're coming
back
and I was like
I didn't know what to do I I didn't have
spit my mouth I didn't know if I should
crawl into the fetal position or what do
you mean I know I'm coming back he's
like no no no no in your head
you're not coming back if you fight like
you're coming back you're going to not
make the choices you need to make you're
going to always think about someone else
he's like right now close your eyes
casually notification team is talking to
your little boy
your mom and dad just changed your star
from Blue to Gold do you see it all
right it's over
it's happening that's your reality now
fight
now fight now get out there and realize
it's gonna happen you don't know when
it's gonna happen it's going to happen
62 a heart attack and a on a you know
jungle gym with the grandkids it's gonna
happen tomorrow with a bullet through
your face
you don't control it give in to it
you're not coming back fight like you're
not coming back and you will never lose
an inch of ground and you'll never lose
a soldier because you were afraid to not
give him the fight you want
it changed my life I'm like is that what
you is that why you guys are all insane
with your long hair and your weed your
Woodstock he's like that's how we fought
that's how we survived and that's the
only way you can you can make it through
and when I thought about that and I
started to live that I was like all of
these things are distractions
I want you to have a wonderful marriage
I want you to have a wonderful family
but you're not gonna have any of those
things if you're thinking about
Halloween and about that bike ride we
gotta go take care of people that are
going and so we would watch
Nicholas Berg
the beheading video
every second of that guy getting his
head cut off by zarkowie in Fallujah
let's watch beheading videos let's watch
the people
in the towers that jumped out the
windows
the heat was too much they jumped that's
what we're avenging that's who we're
fighting every one of these guys cut off
Nick Berg's head every one of these guys
is raping and destroying and they killed
our citizens on September 11th that's
the mindset I don't want to hear about
your family I don't want to hear about
your wife I don't want to hear about
[__] pay your bills if you don't have a
relationship that you can trust someone
to pay the cable bill I'm going to make
this really easy for you re-enlist okay
re-enlist because you're going to need
the income right we are here to do a job
this is our Focus anything else is is
sedition
you are committing a crime to me you're
committing a crime to the country
because you are here for a purpose and I
don't give a [__] about what your
ambition or hope is right now it's us
I don't my dad didn't I didn't know my
dad you had a dad I don't give a damn
you know we got all these different
walks of life and socioeconomic issues
Focus
and that did it that did it and that's
the best possible thing you can do for
your troops I think so I hope so
I hope so
fast forward a little bit
ramrod's take a knee
he calls us into gravenly in his
gravenly Gravelly Southern drawl there
are times I think he's speaking a
foreign language his southern accent is
so indiscernible it's like a cross
between John Wayne and Ross Perot our
task force is known as the ramrods those
of us in alpha alpha company are the
Terminators Alpha Company forms a
horseshoe around sergeant major
Falkenburg
we get down on one knee and weight at
first he says nothing he spits a wad a
red man chewing tobacco into the dirt as
his eyeball as he eyeballs us with a
squint he takes time to look each of us
in the eyes I stare back at him to me he
has always been a seemed as big as a
grizzly bear and twice as scary but now
as I study him I realize he's wiry and
short it's the weight of his character
that makes him seem so large
men I could not be be more proud of you
if you were my own kids
we wait for him to continue he hesitates
he's struggling with his emotions and we
see his eyes messed up that site sends a
surge of emotion Through Me part Love
part despair part blind loyalty
I couldn't be more proud looking at how
far you all have come and what you are
about to do
he pauses again and lowers his head his
iron self-discipline fighting a losing
battle with his heart
that's all go get them
the mechanics and support guys start to
cheer somebody shouts give them hell
others shout as well for a moment I
can't move sergeant major sergeant major
Falkenburg is Our Father Figure he's the
man I've Most Wanted to impress
I have wanted and needed to believe he
was proud of me and what I've done with
my squad
I never felt I did anything to be worthy
of my own father's Pride my father was
the first person in the history in this
of the state of New York to go from
Junior College to dental school starting
with absolutely nothing and
accomplishing so much on his own
I sought his affirmation but always
seemingly in vain I always felt I never
quite measured up to his eyes
to me it was my fault for squandering so
many chances here now I want more than
anything to stand with sergeant major
falkenberg as we head into the fight and
measure up at last
this time I am determined not to fail
his few words have had a more profound
effect on me than any of the pep talks
of the past week a great speech is only
partly about what is said often what
matters more is who says it and how it
is delivered
our Sergeant Major's vulnerability and
love for us spoke volumes
as everyone else gets up to head for
their Bradley's I stay a heartbeat
longer Falkenburg turns his steel blue
eyes to me
no words are spoken but in his eyes I
can see something
a feeling coming my way
respect
I gotta get you to read these books on
audio man it just it sounds so much
cooler hearing you say it
Falkenburg is a guy who is
first of all he was 45 when he died he
was the first American to be killed in
the Battle of Fallujah
and you want to talk about like you're
watching a movie and the hero of the
movie is the first guy to drop and
there's no explanation it's it's the
most morale killing thing in the
universe right
I remember hearing that he was 45 and I
was thinking I'm for you know at the
time I was the same age he seemed like a
dinosaur like that's the oldest person
in the world you know
and and he is a body on the stretcher
he wasn't even big enough to cover the
entire polish litter
and I the guy just was a giant and every
you know always had the worst rifle a
you know an A4 with nothing on it he's
like let the fancy guys have the fancy
[__] I don't need it you don't need
nothing iron sights
um
I just absolutely adored him and and and
I I always he hate I don't think he
liked me and that's the other thing no I
really I I can tell you with with
authority that he did not like me
but I had loved him and I and I and and
had he liked me I don't think I would
have he was such uh
a guy who's been in the military for 25
30 years they've been to every armpit
every butthole the world they've seen it
all there's nothing you're gonna tell
them that they don't know on the day we
show up to Bob Normandy fourth infantry
divisions on one side first IDs on the
other are two battalions two eight two
two infantry which by the way is the
order of March at Normandy Beach
and ironically
it took the first Infantry Division to
take the pedals that's neither here nor
there back in Normandy but
their first enormity first you know
that's their unit
this fourth ID SAR major steps up and he
is the most eloquent guy in the world
he's like gentlemen on the other side of
that wire there's an enemy that enemy
will take your life we are here learn
from us you know what I mean like it was
they were dirty their uniforms were rat
you know ripped and we were just we I
actually made noise I starched my dcu's
I made like
totally combat ridiculous
you don't ever need that right and and
funkenberg gets up after this eloquent
speech about you know the world is a
dangerous place we are the beacon of
light and freedom and Falkenburg just
turns to us doesn't talk to them it says
don't trust a single one of those sons
of [__] and he's like they're gonna
steal your night vision and go deer hunt
with them he's like don't put your night
vision they'll put in your gas tank
they're gonna lie they're gonna steal
Squad leaders I want a green to Green
every five hours
I don't want a single fourth ID guy in
your living quarters I've seen this [__]
they're your friends and then they steal
all your gear and they go home to clean
and they go deer hunting with your night
vision and we're all like and the guy
was everyone was like what the hell is
wrong with this guy right but that's who
he was he didn't give a [__] if he was
an elementary school principal he'd be
the worst ever he was an infantryman and
he all he cared about was these are my
kids these are my boys and the idea that
he would be the first to go down
and how that you want to talk about you
know losing officers losing senior ncos
and these young kids saying okay I'm not
a platoon star anymore now I'm a first
sergeant running a battalion ROTC
Lieutenant running a company
I mean their trigger pulls away but that
that to me was the sign of you know this
is real like we'd lost 40 plus guys to
that point in the deployment every one
of them stings every one of them hurts
but he's much more than
a leader they become your mascot they
become your empathy they're they're more
than leaders they're they're the
identity of who you are they're your
validators every single day it's not a
good day unless he says it's a good day
you're not you know ready until he tells
you you're ready and when that's gone it
is a father figure
um it's it was devastating it was
devastating and now you're not even in
the fight yet
like it'd be like you're going to the
Normandy Beach and the guy gets hit in
the Higgins boat and now you're the
ramps are dropping and everyone's like
what just and you're like forget it
forget it everything's okay everything's
cool we're keep going
and and you get the report that there's
an angel
right that was the radio chatter an
angel we got a ramrod seven Angel seven
you're like
you know disc well you know what let's
go our mission is to get the guy that
killed Falkenburg that's what we're
doing right now are you serious where
yes I got the mission the guys in this
block killed SAR major let's go get them
it doesn't matter where we we're in
Bosnia
we're getting the guys that got sergeant
major Falkenburg do not be the one to
come home to a ceremony and see his
widow and his daughters and say that you
didn't have something to do with getting
the person that got him that's the only
thing we can control right now
this is the last one we're gonna take
right
but it was you you don't know when to
you you can only compartmentalize so
much and so these two books are dealing
with 20 years after that and did we
maintain our promises to our friends
did we sit down with the kids we all
talk about it
um when you're old enough I'm gonna sit
down with you I'm going to tell you who
your dad was
how many of us have actually done that
how many of us have actually stood with
a widow
I would hear a story of a woman that
lost her husband in the war and she got
married again and I thought to myself
that's way too soon that's disrespectful
like how do you do that your husband you
loved him he loved you he talked about
you all the time and you're just gonna
marry another guy
and someone told me he was like Bell via
that was 12 years ago man
12 years ago
let this woman move on with her life
you're holding on
you have no idea what she's been through
you have no idea who this guy is
you you you can't think like that this
is
these families have gone through so much
and we promised
that we would be there have we been
there what kind of lives have we lived
we said we're going to live for them and
be twice as good because they're not
here we have to do more with our lives
how many have done that
instead we're talking about suicide and
addiction and and how people have quit
there's no way you're thinking about
your buddy that died in the war if
you're thinking about you know killing
yourself
getting high or or giving up
you are betraying all of that that we
we've been far too soft with this
generation of of saying oh it's
acceptable that's a choice you make it a
choice it's a valid Choice it's [__]
it's not a valid choice
you you made a promise
and it and if you would have killed
yourself as we're stacking on a house
how would that have been received
but no you decide you're going to do it
at home when it's over no no we have a
purpose
and we have to honor our word and this
book is about how I didn't I didn't
and it took a stupid oh this award
that got all my guys together again and
we realized we didn't need any
of the stories we don't need the glory
we don't need the attention we need each
other
that's why we did it we need each other
we need to be present in each other's
lives
and validate and and acknowledge that
there's purpose and and that we all have
we all have a journey and some of us are
struggling some are doing great
but we we got to honor those promises we
made each other when we thought the
world was going to end in 24 hours
um
at this point uh I'm gonna fast forward
a little bit it's basically go time and
there's a I kind of have to read this
part because we get a new character gets
introduced into the scenario here you
say this throughout Alpha Company
digital cameras appear
and soon the men are posing for one
another nearby are embedded reporters
take all take all this in they cluster
together like new kids in second grade
watching the scene as awkward Outsiders
these photos are crucially important a
form of insurance against our own
mortality a few months back we lost a
man and realized to our unending dismay
that no one had a single photo of him to
display at his memorial service it was
disgraceful surely this is in the back
of everyone's mind now
this time we will have a record of Every
Soul who goes through the breach
Michael Ware breaks ranks from the
cluster of journalists With Yuri in tow
they come over to third platoon and
offer to take our picture the platoon
lines up and they go to work the other
embeds see this and promptly stream to
their assigned units taking cameras and
snapping pictures of them as they click
away they are no longer awkward
Outsiders now they've found a way to
help us they circulate among the
soldiers and start to fit in they've
shown us they're human
and the company appreciates that after
Michael and Yuri finest finally finish
up I let a smoke and stretch out on the
ground next to the track it's almost
zero nine hundred the morning is crisp
cold and punctuated by distant artillery
barrages every few minutes in Apache
Thunders overhead fast-moving fighter
jets crisscross above them in the sky
this is where I belong
it's the first time in my life that I've
found my place it's a reassuring thought
that eases some of the Butterflies
fluttering around in my gut
I wonder if it was like this for the
soldiers of the Union Army during the
Civil War tenting on the old Campground
and All Quiet on the Potomac have been
replaced by our percussion heavy metal
modern Rifts of Mud Vein and dope but
we're still basically the same the
details vary from war to war but no
matter the epoch the camaraderie remains
it is a closeness that no civilian will
ever really understand
a Bradley swings out of the column and
starts towards us Lieutenant Colonel
Newell riding shotgun in the turret
yells at the troops as he passes he
looks like Patton must have looked as he
raced alongside one of his flying
columns in a jeep dressed like he was
ready for a parade Patton sometimes
stood on the passenger seat seat to
shout at his GIS Newell can't do that in
a modern day Bradley Fighting Vehicle
but the similarities are striking
nonetheless our task force is a hundred
Vehicles long strong Newell's track runs
the length of our column like a steel
sheepdog shepherding us forward as he
passes by I hear him Bellow let's go go
go
foreign
who's uh Australian journalist
uh Yuri's the other guy that I mentioned
where's he from is he a Russian guy yeah
and he these guys are in beds and how
much did you know about Michael Ware at
this when you first met him so Michael
Ware was in my opinion Michael Ware was
a Public Enemy Number One because he was
the face of Western journalism to the
terrorists so all these beheading videos
they were trying to basically circulate
through him he was embedding with both
sides
and so I didn't know what a journalist
did and I didn't really give a damn but
he when he showed up I mean really I
mean what am I he showed up and he was
Time Magazine you know CNN all these
things were going to work through him
and he had the respect of being the guy
that has gone to every horrible place in
the world
and so I I didn't see him I saw him as a
partisan I saw him he has an agenda
what I learned in flu and one of the
reasons why I came in a better reporter
when I got out was because I had such I
mean I grew so close to respecting this
guy because at a certain point
our radios are only as good as what
they're you know I can't get on the horn
at my rank and level and talk to a
general in the Marine Corps that's on a
flank five kilometers away he would pick
up a sad phone
and he'd call the embedded journalist
with the Marines and he'd be like listen
we need artillery and we need it now and
I'd be like damn like that welcome
welcome to Team America Michael Ware he
was doing things and and then he sat us
down and gave us his own briefing
and and that that changed the that
changed the way we fought listen you
know you get command and they tell you
dispositions and you know I always it's
gross to say but when you saw an enemy
uh defecate you could learn a whole lot
about what you're fighting you know
diarrhea is a good good sign these guys
are nervous they're not healthy they're
not they're tired
they're not you could see the mucus I
want that right I don't I mean I want
for my I want to see that right give me
more diarrhea I want I want to see the
enemy suffering and scared and not
healthy right Michael Ware gave us a
briefing on what type of enemy we're
fighting and and the way that these guys
you know they're rocket teams he's like
you're going to look for little
designations one building is gonna have
nothing but rockets in it the next
building nothing but medical supplies
the next building just bullets if you
start fragging out like you're doing
you're gonna get the wrong building and
that whole thing is going to go up he's
like look they've read your your books
they know how you like to enter
buildings
we would go into a building on the top
floor all the stairs were removed
all of them you would jump from a roof
to another roof and they took out not
only the roof but the second story as
well you're falling all the way down to
the first floor and they've got you know
these rods and glass and Constantino
wire
he's like you you there's there's got to
be a way that you you acknowledge that
if you're coming from the road and
you're going through a front door they
know you're going to take that door
right that's the door they want you to
take you would find Serpentine like
almost like a maze of just really
crudely put together cinder blocks maybe
eight feet tall and they would just work
you into a turn in a turn and then you
look up and that's the overhead where
that PKM is mounted and they're just
gonna fire at you while you're like a
rat in a maze he's like this they've had
way too much time to prepare he's like
tunnel Networks
you they know they have to protect their
wires and and if they leave their wires
in the open there's too much artillery
and bombs out there they're going to cut
those wires all of those wires are going
to be dug all of them so when you see a
hole and a wire coming out it's leading
to a house I've seen it and I I know
what these guys are doing
I'm like this is this is Intel this is
really good stuff and this is a guy who
did not care about being
famous he didn't care about being on
camera
he was he was just about wherever you're
going I'm going
and I want to get the story so I can I
can tell the truth and that's why he was
hanging out with the Enemy you want to
know the truth who are these people
where are they coming from
I I I love that guy I don't think if he
didn't film that house fight there's no
way that this this award would have
happened I don't think it
it was 15 years the the video and his
documentary and it's circulating
gave our unit credibility gave that
award credibility I mean we hear a lot
of stories
you know unless you see it or hear it
you know yeah totally I mean the the
Chapman story is so unbelievable
that had I not seen a Drone footage
myself
that is one of the most incredible
things any American has ever done in the
history of warfare
the Roberts Ridge and and their what
they knew the the birds getting shot
down the the the seals working with Air
Force and
[Music]
again sometimes you know those things
help uh just kind of paint the picture a
little bit better but Michael Ware had
no business going into any house fight
he had no business doing any of that and
he did it
and uh I just I I he's like family to me
now I love him I I just I I don't know
I've never had a relationship with a
person outside of uniform that I could
actually say I I tell him now
you're you were born in the wrong job
you you you you should have had a a
rifle not a cannon there was a a part in
Fallujah where I I thought about getting
my rifle
and the only reason I didn't was I
couldn't imagine what that report would
look like if my guy got shot because he
you know nutted up
I don't know I don't think I would have
survived that and that documentary is
called only only the dead right yeah
yeah uh I remember when it came out
because somebody you know forwarded it
to me like hey this dude's freaking with
the Moosh hey this dude's doing this
dude's with Moosh in ramadi I'm like
what so I'm like what are you talking
about and went and watched it um it's
it's crazy to watch it's crazy it's
crazy to watch it's crazy to watch he's
he's yeah at some points he's embedded
with Americans and at some points he's
embedded with Moosh
and it's crazy to watch and see and and
then you know there's a story behind it
but yeah it's it's a it's a crazy
documentary he's a CR he's a lunatic
yeah I mean I know I love him I'm not I
I there's Valor that we show that people
fight cancer show Valor people stand up
to bullies show Valor soldiers cops
firemen and I I never thought
journalists could do that every time I
hear a journalist being so brave you
know you had the you know you read a
teleprompter you know what I'm saying
you went into makeup and got your hair
done excuse me if I don't celebrate the
holiday you know I mean I might just go
to work today instead of having Wolf
Blitzer day
but the truth is there are guys out
there and girls that a woman from CNN in
the Afghanistan what's her name um
the the the lady that was uh bedded
though she's she's a real deal yeah I
know I've had a woman on this podcast
Holly McKay and she's gone over and done
all kinds of stuff but I'm like hey
she's like on social media like
messaging I'm sending you know like
messages get out of there like
Afghanistan was falling I was trying to
pass messages like you need to get out
of there now uh but you know she's
committed to doing her job yeah and it's
weird
Man the video of this
I don't know what to tell people read
the book for this is my this is my
advice don't watch the video yet read
the book house to house
spend a few hours it'll probably take
you seven or eight hours to read this
book read this book and you'll kind of
be like
well that seemed crazy but I'm you know
could it have really happened like that
you'll cut you're gonna have questions
in your mind oh yeah and then you go
watch the video and you're like holy
[__]
so that's my advice read the book and
then go watch the video because there's
a video that's just you know you watch
the documentary for sure uh but it's
it's crazy that he was there to capture
this on video it's crazy there's a point
in the video he doesn't mention this but
there's a point where I took a shot at
him
and he's got the camera and I you know
if people think that you know you you in
a close quarter fight
you lose your hearing you can't hear
anything anymore you're exchanging
gunfire for you're totally deaf and this
dude is like hey you know in the middle
of a dark house he's a gay with an
Australian accent and I was like hey
as the journalist and I'm like dude I'm
gonna who the f is I'm gonna blow your
head off you know why are you speaking
English and I I took a shot and he did
like the round like hits the side and
he's just like and he's right back and
for years I thought he just put the
camera down yeah I thought he just put
the camera down the house and left
and he and I I was doing a uh doing a
radio show and I said that and he uh the
first time he contacted me since the
military he's like you son of a [__] I
was in the house with you the whole time
I have the entire video
and uh I watched this documentary and
the first reaction you have is I was way
cooler than that you know what I mean
look at your road ahead you you hear
yourself screaming
and it's like I can't believe how scared
I sounded and then you realize I was
scared you know what I mean like you you
seriously like you hear a story the Army
loves to you know they will they want
their guys this is the version this is
what happened very clinical very sterile
it all happened within two seconds that
video is 29 minutes long and in totality
I would have told you that that entire
fight was two minutes long
that's way too much
of just and and maybe we block
you know when you go through something
you forget about it or you don't think
about it or you can't remember it or you
don't want to remember it but all I can
remember is these it was so dark that
you just think it's the same guy you
know
and you you just you're not you're
bleeding you're not bleeding the 556
almost cauterizes you don't get the
the you can't drive if you're not
hitting pelvis or someone in the face
they're moving you know and so you you
you're not getting stopping power and
and and the other thing that that was so
strange is that like you don't know
where your guys are and so you're
constantly you know thinking that
you're going to get into a spot and
these guys are going to frag out or just
start juicing because you know you
trained them to do you trained him to
err on the side of Area fire at all
times they're gonna go through a spandex
in here with 240s and M249 saws and 40
millimeters and I don't want to be on
the receiving end of that so how do I
just get out but and then it gets
personal and the moment it becomes
personal is the moment where you go
through so many in a close quarter
battle it's well you know it's strength
it's will it's uh you know spirit it's
what you're fighting for your country
your friends your family it all it's the
most schizophrenic experience that
anything can turn that battle and I and
I've never been in an octagon I've never
been you know
but if there's something you can do that
can intimidate me
in that 30 second window or however long
it is in a in a MMA match
I at least dominated you enough where I
could do something
and and I got you thinking
psychologically I've got you thinking
and sometimes it's just registering that
the guy that you're fighting against is
scared of you
right and there was a moment
so the house fight is really three
different fights right you got the we
walk in we get ambushed and then the
tough the thing that caused me the most
thinking was just to scan in a doorway
with a saw that was the nuttiest that
because yeah that's you don't know it's
unknown are there two or they're one is
there what is it it's all unknown you've
never seen the house before
and I remember I hooked my finger
to the second knuckle I mean we're
butterflies you know this is the
training that in the military it's just
I'm a second and I I hooked it because
I'm like if I go down this thing's gonna
keep firing right
and then I have a runaway
and the only time I've had a runaway is
on the Range and you point the machine
you point the machine gun down range or
break a link and I'm about to do that
and I think wait a minute this is
actually this is actually we'll take it
but that thing fires a lot of rounds and
now I'm in this unenviable position of
helping the people that designed the saw
uh FN uh what what's the yeah the FN
people have fixed that magazine issue
where you could put a M4 magazine in and
they have it they still so so I'm trying
to feed a magazine to get a magazine get
a little 30 rounds do whatever
and I realize that not only are these
guys talking to so that they had a room
that had a stairwell going up and a
jersey barrier coming out and
I thought there were two machine guns
the army has their own version I guess
it was a PKM and an AK excuse me for you
know thinking that peaky on those two
feet away sounded like two you know yeah
it was a Pom-Pom gun in my my mind
but as the juice in that door
um the platoon gets on one side I'm the
only guy on the other side but I mean
that I'm on the stairwell now and I'm
looking over and I got nothing left
and I just remember them talking to each
other
and I did not even wound him
and for 200 rounds at like three feet
that just took everything I had my mojo
was done so I start beating tail
and as I'm running out I just feel
the Heat and the tracers behind me
and I'm like I'm running out I felt like
I was in that house with those two guys
again like I'm running I've never broken
contact in my life and I'm breaking
contact and someone just grabs my H
harness as I leave the courtyard it just
pulls me like a rag doll
and I was just like that's it and then
we're taking fire from the roof so so
let me just get through this
um
how this just to just to clarify for
everybody so you guys entered this house
yeah and you there's I mean just think
about what you just said there's a
jersey barrier
meaning that the Moosh had brought
freaking concrete barriers yeah like a
jersey bear like you see on the highway
yeah they had it up the stairs no it was
underneath the stairway so underneath
the stairwell they have a jersey barrier
to like they built a bunker inside this
house this is what you guys are up
against
they've got so your your team's in there
and now they're engaging and your your
team is pretty much stuck right they're
pinned down they can't get out of this
house right and you're standing there
and you realize that somebody's got to
put down some cover fire so everyone can
get the hell out of there right I so
you've got our machine Gunners are
outside and they're firing at guys in a
kitchen and these are two young kids Joe
Swanson James McDaniel they have 240
Bravos which is the M60 version today
and they're firing their machine guns
into the house
the bad guys are shooting from this
entryway into a living room
and the walls are falling apart
and so you've got and again it's like
throwing a log on a on a fire you've got
the rounds just going everywhere you
can't get up you're you're literally
hugging ground and you can't get up and
so I just kind of rolled to the left
side of the room and the entire platoon
was on the right
and I remember trying to squeeze my
rifle and it just it there was something
in the trigger well
and a rounded hit the uh the magazine
well and uh popped the magazine open
with the spring and the bolt was I
thought it was a double feed but I the
the rifle was an OP there's no way I
could I could do it so I I just said
throw me a machine gun give me a saw and
uh someone slid a solver and that's one
of those things where you asked for like
you know I'll help you lift the couch
and then the couch is 500 miles and
you're like yeah I need help with it the
the saw came over and it was um
it was ready to go and I just I needed
time I needed time like I I I my legs
were like you know lactic acid and
just concrete they wouldn't move
and it it just like you're just like
this is it like this is it it's gonna
and so my whole thought process was Get
Low
suck up as many rounds as you can in the
sappy plate in the helmet and if they're
gonna hit you they'll hit your leg or
they'll hit your you know your your arms
but just bring bring those arms duck
walk in as low as you can
and just try to get well aimed fire to
keep their heads down and just kill
these guys walk right into the the
bunker they'll never expect that
just walk right in and it just ran away
as soon as I pulled the trigger it was
just for clarity what does that mean
when you had a runaway
so open bolt weapons close bolt you know
the like a machine gun we we train
people for three second bursts right so
you just as long as you pull that
trigger down an automatic weapon is
going to fire rounds as long as that
trigger is depressed a semi you got to
squeeze every time when I pulled it down
I chewed up so many rounds that the
automatic machine gun just
was seared and that was just firing the
rounds regardless of where my finger was
oh okay so you pulled the trigger and it
keeps shooting and it's just gonna it
won't stop so in a training situation
when he was talking about branky or or
it could be in a combat situation but
once it's running away meaning you'd let
you off the trigger and it's just
bullets are still flying one of the
things that you can do is you take the
you grab the belt of the machine gun the
all the bullets and you break it off
okay and then it will only shoot however
many are left and then it stops and you
know he had to make the decision well
should I break this off oh no wait a
second this is a good thing it's working
it's basically the same thing happened
to Alec Baldwin oh okay too soon no no
but but it's a very it's a really weird
feeling but you think in in a you know
in a combat situation
use it right just point it but the
problem is that it's a 200 round it's a
drum a hard plastic drum and there's 200
rounds and you don't realize how fast
those rounds are gone because once the
rounds are gone I don't have any more
linked ammo I'm not a saw Gunner I'm
hoping that these guys are just going to
get out us we have they these guys have
the Australian peel anytime a special
operative trades a grunt you you get
things you don't know so I learned
Australian peel because but I'm Never
Gonna Learn I'm never going to use it
because I'm a an elite American immature
event I don't break contact right that's
the first time we did it
and it's basically like look I'm gonna
go forward you're gonna get out so I got
the gun I'm gonna move in you're just
gonna and I just need to know last man
the last guy just has to be a last man
so I know everyone's out and then I'm
gonna go with them I'm gonna fire
everything I have and and run away and
we're breaking contact and I I don't
hear Last Man the gun's going crazy and
I'm walking on the stairs above the the
little bunker and I'm just kind of
trying to bend you know like it's a leaf
blower like just trying to like get it
in there and if nothing's happened it
was a disaster
it was pretty bad
uh but that's on tape you know what I
mean like it's like crazy could you have
not put that part in like it would be
great if only the cool parts were in
there but unfortunately yeah everything
you say uh
I mean as you're writing about this it
it's crazy to read about it uh the
trigger still depressed my mind races
I've suppressed the enemy now I should
kill them my heart urges me forward
against the stairwell get out of there
clear the room and Juice these guys I
try to step forward but my feet won't
let me my legs feel like they're chained
to the floor I can advance to the 10
feet needed to end the fight don't be a
[__] move forward I strain against my
own body I cannot move the Saw's bolt
Clacks back and forth as it chews
through my ammo supply
okay I probably have about 110 rounds
left what if I make a push to get on the
stairs no my body still refuses my heart
rages i z the saw along the barriers
more foam explodes out to the S uh
Cascade on the floor it looks like
snowfall in hell in the fire lit Gloom
okay I've got probably less than 100
rounds left
it's time to move get forward finish
this finish this now I push I swear
my legs won't budge the enemy remains
unhurt hiding behind the ripped up
barriers I can't do it my heart seeds
with contempt then my saw runs away from
me sometimes with that weapon once you
go cyclic you can't stop it stop it I
ease off the trigger but it remains
locked back the bolt charges on its own
the gun spews at least 50 more rounds
then clunks on an empty chamber I'm out
of ammunition
I'm still in the stairwell room any
second the [__] Under the Stairs will
pop their heads back up see that I'm an
open Target and finish me my legs
suddenly free up I've got to get out run
I spin right and bolt through the
doorway thinking McDaniel and his 240
will be the in the four year to cover my
Escape I don't see Misa anywhere
but both of the living room and the
foyer are completely empty I charge
through both and out the front door as I
fly to the Courtyard an automatic weapon
clatters
give me another automatic weapon I
scream still standing in the courtyard
you'll pull back Fitz yells I need 203s
give me some 203 fire bullets crack over
my left shoulder and hit the outer wall
in front of me I keep running my legs
pumping furiously and then I'm through
the gate and with my men Misa appears at
the gate and throws me to the side
uh outside the street I got you man
you're good
we're safe
so you
get out of the house
yeah I mean honestly that was pretty I
think it was the angle of the of the
house didn't you know the guys on the
stairwell could only hit you when you're
in the house and the guys from the
window had to have either moved away
from that vantage point because if they
were hitting you know McDaniel Swanson
were right outside with a couple other
guys uh and they were exchanging machine
gun fire at Point Blank Range if those
guys were there with the ammo that they
had I mean it would have been too easy
there were pillars in front as well but
for some reason
it was I wasn't a fish in a barrel for
him but I could feel it and I and what
was so crazy is that you know I'm just
thinking to myself
my dream you know like when you're at
that two mile more uh point in a run and
you you hit the wall and your legs just
everything is you run so hard that you
can't feel anything the adrenaline is
just going nuts but you're like I
eventually have to stop
and when you have to stop in that moment
it's a it's a you can't just stop at a
dime you gotta at least walk it out
after you hit the wall I mean I went
from zero to 60 and I was I felt my butt
cheeks I thought I got hit in the in the
in the ass and I I think it was my heels
like I mean kicking my own ass like I I
I I had muscle spasms you know what I
mean like like I like a charlie horse
just from nothing to full Sprint in a
fight or flight and I had soreness like
on the back of my hamstring and and my
quads and and my glute and I was just
like am I hit what happened and the and
the re the realization that I did
nothing to the enemy
at least if I got two if I got one
let's get the bomb
and and the problem with Fallujah is
that the bombs became like a butcher
shop you know you've got a big set play
you got like three fix wing and I'm like
I need a bomb okay here's what's gonna
happen for your bomb Mr I need a bomb
all artillery stops all the aviation
assets are gone you're getting your bomb
it better be important
and your number's 15. because 14 other
guys need a bomb Mr DMV you know I need
my license done now
and you are on a list
and if you don't have a radio you don't
have a rank you're not getting a bomb
so we asked for the bomb I wanted the
bomb didn't get the bomb but now I'm on
the street with the platoon and everyone
is ducking for cover
and it was just such a horrific feeling
of I can't I mean I would have told you
that that moment in my life
was the moment I I was born to have
and it never in my mind ended with me
running screaming
with nothing with no dent
in in Goliath's armor
it's just it was crazy like I can't
believe nothing happened now that being
said yeah a normal human being would be
like well thank God I got out of there
and everyone in my platoon is okay cool
um okay let me tell you what happened
all right normal human being what would
happen if you were in front of your men
that you care for or love and everything
else and then you start giving orders
and they're like no sir I'm listening to
him
right that's what they did oh okay and
that just pissed me off I lost it I went
from I can't believe this was happening
to F this yeah you you guys want to
listen to fits you guys want to listen
to Lawson
get we couldn't get accountability is
someone in the house is anyone dead do
you have all your equipment I couldn't
get anything
everyone was scattered from still
getting shot at so fits and Lawson did
what we are trained to do which is break
contact to another building set up fire
superiority get elevation eyes on
suppress and then consolidate come up
with a new plan that's a normal plan
that's a normal plan that's a normal
plan I had Michael Ware and I he claims
that I'm pacing the streets like a
lunatic I don't remember that but I do
remember looking at Michael Ware
and I just looked at him and he looked
at me he looked exhausted sweaty and he
was just like
I felt like he was telling me
you could do this
absolutely there's two guys in the house
go you're good for two you you're out
there you know thinking yourself and
you're writing a book like what what the
hell kind of example did I just said
exactly then you start with give me my
[__] rifle who has my [__] rifle
which is
classic right you'd you'd you know
thrown your rifle to somebody else uh
you took the saw
and and you're like getting more
pissed off yeah by the minute
but but in my head I was telling my guys
what to do and they were not listening I
was internalizing that as
bellavia shook
big sarge is not the same guy he's
scared he just ran like a little [__]
I'm gonna look at lost and it fits these
guys are cool calm collected like they
are all the time
right and that and I was just like you
all right all right like is that what
you think I I wasn't there's no rational
you're not you're emotional and and and
adrenaline's going crazy and the only
guy
that I can get any
you know my my Dr Phil is an Australian
from Time Magazine
and he's like I'm not going any and the
bullets are listen I don't know what's
happening to me I can't see me I could
see him
and there are bullets all around him
just and he was just like standing there
so I'm like this guy there has a death
wish
or he really believes that I can do this
and if he believes I could do it that's
all I need and so I was like let's come
up with a plan
um
and my plan was a bomb I need a bomb
right now you get some Bradley's up
there yeah uh Cantrell's Bradley Lumbers
up the street the platoon scatters as
the brat arrives some some get behind it
for cover the turret traverses his gun
barks the shell explode the shells
explode High into the side into the
kitchen and living room
uh unter Shear is that right let me see
yeah unto Shear walks his fire back and
forth seesawing between the two rooms he
pauses his Cantrell sweeps the track
free of the shell casings which tumble
hot into the smoking Street
Cantrell backs the Brad up to up the
street to where he can lay down a
curtain of fire on the rooftops most of
the shells go high but the incoming
shots cease for the moment anyways what
else you got you think we got him
Cantrell asks
Michael where hears the question over
the den of the Brad's engine shots he
shouts there's no way he's got him
Sergeant Bell there's no way where had
been in the courtyard when the [__] hit
the fan he had to dodge the machine gun
fire from the kitchen in my heart I know
he's right but at the same time there's
no point in wasting any more ammunition
the Brad just can't get a Kill Shot into
the house at best The Barrage drove the
insurgents away from the front windows
overlooking the courtyard I think we're
good I tell the Brad crew we're back to
square one I start to Pace again walking
back and forth my inner monologue spills
out of my mouth I'm talking to myself in
front of where in front of the men I'm
livid the whole situation is taking my
dignity I need to find the strength to
get it back
honor what an overused word it's an
abstraction who can Define it all year
in Iraq have stood with my men if they
had to fill sandbags until three in the
morning I'd be out there in the dirt mud
with them I would never give an order
then go relax as they worked my example
is all I have is a non-commissioned
officer I take pride in that that is my
honor
I've always told my men not to be afraid
in combat when the bullets start flying
they need to man up and dish it back
tenfold how many times have I drilled
this into them perhaps telling them to
be unafraid is unrealistic we're all
human fear walks with us in every battle
yet we cannot allow fear to dictate us
who we are and how we act we cannot let
it control us we must Master it
that is another essential element of
Honor as I storm around in the street
struggling with myself where regards me
curiously the last thing I want right
now is a journalist watching me grapple
with my own demons I turn away and Pace
back up the street slipping on a couple
of 25 millimeter shell casings in the
process another spray of Sparks flares
around me do I have the balls do I have
the nuts to do what my [__] heart
wants me to do if I don't go in they'll
have won
how many times have we heard that
American soldiers rely on Firepower and
Technology because they lack courage how
many times has our enemy said that man
for man they can beat us that's nothing
new the Germans and the Japanese said
the same thing during World War II
inside that house I surrendered my honor
and my manhood
now I have to take both back or live
with the fact that they are right about
me that is unacceptable I rant and swear
with abandon down the street I see
Sergeant Knapp taking care of my men
like they are his little brothers I want
to cry I'm so proud I love these kids in
a way I will never be able to express I
see their faces one by one John Ruiz
Lucas Abernathy Peter sulcolas
Alex Tucker Victor Santos Brett pulley
Tristan Maxfield they deserve more from
me
I stopped pacing and let out a deep
rattling sigh only where Remains by me
on the street everyone else has moved
away perhaps my display has convinced
them I've gone mad
but where is still here the journalists
are platoon's unofficial Intel officer
we stare intently at each other
[__] it I say
[__] it agrees where
that settles it I'm going back in
it seemed very rational at the time
again I really thought there were two
bad guys in that house I know I'm good
for two I figured even though they're
talking I had to have hit them with
something
Ricochet a piece of concrete
maybe they I went through their ammo
but the clock is ticking and and my
biggest fear the reason why so the
Bradley the streets are very narrow and
there's High walls the Bradley can only
Traverse at a certain elevation so it
was only getting the upper stories and
the gate was only so wide right the my
fear was just give them something to
think about so they don't run out
because the last thing I wanted to do
this was we're looking for 10 to 12 bad
guys which everyone's looking pretend
it's all bad guys and and it was in a
structure of homes that was blocked off
by four tanks so we had thermals they
couldn't leave this block they're in
here somewhere and this is a couple more
houses to go this is all of them
uh we think we hope it's all I don't
want them getting back into houses that
we already cleared and now we're playing
you know whack-a-mole again and we're
going to get someone killed or or hurt
and
but but again talking someone I thought
someone said we're gonna die and so in
the video
I'm yelling We're Not Gonna Die and all
the guys today will tell me no one said
that that was in my head that I'm just
I'm resp but they thought they were like
dude you were having a full-blown
conversation and there was no one you
were talking to you're answering
questions you're you're taking food
orders like you've lost your freaking
mind and and uh I think where sense that
I think I think Michael Ware sensed that
I was coming unglued and so he did
so he's basically like this guy I think
we've gotta we've got some hope here
let's he's like what are you thinking
without saying it he's like what are you
thinking I'm thinking I want to do this
and I was I was ready uh someone gave me
an M16A4 with a 203
I had one grenade I had 140 millimeter
and I made the mistake of giving
magazines away because I saw
the enemy was wearing our uniform
because that Fallujah Brigade had all of
our uniforms but I saw a guy running
around with a with a Marine's rifle
and this guy had the bandoliers the IBA
and I just thought someone died and they
got all of his ammo and there's no way
I'm gonna go in here and get waxed and
then give because I was you know we were
carrying I don't know how many magazines
their combat loads so you know I don't
want the guy to have everything so I
carried five magazines one of them was
empty which was my mistake so I had four
full magazines and I probably should
have taken much more than that you know
no that that was a huge mistake but I
was thinking I don't want these guys to
have too much
but then I so so the the plan is
I need as many Saw Gunners as I can now
Doctrine is one thing
you've got your you know in a stack our
military infantry 7-8 you know
non-special forces Doctrine is you got a
point man rifle and then you go with
your uh Grenadier and then you got your
automatic weapon and then you got a
leader team leader squad leader whatever
it is
where we learned very quickly in
Fallujah is
I need Machine Guns automatic fire I
don't give a damn what it is shotguns
and machine guns so we incredible for
our Battalion and our Brigade and our
division to just find brand new songs
most of these saws were older than our
saw Gunners by the time we deployed we
got everything was new
and they got the combat saw the smaller
rifle the collapsible buttstock this was
hell yeah this was good stuff so we all
carried sauce as many saws I can get so
we had I said I wanted
four guys around the building
and I was gonna run in there like a
lunatic and try to push him out of the
house and then our saw Gunners would
shoot him up that was that was the that
was what we drew on on the dirt right
Lawson is a buddy of mine Lawson died in
2013. great kid great guy he was our
weapon squad leader he had an M14 only
for Fallujah no night Optics on it so
when the M14 goes away the only thing
he's got is a Beretta and I don't know
if you know this but next to like gold
a nine millimeter magazine was the
hardest thing to find you would do
anything to find an extra nine
millimeter magazine they were just you
could not every Pogue you know sitting
around weather traffic they all had the
nine millimeter magazines we couldn't
find them so we only had two magazines
of nine mil
and he had his nine uh millimeter and
that was it and night vision with no
Optics obviously it's a handgun
so we set up our guys as soon as I walk
into the house the third time right so
we were in the house leave the house the
Bradley fights that's like the second
fight and then I get in the house a
second time the the real fighting
everything is different that Bradley
fighter vehicle rearranged everything in
that place and the first thing I noticed
is that whatever plumbing system they
had
is all over the ground and it smells
like
a menstruating anchovy right it is
horrific it is horrific I mean just the
foulest nastiest dirtiest water in the
world it's slick
uh and and I there's fires everywhere
so the areas that aren't wet have fires
going on
and I'm seeing these I thought they were
at the at the time that the only light I
had
was night vision and the blinking of the
of the shots that were fired the tracers
and now I'm seeing that what I thought
were bricks are just blocks of that
plastic pe4 the shitty C4 though so and
there's one like mushed on the ground
and I'm like this entire freaking floor
it's wired and I think I gave the
instruction because they're not very
well they don't know they know as much
about explosives as I do and there's
like these really long
um you know popsicle stick size uh
blasting caps and they're like out
there's some are hanging like uh
speakers like just really poorly done
not and the Brad just rattled everything
so you got water and then there's broken
mirrors everywhere
and you could like look up in the corner
and you could see a broken mirror
through the fire and the night vision
and you could see the corn so they saw
us coming when we walked in but that
worked two ways because I could see them
at the 7-Eleven that they built with
their little mirrors everywhere and uh
and then I I I could hear one of the
guys like doing his prayer like he was
saying the same thing over and over
again
and that's when he started to uh he put
He he was screwing a fuse on a rocket
and his buddy under the stairwell was
holding the rocket and he was basically
fixing the rocket to fire the RPG he's
got an open door behind him
and uh I was like okay game's over
Lawson's inside the guys are outside
he fires that RPG at the you know I'm
not MacGyver what you shoot a rocket at
a bunch of flash explosions it's going
to blow up right I don't know what the
hell's going on I mean it wasn't raised
in Mogadishu you know so I don't know
how explosives and all that work he's
got that rocket he's going to shoot it
we're all done
So the plan was now and everywhere I'm
walking with the water it's sending
awake
of little ripples everywhere so they
know that someone's in here
so I don't have any choices I just
decide it's we're doing it so Lawson
doesn't even know like what's the plan
what's you know what are we we're
whisper he's like we're just doing it
he's just in there with his nine mil
with his nine mil he is
right and Michael where with a camera
Michael where were the camera trying to
get like what's your knife what are you
seeing through your night vision because
uh they got you got fires in there that
screws it up you get no ambient light or
is that ambient light working for you
like what are you seeing through your
night vision so I wasn't an Airborne guy
but I was told that the Airborne
infantry changed the way the Night
Vision Works so when you make a sudden
jerk of your head
the night vision shuts off
and whether it was just running or just
the motion of whatever I was doing my
ps14s were cutting off and turning back
on and it was the worst time because the
only reason why I got that rifle it's
got a pq2 alpha which is an infrared
flashlight and an infrared laser now
you're Annie Oakley with that thing I
don't have to aim it I mean I'm popping
dudes from the hip with a peek to Alpha
I've got a line right I could you know
yeah so but without the pf-14 it's crap
and these things are just on and off
they're just going and it never happened
before I had great and I I was like
proud of the way I took care of my knife
the guys would break their night vision
be like you
irresponsible horrible human being you
know what a marine would do to have that
you get a seven Bravo for the rest of
your life you don't deserve the ps14
that was such a cool thing to have the
ps14s and the squad and we took great
care of them and I never had an issue
and all of a sudden like you need it you
need to make that flight and it's
delayed and you're screwed and my night
vision start coming on and off and so I
just said all right I turned it off I
turn it right back on and I'm like I
just need just get through that door
again I'm thinking there's two guys in
this house the only two people I've seen
are under that stairwell
and that's it and nobody's communicating
there's we don't know what the other
platoon is doing they're on the other
side of the street they don't know where
I am the Bradley the a lot of confusion
but I walked through that door and I saw
his eyes and I was like oh yeah like you
had no idea of all the things you
thought back door see I thought they
were thinking back door too right I put
the guys they were super loud they're
getting around the house now we're gonna
come through the back door
and then we came to the front door again
and I see this guy's teeth and their
beautiful teeth like veneer teeth like
my dad's a dentist I know good teeth and
this guy smiles and I just I just start
shooting
and uh
and then my night vision dies again but
I got quality aimed shots with a pq2
alpha
and I figured I got them both and one
guy ran
and the other one got trapped between
the jersey barrier and the uh stairwell
he couldn't move out of that area so he
was pretty much
done
um and but the other guy ran to the
kitchen in front
and I was like okay one guy that's it
one guy left and he was wounded you know
I hit him a couple times
um
and then as I'm doing that I'm walking
backwards away from the stairwell and
I'm like this is a room and I'm just
standing in the doorway of a room
and then as soon as I'm thinking I
haven't cleared this room yet
guy from the kitchen starts shooting
back
and then Lawson with his nine mil is
just you know gangster from the side
just popping this guy
and this guy starts shooting a Lawson uh
from the kitchen
and as he's doing that losses just kind
of Pops back into the water
and whether he had hit through the wall
or got I don't know I don't know it's
dark I don't know what's happening he's
not saying anything which is smart all
right you don't want to he's a tough guy
he's been hurt before and he's never
cried or screamed or anything so he just
kind of went back and he just his whole
arm just drops and he got his hand on
his shoulder
and he's reaching for his neck and he's
like is this blood or water
and I'm like oh no like that's not the
choice I can't see he's like it feels
it's slick I'm like but the water's
slick you know the one he's I'm he's
doing this like with his hand he's Nami
can't move his fingers
so he's like he just points to his
weapon and with one finger says I have
one mag left
doesn't he just won and I'm like okay
and so I switch out mags and I back into
this room
and it's a master bedroom and I have
there's like
a bed a wardrobe
and and uh
I I gotta clear it right and as I'm
doing that these guys come running
through the door and so now we're
exchanging fire
but I'm noticing that there are tracers
going horizontally in the room and I'm
thinking is my zero off like am I am I
just you know like because I'm shooting
from the hip and the PS4 teams are
coming on and off
and I'm like am I shooting to the side
you know is this Pikachu did it get
damaged did it get jostled
what's happening well these rounds are
going horizontal and uh my platoon
Sergeant's screaming in my radio
and with that noise from my ear everyone
and I hear a Cavalcade of foot steps
upstairs next room over and I'm like
this radio is going to be the death of
me so I just take I I I told him I said
two efforts down one RPG I'm really
stressed out right now
I'm really stressed out right now and I
just threw the radio in the water
and uh and that that's when I realized
that
I I could start to cheat a little bit
and use the gap of my night visions
solid for a little bit and I just have
that Pika too and I could use the gap
between the frame of the of the door and
the concrete metal frame and there's
like a hole and that that dude was just
like
like trying to creep up on the door
and I'm like I got you you know and so I
just put the rounds through that Gap and
I couldn't have done it without a laser
obviously
and uh he buckled and but the weirdest
thing was guys would fall
and I'd look over and they weren't there
and so I'm like is this Hollywood's
obviously full of crap but I mean it's
just the same guy
or is this a different guy
is he running up down the stairs what's
going on
and just as that happens
um
another guy comes tearing down the
stairs and you can I could hear his
pants
um and as he hits the water again that
Ripple gave him away in the water
and he just started firing and I popped
him and then the guy came out of the
kitchen the original guy that was when
he came out of the kitchen
and then all of a sudden I'm just kind
of relaxed and everything's cool
and uh I hear some guy screaming
from the stairwell
uh and he's it's like British a British
accent and he's just like talking and uh
I don't know if it's Lawson I don't know
if it's Michael what Michael what is
Australian is he talking to me but this
guy's like talking about like the your
mommy won't find your dog tags
and I'm like his face you know what do
you I don't know are you trying to
intimidate me like so I'm speaking
broken Arabic
first Infantry Division manual stop or
I'll shoot do not resist first American
Infantry
all that crap and then I hear like dog
or something instead of kelp whatever
and as I'm going through all that
another Target appears in the door and
I'm shooting that Target
and I see a long stream of of rifle fire
that is from my left out of a wardrobe
straight into the wall
and I'm like I did not I didn't just
shoot that was not me you know what I
mean and I'm like oh my God there's a
dude in this room
and as soon as I even process that the
doors just come flying open
and he runs out and he's got a snub nose
AK under his armpit
so he's running this way and the rifle's
pointing behind him and he's just
squeezing it like behind him oh okay
right so he's planning to try and get
out of the road I think he's just trying
to get up but he's it's dark and he
can't see anything
and the Wardrobe falls on its doors
which again there's a lot of Miracles
but that is probably the most miraculous
thing is an entire wardrobe like a Foot
Locker you know like a wall Locker that
landed on its doors because if that
thing would have fallen flat he shot
right into that wall Locker into that
wardrobe and had that thing been flat
that would have gone right into me and
the side of the wall as well
and it just absorbed through the the
wall
I took
um I I thought I could hit the elbow
and I it just instantly it's it's wet
but I'm wet too so it's like what's
going on but I remember grabbing my arm
and I'm doing this inventory of like you
did it you got shot
and it's not that bad right it's not
that bad it hurts
you can't see it but you are now a
bullet shot you've been a victim of a
bullet wound and all these guys that
acted tough you now know what they went
through you're just as tough as they are
you're not gonna you're not gonna scream
medic you're not gonna leave you're
gonna breathe you got shot in the arm
and you're good to go you're lucky stay
in the fight everything's good
and then I'm like this really hurts like
you know what I mean like it really
hurts and I'm like oh okay but I'm like
I'm psyching myself up right
dude is at the corn he's leaning against
the the metal the doors weren't like
real doors they're like metallic tin
doors and he's leaning against it and I
hit him
now again I thought I hit him six or
seven times the video it's like three
shots but again what I'm thinking what
actually happened I thought I hit it
repeatedly but I got him on the lower
back
and it was the first time I heard
someone like actually scream like really
loud and he moves his way out the door
but I hear him up the stairs and this is
the time where I get to do my little
field you know medic I'm gonna treat my
own arm wound put a tourniquet on yeah I
have no idea like it's below it's right
here in the little joint area of my
elbow
and I'm like oh my God I feel I feel the
bullet like the bullet is actually in my
arm and this is crazy because there's no
Kevlar and it would make no sense that a
bullet would Lodge and just kind of stay
there
so I'm like Oh I Feel Dizzy but is it
the smell is it my nerves I can't pass
out now and I just kind of flick it out
and I feel it it's a it's like a piece
of wallet it's a splinter and I'm like
dude you went from almost being shot by
a bullet to a splinter and you were
gonna take yourself out of this fight
you know what I mean like Call of
Medevac for a splinter I went from
thinking I'm just like every other tough
guy I saw get shots being like you don't
even can't take a splinter like you were
gonna punch out for a Splinter Man you
know what I mean so like my head is
going from like super confident
to
but when he left and he turned and I saw
his face
I'm like he's scared
and I liked the fact that I hit him
repeatedly
he's wounded and he's scared and he
wants to run away from me
so I figured okay
Lawson go get
I'm yelling the law said I need saws and
shotguns and fits and first squat get
everyone get the whole platoon in here
and he's like I'm not leaving
and I'm like no you gotta leave because
we need to get everyone in here right
so I don't want to be on that floor
because I'm thinking Bradley Fire or the
guys just come and start spraying I have
nowhere to get cover
and the best place I want to be at least
on the second floor to tell them hey you
know smoke grenade flare I'm here right
but I know that guy's there and I look
up the stairs and I could see his wet
feet but then there's blood like a lot
of blood on the stairs
and I make my way up in between my wet
shoes my wet boots
and the blood I take a step on the
puddle of blood
and both feet just go completely out
like like I lost my footy completely and
when I lost my footing uh at that moment
around just went off from the second
level of the stairs
and it was right and our our bullets
when they hit like brick or concrete
Ricochet that 762 just
it just bugged it just went right
through it but I could see it
and I was like that's where my head was
right and so I went from I got this guy
to I just slipped and if I didn't stand
up I would have been done
and then when I got to the second level
uh my ps14s
went I went to when I went to flick them
on they went to IR you know that uh
liked it yeah that shines and I saw his
face and he was just all kinds of
stressed
I imagine he was very stressed and I was
like this guy's mine and one more that's
it so I'm doing my head I'm like one two
three or is it one two three four
like I I'm just trying to do an
inventory of how many are there still
people alive downstairs
did I just leave Lawson and where would
alive guys or is this just two guys that
I'm just losing it do you know if Lawson
went to get the rest of the squad yet I
can't hear anything my hearing's gone
and not only that I can't
the the the the building is so big and
thick that with the water if it was
empty and dry maybe you could hear
Echoes of whatever but the only thing
you could really hear was what was
coming at you when something went from
hits the water the water was the
giveaway that there was someone coming
because you could hear the splash
and you could see the signature of it
but upstairs is dry it was super dry up
there and uh
now I'm I'm back to um
I got my rifle and I charged a magazine
and I think I this was the last what
felt it felt like 20 that had shot maybe
just one of those I recharged and didn't
have full 30. but I took out my grenade
and and this is where I was going to
practice my cooking off I was so proud
of how I cooked grenades off I was
cooking grenades off at the 12th grade
level you know I I was really good at it
at that point and uh that's Sizzle you
know so many guys would tape their
spoons
and then they just throw the grenade
with the tape off but the spoon would
stick to the casing
right you pull your pin and you threw it
and it never went off because the spoon
stuck to the it had been taped for so
long
so I I was I guess unhappy to me I'm I'm
and I and I brought it to my ear
you got to be careful because you know
defense contractors five seconds two
seconds
but I couldn't hear the sizzle
my ears are so shot that I was like
one
two and I just was like oh no you know
like that's how this story ends with me
blowing my own head off with a grenades
of my ear like he was taking a call like
Massad blew me up for taking a call
and I as I turned to look at him
I the room was an L shape right so I had
like a like a perpendicular I threw the
grenade I hit him with a grenade but it
went into a big pile of these foam
mattresses and uh
I heard it Kaboom and I heard him uh you
know hurt
and it got bit by something it shrad
will hit him somewhere but when I came
into the room I instantly tripped over
my my shin uh scraped off the top of a
just a mess of propane tanks I mean the
entire room was full of ProPay tanks I
fired one around and I just smelled
this like really oily Thick Smoke that
was like plastic foam burning and
natural gas
and I and I just like I can't I can't
shoot again because I'm gonna blow the
tanks up or do whatever so I just kind
of use my uh rifle to find him in the
room of smoke and wave the smoke around
and just try to find where he is and
whack him as hard as I could and that's
where
you know I we just started wailing on
each other uh in the dark and the smoke
just kind of where is he where is he at
and um
I didn't want to bend the barrel the the
M4
is a rifle that you know I butt stroked
people with that plastic butt and it's
it doesn't really do what you want it to
do but the problem with the M4 is that
if you whack someone hard enough you're
going to bend your Barrel
right so I mean that you're taking your
rifle out of the fight I got sanos's
rifle but it's heavier you know the A4
had that stock that was you know and so
that that's much better to go into
the fight with an M4 would be
um so I tried to take advantage of that
and I I really it was the first time I
realized how how exhausted I was I was I
was really spent you know and I was
starting to feel like my stomach
was tightening and breathing became
harder and and uh I I was hoping that I
could
just get close to him and shoot him
right like like be able to get a close
shot into him
but I also realized that when a person
is fighting for their life they're not
gonna give you any of those openings and
I could tell he was older
um thus the foam would burn and then die
and then a flame would pop and then it
would die and then a flame would pop
again and he had a Gray beard
and he was wearing a bandolier like uh
you know around his waist
um
and so
yeah we it was like every time I thought
I had an advantage he had a big gouge
out of his uh his arm his uh forearm had
a giant bite from shrapnel and
so when he would do something to me
I would just kind of put my hands in
that that wound and that and it just
complete you know that he that was so
much pain that he would you could tell
him his guard was down
but this is why we need to teach
self-defense and and Jiu Jitsu or
something because
in the gear it's hard enough to move you
know God forbid if I had elbow pads on I
would I wouldn't have made it he but the
the vest is so heavy and the way we load
the vest is he makes it even more
unbalanced
I didn't have any moves I didn't have a
choke I didn't have anything to do and
my hands were wet
uh usually hair
um so I I stuck my finger in his eye and
I figured
that that was
gonna to do it and I I was so freaked
out by the way an eyeball
you know ruptures that it it just
unnerved me the whole thing was just so
it seemed like I was cheating you know
what I mean like I was
doing something that was
um did not what we're supposed to do I
never had an experience with uh
with anything like that before I've
never done anything like that uh in my
life training no one's ever given us a
PowerPoint or class on that and
and I have my helmet
you know and and so I figured
my helmet is probably but I my ps14s
were on the helmet and the tie down at
that point when I took my helmet off the
we these no one ties the elites don't
tie things down but we tie everything
down because we're so irresponsible you
never know when you lose something and
and I had a I I tied it down but when I
took my helmet off my 14s fell and now
you've got like this uh you know
pendulum and so it's it's not you're not
able to get what you want
now the the part of the story that gets
misinterpreted a lot is the I took a
sappy plate and everyone said I took my
sappy plate out
I opened my vest
and on an IBA at that time it was velcro
one side had a plate the other side
didn't
and so as I was trying to hit him I
wasn't getting enough force with my
helmet I I I took his head and I just
kind of used the open vest to subdue
them
if you ask me that's when the fight
really stopped that I would think that I
that at that point it was I don't think
he was we weren't equals at that point
whatever you got the upper hand yeah
like the wounds that he was sustaining
to his head between the helmet and the
sappy plate were enough to either
disorient him or or make him
just not a a a problem at least in my
own head I thought everything was great
uh and he goes to the ground and when he
goes to the ground
um I put my hand over his mouth and I'm
literally all my Force has got one hand
the one arm is wounded and when I put my
leg on it he's come like his hips are
coming up he's uh it's hurting him but
then he's yelling
and then I hear a guy above us yell back
and that's when I completely went from
I'm in control and I'm gonna be okay
to complete you know a panic of I don't
have the strength I don't have the
strength to do this
right and he's wounded I mean shoot me
four times you know I don't know if I
could do what he's doing but if there's
another guy that I have not yet met and
he's 100 healthy
I'm in deep trouble I'm I'm in trouble
and so as work where I've lost complete
positive control on my rifle at this
point now I'm trying to find it with one
foot
and just kind of probe my foot out to
find my strap I could drag it to to me
or do whatever
and uh he bites my hand really
aggressively
um right and it's
it's like now I'm I'm firing on
you know I thought I had him in a good
grip where I could at least and I
thought the fight was out of him
and he just starts biting me and then as
I move up my body
the hand that I was not holding
I just I just heard a loud crack of what
turned out to be a Soviet 45.
I don't even know where he had it or
where it came from but I just fired
directly in the wrong he didn't thank
God he didn't know where my head was but
it was close enough to my head that it
went from not being able to hear cloudy
to like ringing not being able to hear
you know which is it's like a tinnitus
versus I just can't hear you know and
that was that was really like it
affected my equilibrium and affected
my thought process things became dire I
went from Super confident to like this
isn't going to work out and the and when
I stood up
um looking for my rifle I felt that I
had my Gerber in my cargo pocket not on
my belt which would have been almost
impossible with the adrenaline and the
sweat and the water to to pull that out
it was so tight to my belt that it would
have been
you know but it was in my cargo pocket
and uh
and a lot of people think that's a
multi-tool they say he killed you know
the multi-tool came out it was a Rex
Applegate
you know a very quick release
um
and uh I I just figured I would uh I
would just pop them I was just gonna let
them know you know
I was speaking broken Arabic it turns
out he didn't even speak Arabic but I
was just trying to tell him to shut up
and uh so I could hear what was being
said or how many were you know was is it
our guys maybe it's it's my guys coming
up and I just can't hear
and so I just I was just letting them
know I have a knife and uh and then it
was he bit me again and when he bit me
you know in my he bit you know my lower
body and and that was
unbelievable pain it was unbelievable
pain and it was just a
complete adrenaline Spike and it became
I'm gonna I'm just gonna jab him you
know I'm gonna I'm gonna cut him and
when I when I put it in it hits
collarbone
and uh it caught my uh side of my pinky
down uh my hands kind of went
off the blade and kind of went to the
to the knife and uh it nothing happened
it was too hard and it was not in the
right region and then
when I put my hand over his neck I kind
of felt where I could guide it and as
soon as I put it in it was a cold night
it was a Rainy Night
I felt steam like warm hot
Steam
and there was a noise that
I couldn't I couldn't hear the noise but
I could feel the noise it's a
it's like you there was a uh the spurt
was this is
and everything just Auto rebooted he was
just like it was over it was like there
was no
you know there was no uh response to it
you know and uh
the only thing I took enough science
to know that I could speed it up and so
I just kind of was doing like a little
bit of um like a CPR almost
I just
get just to end it you know just to get
all of it out
and so I just started putting you know
like doing CPR uh to to end it and
and that's that was it and after all
that I I
it was ridiculous and it wasn't
I wanted a cigarette
you know and uh I went outside and and
again my helmet's gone
my vest is open
my rifle is somewhere on the ground
I have
a magazine Maybe
I don't know eight rounds left uh 10
Rounds much less than 30.
and I know there's a guy above me but
it's a porch and there's a roof on top
of it
and so I just kind of
cupped my hands but I wanted the
cigarette to be like my light
right because I have no night vision and
I figure if I get that cherry going
I could at least signal someone if
they're coming in because I haven't you
know
I figured I could at least see something
get some nicotine I mean I wanted
nicotine but I also wanted to see like
what was going on Signal do whatever
and as I'm dragging that outside open
air
I just hear like uh
like someone like took off like a
Scuttle of feet
and like the the most grotesque Joe
Theisman snap
um I've ever witnessed I played Sports
I've seen guys you know break legs and
compound fractures Achilles injuries
I've never that was a bad one and
whatever he landed on
completely immobilized him when he
landed on the ground and um
he was was in severe distressed and and
emotional about how much he was hurting
and the magazine swiveled out of his uh
you know uh no butt stock on the AK
um it was a short AK with no buttstock
and the magazine was out and when I
threw it back in and and reached
recharged it it just it was way it burst
it was on automatic and it just burst
and very little accuracy I don't think I
hit him with AK
and then when I ran into the the
building uh he fell like back into a
water tank in the corner
and he couldn't move his like he was one
leg was the only thing that was causing
you know it was ability to move but the
rifle I I ran into the rifle and uh my
rifle
and so I I picked it up and I just shot
um until it went empty and I don't I hit
him I I could see that you know I hit
him and I hit his wounded leg and I hit
him in the back near the kidney
and all I know is I didn't know if there
was a landing he a canop there was a
canopy underneath that part of the
building
but I just heard the saws open up on
them
so when I looked over finally
um
I could see that he was you know head
first in the in the palm area and the
two machine Gunners had
had done their thing and then the guys
come flying in
and Lawson ends up getting shot by a
shotgun
Lawson uh total accident but Lawson
basically was on the Second Story
and he was like Terminators our guys are
called Terminators Terminators coming in
and he just kind of turned the corner
and and someone hit him in the sappy
play but that could have been horrific
and so the next they're like bomb is
coming in
bomb's coming in
and I just
my voice was hoarse I was like totally
like you know
Shook and uh we ran out of the house and
um
fast mover Dropped a Bomb and it went
right through that you hear it like Ting
Tong like you would hear it like it
didn't go off
and then uh they brought so that was a
250. they brought in a 500. that thing
bounced
and I don't know if it was our laser if
it was the few I don't know what
happened two bombs were duds
the final one was a two thousand pound
bomb and we were all
like outside of the house that blast
was worse than anything that happened
inside the house I mean it just voided
all of our
I mean just like we just vom like
uncontrollable vomiting like so you were
just outside the house when the 2000s
the Bradley so the Bradley's all pulled
up on the line and the guys got inside
the Bradleys and zipped up
and Fitz had grabbed me
as I was making sure all the guys were
in the brats he just grabbed me threw me
in a hole
and honestly we got the best end of it
because the guys that were in the Brads
got just completely concussed from that
boxed in area and all that munition I
mean danger close I'd say it was
I don't know 200 meters
from where the bomb went off and the all
the periscopes on the side of the Brads
were all shattered
um and the guys were all like woozy and
vomited it was really bad I mean they
got shook really really good we were
outside
and I think we got the better end of it
I think I think because we were low and
in a hole we didn't get nearly as messed
up as all of it
but we go back in pull the bodies out
um
you know start doing our inventory
and uh
the next day
uh I want dice our executive officer and
then JC Madison died and then Sims died
and it just kind of was like crazy day
but there's like 12 other crazy days to
go and we just kind of did our thing and
and then 15 years later I get a call
that the dod is doing an investigation
and people I haven't talked to in 15
years are calling me telling me that
they're looking into every aspect of my
military career and I'm thinking like a
lot of guys have happened someone gets a
little jealous
someone gets upset
and they said something happened the way
I had a reporter investigating and the
military calling I lawyered up I got a
lawyer
and I was like you know I'm not going to
jail like what's going on and then Trump
called
before we get to that yeah before we get
to that so the the this whole story that
you just told about being in this house
um this is November 10th
2004 this is your your 29th birthday
29th birthday yeah this is two days into
the battle yes because there's a couple
days and there's a little bit of a lull
as it kicks off you know right it's hard
for you guys to get through the breach
you guys get in there and
it takes a couple days I mean there's
action out of the gate but it but this
is definitely a highlight uh for what
you guys were doing yeah
um
like you said Lieutenant ewon November
12th he's standing in a Brad
he's actually waving goodbye to to where
who's going to like
fit fill his report or whatever he's
going to do
and he gets hit with uh
he gets hit with an RPG
um RPG doesn't detonate so it's like
awful
um
you you got in in the book remember the
ramrods you've got this this quote they
take you know his brother had died and
you explain this in the book and again
there's so many there's so many things
in this book
but you know his brother had died in
1989 and so
uh Ed ewon they his parents want him
buried you know in the cemetery in their
small town in uh Nebraska I believe
and there's a
inscription on his grave about about
Lieutenant Eddie Wan it says Ed lived
every moment he stood in the rain heard
the Thunder danced to the lightning
and believed in rainbows
that's
the 12th the next day the individual
that we've talked a bunch about
Captain Sims who's your who's your
company Commander
um a guy and it's it's you know I don't
think I covered this but as you guys are
going in you know this guy realizes what
kind of a fight you're about to go into
and it's not going to be a hearts and
mind fight and you guys
all really come together as and he knows
he's going to be relying on his door
kickers
um and
so the next day after uh Lieutenant ewon
dies
Captain Sims he's um
kind of catching up with you guys on the
battlefield you guys are tired
and he's gonna go
basically do a strong point in the
building kind of set up a little command
post or something
and you know you're like hey boss let me
let me go clear that thing for you let
me get my squad in there let me clear
that thing and he's like no you guys get
some rest stand down he says air out
your feet get some child we'll take care
of it
and um it was a building that had been
cleared but
you know it that had been left and
cleared and left and when these guys go
in it
um
they get into a gunfight
captain since Captain Sims is killed
and like you said you know this is and
this is something sometimes people
forget is that when someone gets killed
in combat combat continues
and you you still have a mission you
still have an enemy and you still keep
going
and that's what that's what happens you
guys keep going
uh for a total of 10 days
it's
November 17th you guys finally come out
of the field
um
and you got some great
you got some great
perspective in there you know as you're
coming out of the field and what that's
like you guys are now
uh seen way more than anybody else has
seen in certain the the ramps in the
rear you know they're trying to tell you
to get your uniform squared away in this
stuff and uh always that that that
contrast between the guys that are on
the front lines the guys that aren't
the Time magazine article comes out so
Michael Ware like you said works for
time
so you guys are out of the field on
November 17th November 22nd this article
comes out that he's written it's called
Uh Into The Hot Zone and it's
it's telling your story uh you're it's
telling your company's story
and of course I mean you know the uh the
Fallujah event was in every it was the
entire news for you know three week
period and so now everybody is reading
this article about you about your guys
um and all that being said deployment's
not over yet
you guys still have another three months
of deployment left
what are you guys doing when you get out
of Fallujah what's that recovery like
and and now what's your mission towards
the end of deployment
so you know we don't really know about
the magazine the article
um but everyone in our sector knows
about Fallujah
and they know that when we were gone we
were replaced by units that didn't have
the same logo on their arms Insignia and
what that meant the the red one and
uh that we were in Fallujah and that
bought us a tremendous amount of Street
credit with the with the bad guys
you know it's
um
we were super cocky we were super
confident
uh and we weren't you know the mistakes
that we made the zigging and zagging in
the old days was long gone the chances
we were taking you know they always talk
about how when you know John the John
Basilone story of
you know you got a guy that does crazy
things at Guadalcanal and then he wants
to go back to Iwo
and the unit that he led I mean they got
a John Basilone
um is a legend and an icon he's selling
war bonds he's dating Hollywood starlets
I mean this was a national hero
and everyone hung on everything he said
he had so much Street Credit
he didn't last what 15 minutes on ewo
and and so there are things that the
reason why they take you out when things
like Fallujah ramadi big set plays where
units do crazy things it's because you
you don't have a sense of of your
mortality and you you do take chances
that you think well it hasn't happened
yet you know I'll roll it until you know
we fold and
our unit was doing that I mean we were
just like
in the old days if you took fire the
enemy stopped
you know you'd give Chase you'd do your
job but at the end of the day
we fired they stopped they ran away who
cares after Fallujah we we were going to
kill you like we were going to take you
out and it didn't matter how long it
went down it didn't matter you know we
had guys going through tunnels and you
know it's very difficult to clear an
attic you know that's one of the most
dangerous things you can do because
you're literally just popping up in the
middle of a floor and anything can hit
you and those are always you know guys
were just doing things they'd never done
before because they survived what was
you know an epic urban fight
and I noticed it and I noticed that
election day was the big thing the
battleship was because January 2005 was
going to be the first free election and
all of the craziness that we're gonna
that was going to happen on Election Day
and so our mission came to just we had a
pretty good handle on diala Province
before Felucia when we left there was
that period where they regressed a
little bit just because the unit you
know you're brand new you don't know the
area very well great soldiers they just
didn't know our area
and so they were only there for a month
and a half and we started to see that
they were taking liberties we took those
Liberties back we counter punched we did
great things
but it also became a way like it it was
real now like the guys were gone they
weren't etsing they weren't going to a
different Duty station they were no
longer there in the memorial services
and the you know
and you just take more loss towards the
end of a deployment you think why are we
taking loss at the end we're so close to
just going home like is this what's the
point what are we doing
and so that became more of a struggle of
keeping Our poise and our Focus but also
the discipline was the hardest for
leaders at the end that's when all the
crazy happens like in the last 30 days
of a deployment is when nothing can be
rationalized no loss no injury no death
nothing makes any sense because you're
that close to the finish line
and it takes a lot to just kind of you
know maybe I'm going a little bit too
crazy you know what you don't want is
you don't want you know that that guy
who's getting out of the army he's got a
month left in a combat zone and this is
Jerry Rice's last football game and he
wants one more touchdown before he hangs
it up I don't want a guy who wants one
more fight
you know before he hangs it up you know
so you you want to be reasonable but at
the same time professional and
disciplined
uh but that was that was tough because
you know there's and then the units are
coming in to replace you and they've
done nothing but red you become our unit
became like army rock stars you know
they they were in magazines in their
army times in the and so guys are taking
photos with these new guys and signing
furniture and this is the coffee maker
from the Gunner of the you know like
they it was a weird feeling uh to hear
your unit and these names of guys that
you work with every day and they're in
Rolling Stone magazine they're in
they're on CNN they're talking about
Funk hey turn on could you take me Fox
News they're doing a special on on
Sergeant Falkenburg like what like it's
just our major like it was the it was a
very surreal
um experience to go from the Backwater
and a unit that really peaked in Vietnam
to to the first Infantry Division back
where it's cool again and all these guys
who just did their jobs are now you know
doing interviews
you know you've got reporters that are
sneaking onto the fob
to interview the boys from Fallujah a
month later
and it's just like it was very surreal
um
you know because it's just a lot of
attention and it's not necessarily
people process it differently you know
and you guys end up going home in
February 2005 yeah and at what point are
you deciding that you're going to get
out of the army
you know my whole thing was so I didn't
know anything about you know the Time
Magazine everything you hear about you
know you're in a vacuum
but the there was a big award ceremony
going on for the division and a welcome
home and again we're a German unit
and it was a lot of silver stars and
bronze stars and a lot of these guys
that did incredible things you know it
was hard to get a private a specialist
in E5 the award that they deserve a lot
of guys that really never squeezed
around were getting awards that probably
you know aren't Service Awards not Valor
Awards you you have that in every unit
but it was apparent that they were going
to take this Fallujah fight and
essentially make this award
a distinguished service cross
and that's the way it was built we did
the unit the Brigade Commander Paul Ray
Smith had just received the Medal of
Honor the first recipient since Vietnam
posthumously for what happened in 2003
at the airport in Baghdad
and so this was going to be
the second a distinguished service cross
which would have been the first
distinguished service across since
Vietnam so we got the Medal of Honor and
the distinguished service cross and this
is what you're hearing about your award
yeah so so I'm getting the DSC that's
that's the way the the ceremony is going
to be all the guys get their silver
stars or bronze stars and we're going to
hold the DSC Secretary of the armies
coming to Germany whole division it's a
DSC award I did a commercial for armed
forces Network talking about
getting the DSC and the DSC is in the
back I mean that it was happening
and if that's going all going down
they're basically saying no one knows
anything more than the DSC and it's not
an award that you you know you don't
know how to write it and the witnesses
and so the division did the DSC with
Battalion and Witnesses and whatnot and
uh Secretary of the army shows up day of
the award uh would do their rehearsals
we're getting ready for the Live the
band The Division Commander and the
secretary of the Army is like belvey's
not getting the DSC
and so I'm like
all right you know like what that kind
of sucks I mean we did the commercials
yeah I'm in my uniform here like what is
going on and they're like
they're upgrading it and I didn't even
you know I I was like they're upgrading
the DSC I mean it doesn't make any sense
like what is going on and
it went from being upgraded to just you
know Army times USA Today all these
media people telling the world that I'm
going to I'm nominated for the Medal of
Honor which is not something the Army
puts out no one puts that out you can't
say you're nominated for anything it's
not you know you're either approved or
you either get it or you don't there's
no like you didn't get the Medal of
Honor give them the DFC it's the Medal
of Honor nothing right you can take a
silver star and upgrade it you can take
a DSC and upgrade it but you don't get
like a fallback award you know it
doesn't work in reverse
so I go home I leave there was a lot
that happened on that deployment and our
unit was disbanded
so half of the guys went to another unit
and deployed in in eight months the rest
of the guys went to stop-loss guys went
home everyone went home
and I just was like I'm going to be a
civilian and uh
I wanted to do some embedding I wanted
to do you know some other stuff work
some vets groups and whatnot and then I
get a a package in the mail
and it's the Silver Star
and it isn't my citation it's not my
name and I'm like this has to be a
mistake right it's not on my gd214 it's
not your citation it's not your name no
it's just like I jumped on a tank and
you know I suppressed the enemy it's
basically the Silver Star was for
stepping in the doorway with a saw got
it and then there's something with a
Bradley that I didn't do
and then my middle my name is spelled
wrong but it's not on my TD 214 and the
orders aren't signed so I'm like
you know what's going on and now
everyone's like you're gonna get the
medal of honor and the media is like
this is happening the Silver Star it's
an interim award
you're going to hold on to that and then
you're going to get the middle of Honor
well that goes on forever and then
it nothing happened
and so people so what are you doing so
now it's you're out of the army I'm out
of the army uh I I decide I want to go
back in the Army
um but I don't want to I have a family
and I want to be a dad I want to get a
normal job and then I hear so you're
conflicted conflicted I go and become an
embedded reporter uh I start a veterans
group we start running Democrat
Republican Veterans for congress we have
a great class Lee zeldin who's running
for governor in New York was one of our
first guys Alan West was one of our
first guys uh we've had some good ones
we've had some bad ones but we we ran
you know quality guys and and girls and
in the process of doing that I meet all
of these like there's a class that is
started where there's like a
professional veteran class that comes
out of Afghanistan in Iraq and I'm super
cognizant that I don't want to be that
guy I don't want to be the DD214 guy in
my car you know what I mean I don't want
to be the guy that's low crawling to the
cop here you know it's like hey what
time well zero Niner we're gonna like
stop another brief all right like you
work at an Office Depot like you do not
have an actual Depot and so I I don't
want to be that guy and I want to be
like a normal guy but every time
something happens with the war my local
newspaper my local whatever is like this
guy's getting the Medal of Honor
and then people want to write books
and the books they're writing are not
the stories that happened they're like
you know then you know he's killed eight
people single-handedly uh yeah but
that's one story you know how many
people he killed over here and it's like
wait a second first of all how much
money are you getting what's going on
here like you're making
money off of our friends our stuff
what's what's why are you sharing these
stories they're not true
and then I got to hang out with guys
like Marcus Luttrell and I saw the
veteran side of celebrity
in a way that made me super grateful for
my life because Marcus was a 50 50. 50
of the country thought Marcus Luttrell
is truly one of the greatest treasures
we have in our planet he's a humble
decent wonderful man that went through
some crazy things
and then 50 were like I hate him because
he's successful and known why is he
famous why do I care about Marcus
Luttrell
and I'm watching him go through this
and I'm seeing
that for every guy that wants to shake
his hand for every girl that wants his
phone number
there are 50 people that want to put him
in jail and there's 30 people that want
to call him a fraud and go after a story
and go after his friends and he's doing
this journey
and it's like he's a Pioneer like he's
discovering the Oregon Trail and he's
doing it all by himself
and it was uncharted waters uncharted
waters with Grace and dignity
and he can't win every everyone's out to
to to to snipe him and I remember he
told me one day we were in Texas doing
something and he said you are so lucky
it's not the Medal of Honor because it's
crazy as this is the medal of honor to
be worse and I'm like you know what
maybe you're right I'm blessed salgianta
first living recipient
I see this guy he's on at the Super Bowl
he's on the Letterman show and I look at
his face
and I'm like this guy it's got the
weight of the world and he is just just
getting Buzz sawed I mean there's you're
the great you can't take anything away
from solgiato what he stands for what he
did who he is how he leads his but
they're still people don't want to just
rip him to shreds and go after his unit
and his decisions and does he well I
heard he was I come on man give the guy
and he's the only one and there's no net
there's no support there's no one he
could talk to a Vietnam guy nothing just
gianta on his own doing his own thing
and I said Thank God this was the first
I was like and then it became well maybe
the story isn't true
I mean you didn't you didn't get the
award that they said you're gonna get so
they did the investigation and obviously
you didn't do [__] this is [__]
right so now I'm like wait a second I go
from going from being like the Susan
Lucci of combat veterans I'm nominated
for a Daytime Emmy for 18 years not
getting it
it's an honor to be nominated now when
did you do your embedded reporting so so
this is six so 2006 you freaking in
ramadi when I'm there yeah no so that
which is crazy and major Megan McClung
was the Pao who lost her life in the for
the Marines and I thought I got approved
because I'm like the only guy that wants
to be there at the end of that tour at
the end of that little time she said
will you sign my Time Magazine
and I was like no way like she's like
yeah come on what do you think we're
stupid like yeah you show up here no one
wants to be here we just wanted to make
sure you weren't coming here to be a
hero and you were coming here to do
something stupid and when it was
appeared you know it was apparent that
you had your heart in the right place
we thought you could you could use your
platform to tell them what we're doing
because we're doing great things
everybody no one's talking about it at
all
what was it like when you were on the
ground there and Romani yeah that was
the worst place I've ever been in my
life I would I would take ramadi I would
get an apartment a Fallujah before in
2006 ramadi was insane and and I'm not
telling you anything you don't know but
I'm you know as you're sometimes you
don't
sometimes you you can go through
something that's really bad compared to
another bad thing but unless you have
the perspective to know like
okay I saw the Army the Marine Corps and
the seals right
uh there was no differential the only
time you could tell Elite people just by
the way they move you know the fluid
nature of how special operations do
their thing the Rangers incredible Mars
the marine Special Operations marsac
um you know all these guys Recon these
are some studs right
I never was in an area where I could not
tell
because of just the over the just on the
disproportionate amount of brazen enemy
attacks you could not differentiate what
unit they were attacking until 40
minutes into the fight and the
objectives were being pushed and you
could actually see it was that crazy it
could have been 101st could have been
third Marines it could have been Navy
Seals there are 60 guys running around
doing whatever the hell they want to do
and it is just uh snipers and hides
that was where we found the guy
on a on a a table with a hole cut in the
table
and there was human waste human urine
hooked up with IV bags and someone just
went in there and threw water on a
blanket
I mean the dedication to just lay in a
hide with an IV for your food
that Romani was nuts and you know the
the cement truck bombs the video of it
no one was covering it we had a a time
was just balcony journalism you heard a
story a Stringer gave you a video of an
IED you put on the news nothing on the
ground nothing Tactical
uh are we winning ramani was a fight
that actually was like an anaconda just
squeezing the life
out of these insurgents and the more you
killed
you saw a clear reduction of violence I
mean a clear reduction of violence like
you might have Five Guys you couldn't
recruit
when you just had that kinetic fight the
snipers were crazy the mortars were
crazy
uh it wasn't
um
and the civilian population was was
still there but you saw the beginning of
the sons of Iraq you saw the beginning
of the anbar Awakening in 2006 but most
importantly you saw the population see
enemy combatants that were muja Deen as
the actual occupiers that was the first
time was romantic06 when Americans are
like they're the bigger tribe they're
not going anywhere they're good people
they're honest they just want to be left
alone
play the game work the job do whatever
take their money
but these guys from Syria I don't want
them I don't want these guys coming in
from wherever they're the occupiers get
a ran out get these people out
um and and we'll be fine
but ramadi it was not a good place and
and it was uh it was also weird to see
people lose their life
and watch someone mourn
someone that I didn't know like I'd
never been around someone who was hurt
or killed that I didn't have a
connection to
and watch that extremely personal
you feel like a stranger
you feel like um
you're intruding that that's not why
we're we're there we're not that's a
very personal thing
and that was that was really crazy too
and when I was in ramadi I had a kidney
stone and I remember being medevaced
by one of the seals out there
and the last thing he told me I mean I
was trying to I didn't want to drink
their water because then I it was weird
because like you they don't they don't
want you there like no one cares about
you you could be missing for days and
they're like what I don't know everyone
and and so they were like I'm gonna buy
you a drink
and I was like yeah that'd be great I
guess he meant he was going to give me
pain meds
but when I came to I was on the on the
shoulder of a grown man
I was thinking please don't know who I
am you know I mean like I don't want to
be the guy from Time Magazine that's
being carried off like you know a
sandbag but they did surgery on me there
and removed the stones and gave me a a
uh a catheter and a I had stents put in
it was nuts and then they sent me back
out into ramadi and I remember this guy
this guy came up to me he's like hey I
got your Flomax do you need fluma look
you guys are issuing Flomax
prescriptions
we have evolved since 2004. but that I I
got to see the hospitals and the
surgical units and how hard those men
and women work and the ground units but
the people of ramadi gave me hope that
this is actually going in the right
direction I couldn't say that about
dialla diala was worse and and I went
back to dial in 08 same area that I I
fought in I went back to Fallujah in 06.
didn't really seem all that great
uh I mean it wasn't better
um and then in 2008 it went back to
Fallujah and they had a fight at a city
council meeting over solar lights for
their traffic signals and I was thinking
damn we uh they're more green than we
are yeah that's for sure but
yeah
the moral of story is uh when when I got
out the award I didn't know what was
happening with it and it everyone kind
of turned immediately people were like
this isn't real this you're bullshitting
this story is not true you know Gerber
would have given you a Knife by now you
know like this something would have
happened like this this doesn't make any
sense and yet
everyone said there was a tape
there's a tape out there and I didn't
have a relationship with Michael Ware
but they're like there's a tape out
there and now I'm thinking oh [__]
what's on the team show me what's in the
box what's on the tape like is it good
is it bad like I don't I don't want to
you know do whatever and then uh he sold
his documentary and when he sold this
documentary
uh everyone started talking about it
again and the book started reading the
book and they wanted to make it a movie
they want to do all these different
things and I thought ah this is I'm
getting into the territory that I was
really happy I never was in
and uh then you got Dakota and
everything he went through and Kyle and
you know all these guys will Swenson and
you know just it just seemed like half
of the population was like at a boy
here's a free ticket to Disneyland and
the rest of them were like I'm gonna
hunt you down and make sure you could
never work a job again
uh and it's such a schizophrenic world
man and so
2018 I'm minding my own business and I
get these hold on before we get there
though I mean there's a huge amount of
time that's passing by so it's now 2005
2006 you're doing some I gotta joining
2008. you're you're doing reporting yeah
and so I was I worked in Washington I
started a veterans group called Vets For
Freedom Pete hegseth Fox News
um we had uh Marcus was a part of that
uh there was all these guys that we
tried to just get the politics out of
War fighting you know send us to fight
and if you don't like it don't vote to
send us but you can't defund a war while
we're in the process of fighting it and
then uh I I just I I wanted to go back
home I wanted to be a dad I wanted to
coach soccer and I wanted to just see my
kids and this is what we fought for so I
just became a a normal you know a guy I
worked at a milk plant
I was doing you know advocacy work for
like the power grid you know like
nothing crazy like you can't be against
protecting the power grid you know what
I mean and uh working at a milk plant
and everything was cool
um and then an opportunity came up to do
some radio
and I'm I'm in Buffalo and I love my
hometown I love the bills I love
everything about Buffalo and uh I was
like hey you know what when I'm on the
radio no one's talking about the Army
um weather traffic guy
so in a way it's the way you were
weather traffic guy no no I'm just
saying I'm talking about just cat
Decline and you know plastic bags like
nothing remotely you know if they did
you write a book yeah yeah but let's
talk about this cat the claws why are we
declawing cats it's like cutting their
fingers off are you happy with yourself
and in a way I could control my
narrative I you didn't know what I
looked like you just heard it every day
and yet I controlled what you knew about
me and if you wanted to ask me a
question about something I want to talk
about
I just switched the star hung up on you
you know I didn't have to be on Facebook
I didn't have to go nuts I didn't you
know you want to talk about the war and
you know there's moments where you have
a book out you go out Fox you talk about
the end of the war the way Obama ended
the war Bush what do you think about
this what do you think about Trump what
do you think about the caliphate those
are things you know you feel like doing
them or you don't but I'm not a
professional veteran and that chunk of
my life was amazing you know and then I
started going through all the things all
my friends were going through you know
Chuck Yeager dies at what 99
what do they talk about the soundberries
24 dude we're talking chunk Yeager's
entire life and we're talking about when
he was 24. it's a sound barrier who
gives a [__] he had kids he had a job he
had businesses nobody wants to talk
about Chuck Yeager they want to talk
about when you're 24.
and you start to realize that if you
live your life in that moment that's all
you're going to be
and everyone's going through what I'm
going through went through a divorce
divorce sucks War sucks you move on you
meet new people you have new
relationships but I never I figured that
the guys were the war
my old unit my old life was the thing
that I'm burying in a time capsule
and so those guys the more I heard about
them the more there were problems I'm
not your squad leader anymore
I I can't help you anymore
it's time to move on
and then all of a sudden I get these
phone calls from guys I haven't talked
to in Forever got to the Pentagon people
I met you know in Washington or overseas
and they're like do you hear what's
happening which is like the worst way to
start a conversation did you hear what
they're doing to you
they knew a lot of information they had
a lot of stuff and your your initial
thought was they're investigating you
they were investigating they're asking
questions well I'm not I don't even know
who you are you're calling me on the
phone you're asking if you think the
Medal of Honor just was never going to
happen at some point did you figure all
right what year did you approximately
say hey you know what it's been four
years that [__] ain't happening I got my
silver star with my name missed us
all the living recipients were
Afghanistan
and the Obama Administration was very
clear that Iraq was the bad War
Afghanistan was a good War we don't talk
about Iraq
the caliphates moving throughout the
country no one wants to revisit Iraq
we're making Iraq movies that we avoided
because it was too close to reality now
you know Superman's making the movies
and you know ramadi like all these
things were happening that the culture
was just like no more Iraq
and it was okay and this was like 2010
or something
2010 that it was like okay fine and by
the way I saw what happened to Marcus I
saw what was happening to all these
other guys I mean they Savaged Dakota
Meyer for there's absolutely nothing no
one could rationalize why that guy goes
from American hero on a pedestal
you know you you take will Swenson and
Dakota Meyer one each branch of service
you get more for the exact same thing
you don't think that's weird for those
two guys
you don't think you're creating uh why
are you doing that you can't say that
will Swanson did something incredible
that day Dakota Meyer did something
incredible that day no that's not what
you do you make it about Branch rivalry
you take two guys you're digging into
people's lives this is trauma this is
the this is their identity right and
then Dakota decides to be a man and get
married and because he marries someone
we got to put on TMZ he's now a
celebrity that gets followed by gossip
magazines come on dude this is these
kids are young they got their whole
lives in front of them you're lucky they
didn't end up you know like Elvis in
some Vegas hotel just you know eating
peanut butter sandwiches I mean you you
can't do that to young people and not
give them the the opportunity to become
normal again these guys can't work
normal jobs they can't be normal you
don't want them to be normal you want to
exploit him to sell war bonds
but then when they make money or they
become successful you attack them for
being [__] and I mean it's it's
unsustainable and it and it's horrible
to see it's like watching a slow-moving
freight train
a baby playing with a you know stick of
dynamite and you're watching this and
all I could think of is
my heart breaks through these guys I
know them all to be honorable wonderful
men but I'm so glad I'm not there I'm so
glad that for whatever reason my path
was different and I could just control
it you know I love that and then it
became apparent that Not only was this
going to be serious but
reporters the same reporters going after
Navy Seals for you know doing silly
things
the same guys loving the Leavenworth
dudes that were getting thrown in jail
uh these reporters were like hey tell me
about this incident tell me about this
tell me about that and I'm like you know
what you can all eat a bag of hot I am
I'm lawyering up dude you're not
touching me not touching me right
and these guys are like dude one of two
things was happening either you're gonna
go to jail for 40 years or you're going
to be the ambassador to France like
we've never seen this before like there
no one wants to acknowledge anything so
I'm doing the radio show one day my
contest line blows up like we give
tickets to Mannheim Steamroller
and it's some someone from army
Personnel that's like you must pick up
the phone or will come to your house
and I'm like Army personnel
like that's not like there's no criminal
CI there's no CBS show is going to spawn
off G1 you know the RV Personnel yeah
out of it 71 Lima on on this episode of
71 Lima paychecks
right we're gonna figure out the housing
uh you know food crisis no it's it's
ridiculous and then
uh they're like a senior member of the
dod wants to talk to you and I'm like I
maybe it's a DSC
right well that's awesome senior member
got to be Chief of Staff you know
whoever
and then one day uh they're like are you
by your phone are you by your phone I'm
like yeah and they're like the senior
member of the dod is calling and are you
suspect at this point that you think
it's a DSE you think the DSC I think
through yeah yeah because senior member
they would just say you're getting the
well just tell you I'm a grown man I
mean what are we doing here it's not
like
let me go to the book phone rings
I took a breath then answer the phone
hello David an upbeat woman's voice said
to me my name is Madeline and I have
President Trump on the line wishing to
speak to you is now a good time
what the hell I almost said that out
loud fortunate I caught myself uh uh
yeah now's a good time
my phone blinked suddenly heard
president Donald Trump's Voice come
through my phone speaker David how are
you
do you know why I'm calling
I'm a little nervous I admitted you
should be nervous I should be nervous
okay do you know what you've been
recommend recommended for
in that instant I knew what was coming
was far more life-changing than
throwaway allegations the war was over I
had moved on 14 years ago I was told I
was nominated for the Medal of Honor sir
a lifetime ago
back then the thought of being awarded
America's highest Valor medal was
seemingly a dream come true a validation
of my skills and professionalism as a
soldier it would erase the insecurities
I had wrestled with constantly and be a
tangible symbol of my service to my
father after all these years I could go
home to him with something he could take
pride in about his youngest son none of
that happened
well David
you got it Trump said
just like that
I mean when you it's one of two things
it's Alec Baldwin from Saturday Night
Live or it's it's Donald Trump I mean
the first United States and honestly it
was so surreal the moment I heard the
moment you know you get a call from a
flashy number and it's a switchboard of
the White House
then it can't be the DSC you know but
the amount of Cloak and Dagger that's
behind this thing is just so crazy and
then it's not just
you're getting the Medal of Honor now
that you're the only guy from Iraq so
now this gives every weenie from the
mainstream media an opportunity to be
like let's
re-adjudicate why we went to war
in Iraq am I just a recipient of the
Medal of Honor am I a mascot am I the
guy that you just want to you know why
is this happening why is there only one
why are there so many Afghanistan only
one over here
and you know I I I mean when you look at
the Timeline you know some of these guys
have had the Medal of Honor for 10 years
15 years you know whatever I think the
old magenta was like 2012 maybe 11 10.
yeah sometime around there
I mean I was long out of the army when
that happened so I'm the old the second
oldest of the G wat recipients
but I'm one of the newest recipients
right and so it's like I kind of
navigated all of that and kind of put
that away you know maybe you do want to
give it to a 23 year old go out there
and enjoy it and have fun and you know
get a you know buy a car dealership you
know Valor cars go do what you want to
do with it but at this point it's like
you know
you're you're 35 and so and delivers a
Shetland pony to your door you're like
no Santa I was 11 when I wanted that you
know like that's it's not it's not what
I at this phase of life
and then it it starts happening and then
every you you realize oh you know here's
the key to the city and you know here's
an allegation here's the you know why
why did you say this on the radio did
you did you actually imply that this
person should be beaten to death I mean
I'm like I've been doing the same thing
for seven years come on I the attention
is and not and then everywhere you go
you're in the past tense
they talk about 2004 didn't want to hear
about 2022 they don't want to hear about
the future
uh it's you know you're in a frozen in
time you're at your own funeral
everywhere you go
and all I thought about was I went
through this with 40 of the most
beautiful people I've ever known in my
life
maybe I'll just go through with them
again
what if we make this award instead of
being the guy that stands up there
awkwardly in a uniform you've probably
never worn as a soldier
and you eat a bunch of shrimp and and
you meet like Jimmy Kimmel right why
don't you
just say look
I'm gonna be the guy that just
constantly redirects it to the kids that
got nothing right the ones that did
everything I asked him to do and never
received any
you know maybe we just bring the band
back together
you know let's make the Medal of Honor
about the unit why do you not go why
don't you get to invite people to it you
get all these people to come to the
White House but you can't invite the
guys that actually were there that day
why don't you want to do that you know
why isn't this a unit award why don't
you bring it's all of our we all did it
right there was a camera there there was
one guy and and uh you know it became a
story that people talked about but
did I do it could I have done it again
I'll tell you again would I do it again
knowing what this was no I would have
called a bomb in and waited for it
patiently there's no way you want this
if you are a person
that is is going to live your entire
life you know based on the past
um
I don't know of any other award where
you have to wear it everywhere if you
interviewed Will Smith and he brought
the Oscar you'd think he was a total
douchebag you might think he's a
douchebag anyway and you might be right
but my point is you don't bring that
everywhere you go this is an award
you're supposed to wear everywhere
you're supposed to it's your identity
this is like oh no it's there's only so
many living and and there's only so many
in our history and let's let's just
everywhere you go it's this award first
and I'm thinking to myself man that that
it's the wrong
there's so many let's talk about the
Iraq War let's actually have a
discussion about what was sacrificed and
what was accomplished because I'll tell
you what all you people that want to
ignore Iraq for 10 years
baghdad's more likely to host a Summer
Olympic Games than Kabul is
I mean can you actually look at the two
Wars and say that is Iraq better today
than the good War the war of choice in
Afghanistan
and that's through no fault of American
Valor American blood
but you could get a president-elected
tomorrow that decides Ukraine's worth
American treasure and blood you can get
a president tomorrow that wants to hit
Nova Scotia for some reason I don't know
look we don't make those calls but we
fought a fight of Our Generation and we
did it with Valor we uh uh just went
beyond the highest expectations of of
what our military branches ask of us
and I'm proud to be a part of the
generation
I might not have voted to go to war with
Iraq but I'm proud of my war and my war
was Iraq and I'm proud of the men and
women I served with and uh make the
award about that
yeah and just to clarify you
you were the first living uh Medal of
Honor from Iraq Paul Ray Smith uh it was
the first recipient yeah but in that
story is you know as close to Audie
Murphy's you're gonna get
um
the uh you detail this the you know as
it goes from there so
um first of all it's it's it's it's
incredible you know as you make this
decision to bring everyone in and you
start reaching out to your old friends
and you're you're reaching out to the
gold star families the widows the moms I
mean it's it's incredibly
um emotional to read through it
and how that goes down and what you're
feeling and what you're thinking and
um and then you know you get to the
point where you're actually you take it
through the ceremony and I you know I
attended Mikey Monsters Medal of Honor
ceremony at the White House and
you know was obviously honored to be
able to be there for that but
you just being able to read your
experience and what that was like and
and reflect on what I saw I mean you
just did a a great job of capturing the
the ceremony and what happens
um
yeah it's it's it's a very powerful a
very powerful thing and this idea that
you talked about you know why not make
it everybody else's award
and it's not just something that you're
saying right now it's what you actually
did you reached out to everybody you got
the band back together those those are
the words that you use in the book
um they allowed us to take those guys on
stage oh no that was that was that was
awesome that was epic that really was
cool and and listen I gotta tell you I
don't know I would have reacted
you know they handled it with Grace
and love
and the the ramrods of of my unit were
there I don't think you know in my 20s I
couldn't tell another man
you know that we we in the military we
were super weird about you know we laugh
at things that are you look at today and
you're like you would never say these
words or you never laugh at these jokes
but expressing love in in my 20s was
could not be done you couldn't go up to
a guy in your 30s or your 20s in uniform
and be like I love you
you know don't ask don't tell just just
love me write me a note or something and
when you hit a certain age you realize
I love you and I want to tell you that I
care about you I really am proud to be
in your life it's a gift that you and I
are connected and no matter what happens
in this world no matter what
disappointment you have I know who you
are I know what you're capable of I know
what you've done for me and you know
these the questions that I was always
afraid of
you know if I would have gotten this
thing when I was 29 I probably would
have been an idiot I probably would have
you know I I don't know if I was
emotionally mature enough to be able to
to realize that you're a product of the
people you're with you know we smoke
cigarettes at 14 and we blame you know
peer pressure
but peer pressure also makes you kick a
door down peer pressure makes you clear
Road IEDs makes you jump out of a
helicopter with a rope it depends who
your peers are if you've got quality
people they're gonna you're gonna be all
right going with the following the herd
is okay if the people are are worth it
if you got dirt bags of scumbag you're
going to be an idiot so these kids are
men they're all great people
I'm blessed to have him in my life I'm
glad we're back
but you know it it doesn't give you a
pass and and there's always going to be
you know there's it's it's CR it's crazy
how uh we think that something that we
get
is
you know somehow Gonna Make You Coast
through like I think there's a mindset
that you don't need to do anything
anymore get a DUI tomorrow and find out
the first thing they say it won't be you
know a random guy in Buffalo with a
radio show it's gonna be uh you know
deal you know the Metal of Honor guy
gets a DUI as it should be don't get a
DUI don't be an idiot you know it's not
hard to do
I hope uh yeah pretty pretty awesome
um
on that day when you talked about them
coming on stage you say the president
asked my family to join us on stage this
is right after you received the Medal of
Honor this has become a traditional
gesture to acknowledge the family my
mother walked up to meet the president
along with my brothers Dan and ran and
my three beloved children their mother
stepped up too sharing the stage with
them was Unforgettable my family
together in front of countless people
across the world the effects of November
10th have rippled through their lives
ever since even if the kids had not
known it they earned this a gesture that
was once an homage to them by our
president and atonement for all the
hardships we'd experienced as a family
since my return as I stood there though
my heart and head told me this needed to
be first and foremost the ramrod's
spotlight their moment
I needed to give this honor there on
stage with the president to the men
Tamara Lee and Colin Sims where it
rightfully belonged
I moved to president Trump and asked him
sir can I bring my ramrods up here I
pointed to the audience Trump was
surprised
this wasn't just a break in protocol
this was taking a wrecking ball to it
but this president was never one to
adhere rigidly to past Traditions he
asked how many are we talking
all of them sir
he looked over at them and said let's do
it bring them up come on up here guys
president Trump rolled his hands over to
welcome them get up here the ramrods
flowed onto the tiny stage this felt
right this wasn't my award this was our
award Our Moment not mine we fought the
Battle of fallujah's one family
we should we would share this stage as
one family it reminded me I was never
alone I always had them these men never
betrayed me never let me down they did
everything I asked of them and more they
are the reason I am alive and did have
my reunion with Evan after all
of course they were also the reason I
was wearing this award there we were
shoulder to shoulder One More Time
Captain Sims
led the way for this moment
he showed us that true leadership didn't
end with our time in combat it took me
14 years to figure that out he wanted us
to fight scrupulously not because he saw
it as a path to Victory but because he
knew it was the only way we would we
would survive the aftermath of War
I'd never known an officer who looked
that far ahead he wasn't trying to just
be our commander in Iraq he felt that
responsibility would be his forever
as this event unfolded I understood the
vision of our forever Commander
the Medal of Honor had brought us back
together
it was our unifying force
yeah and uh
I what's pretty awesome is you can go
watch this on YouTube I hate to say it
but you can go watch us on YouTube and
it's it's freaking outstanding to see it
was awesome it was awesome to go through
and and you know and so then uh you know
the Army wants you back and uh help out
recruit do all those things and you know
one of the things that really opened my
eyes
um
the Army is I I love my Army and I I
that's the soft spot it's always been
don't let you know your Harmony is
depending on you and you want to do
what's best but the Army also has
changed a little bit and it's another
generation's Army it's not really my
Army anymore and I think that's not
necessarily a bad thing but it's not a
good thing you know all right and and
there were times during this process
where I had I had people in my life I I
I I wanted to be able to experience this
award with with the the folks that I I
had a new
I had a new Brotherhood of of people
that I cared for
and because of the situation you know
with divorce and the Army and the White
House getting involved and all the pr
people the communications people
it they were making calls and dictating
decisions that weren't really
putting me first right and and it's
tough it's tough because you have to
think well this is about the institution
this is about this it's about but we're
supposed to be an organization that is
lethal that's ready for the next fight
and we are far too in the weeds as as an
institution right now I don't know the
Navy or the Air Force or the Marine
Corps but I can tell you that you know
there is this generation we were
supposed to you know they talk about
that famous class in West Point during
the Civil War that had all this
experience in the Mexican and the Indian
campaigns and how great they were in
battle in the Civil War because of all
the experience they had that was
supposed to be us
after 20 years of war we're supposed to
have the best generals and the best
Colonels because every one of these
young lieutenants cut their teeth in
combat we didn't have it after the Gulf
War
they all went away and you had peace
time and peace is great we love peace we
fight for peace
but my God we are hemorrhaging
far too many light kernels and Majors
that are just saying it's not worth it
and the guys sticking around for four
stars
I worry that in 10 years they're the
ones that need it
they got nothing else to do
there was a time when our four-star
generals were the best of they were CEOs
you know I just saw one retired the
other day this guy could work anywhere
in the country he's that good
all right Paul Funk is one of the
greatest generals the Army's ever seen
what's gonna happen in 10 years are we
going to have the best of the best or
are we gonna have people that just hung
out long enough Survivor Island
they kept uh held onto the torch
and they're there it's it's it's uh it's
sad but I I want my command server
Majors to all have been privates in
ramadi and Fallujah I want my generals
to have been lieutenants
in Kabul and in Afghanistan we don't
we're losing it
well that would certainly be a an ideal
thing and uh speaking of Ideal things
you get you ended up giving a speech and
this speech the next day this is at the
hall of Heroes at the Pentagon and you
end up giving the speech it's uh it's an
amazing speech it's a it's an amazing
speech
and it's got a bunch of views once again
you can go watch this
um but you you in the speech
a lot of is it you just paying a tribute
to the men you fought alongside
and you pay homage to all the services
but there's one part of the speech that
I think it captures what you just said
of what the ideal what the what the
American Military is supposed to be
and I just want to read this real quick
you say this
and go watch this whole speech on
YouTube you say this the entire military
is one cohesive dedicated force and the
threats to our Nations they don't sleep
they're watching our every move Iran
Russia China North Korea Isis Al-Qaeda
they may be watching this right now
our military should not be mistaken for
a cable news gab Fest show
we don't care what you look like we
don't care who you voted for who you
worship what you worship who you love
it doesn't matter if your dad left you
Millions when he died or if you knew who
your father was
we have been honed into a machine of
lethal moving parts that you would be
wise to avoid if you know what's good
for you
we will not be intimidated we will not
back down
we've seen War
we don't want war
but if you want war with the United
States of America there's one thing I
can promise you so help me God someone
else will raise your sons and daughters
we fight so our children never have to
we fight for one day when our children
and our enemies children can discuss
their differences without fear or
loathing
we fight so that anyone out there
thinking about Raising Arms against our
citizens or Allies realizes the futility
of attrition against a disciplined
professional and lethal Force built to
withstand anything you can dream of
throwing at us
Americans want this kind of country
Americans want this kind of world and we
stand ready to defend it to protect us
so help us God
may God bless this beautiful Army
may God bless our Marine Corps our Navy
our air force and our Coast Guard
may God bless our allies
and we already know that God blessed
America because he gave us the greatest
fighting force this world has ever seen
2-2 infantry and the first Infantry
Division thank you ramrod's Duty first
Dukes
foreign
again to me
that's the military that I tried to join
that's the military I tried to
represent when I was in and many of the
those I served alongside that's exactly
the way they felt and you captured it um
incredibly I appreciate that
um a little editorializing at the end of
the greatest fighting force the world's
ever seen you know that might be
hyperbole but my point in in that is
that you know I think we're all raised
differently in the in the military our
leaders gave us tough love but now that
we're out we're still ambassadors and
it's very very important that
people start to see veterans you know
we're not some infomercial for Sally's
to others
for 99 cents a month private Snuffy can
get a cup of coffee do you know what I
mean like we got uh you know like
wounded dogs and cages building houses I
I love those institutions but we're
going to run out of houses to build
we're gonna run out of wounded men and
women who gave us everything for our
country God bless their sacrifice God
bless their service but I don't want a
cottage industry of you watch a
recruiting commercial it's followed by a
guy lost his limb trying to open his
kitchen cabinet
I mean that's a really schizophrenic
message to send to America's young
people how do you honor service and
sacrifice without bookending it next to
a commercial saying join us and we too
will give you a kitchen countertop that
allows you to cook in front of your
family in case the worst thing happens
Hey listen
everyone knows what's going on with
service and the men and women who have
sacrificed who've been out there they
Empower us they're they're walking
vessels of Valor our generational Valor
no one should cheapen that no one should
denigrate that buy them two houses and
an additional car in fact take it from
Iraq let the Iraqi people pay
reparations for our dead and are injured
I'm all about it I have no problems with
that at all but at the same time we
still have to have a warrior class in
America
and this is just the victimization of
veterans is something that just
absolutely I find repugnant and it's not
helping us it's not making us more
deadlier or more lethal on the
battlefield it's not intimidating our
adversaries and it's not bringing peace
to our allies it's it's it just shows
that well eventually America will get it
eventually we'll understand that the
greatest generation was the greatest
generation of American because they knew
they were at War and they had to do
everything to win their War
you want to say no to war forever I'll
be with you I don't want to see War
again
but if this is going to happen it's got
to be overwhelming devastating and a
reminder to your future generation go to
dental school and learn a trade don't
fight against Americans because it is
going to end in tears every single time
and I just don't think we're that
military anymore and I don't think our
elected officials want us to be that
military anymore
you know hearing the stories of people
joining our military to to get hormone
therapy
it's it's like what are you doing you're
combat ineffective you can't deploy why
would I why would I want you in my team
what do you do I want a college degree
font you want a college degree fantastic
you want to be a citizen fantastic you
want to better yourself better your
community better your country I'm all
about giving you the tools to make your
Society better for serving
you're not bettering yourself
because you're selfish and you see
yourself in a different light and this
is what's best for me it's not best for
your community it's not best for your
country it's best for you
and that's the opposite it's literally
180 degrees from what we're supposed to
be
and I just don't know why more people
aren't standing up especially
you know our generation saying just
because I'm who we are does not offend
you
I mean representing our our true self of
what the military is and what veterans
do is not something it invokes pride
right it gives us Swagger it gives us
security it gives us Pride it gives us
patriotism if it's offensive to you
that's the problem
that's your problem it's not it's not
the institution's problem I'm so sick
and tired of having to apologize for
what
do you want me to you know the first
question that we got asked uh when we
did the whole little media thing after
the Medal of Honor is what do you say to
the families who lost loved ones in Iraq
or Afghanistan
and I'm thinking to myself
the fact that you have to ask that
just shows me I mean what are you goo
stepping with you know what side you
tell a family member that their loved
one died so that we could live
that's what happened their sacrifice
could have been any one of us
they put themselves in a position so
that we could have it tomorrow and a
future
and if that is difficult for you to
understand then I'm glad you never
served
honestly the part of me wants to think
that maybe we think we're better than
civilians and other parts want to say
well some people can't do this some
people don't want to do this I get all
of it
but there are certainly people that are
offended by people who make the choice
to serve their country or serve in you
know any sector of First Responders or
any of these other folks
they're just offended by everything and
I honestly I don't even give a damn
about I mean you're just a vacuous
non-entity at the end of the day if
you're not going to put the fire out if
you're not going to help tell everyone
there's a fire
and all you want to do is comment on why
the fire got put out
then you're just a jack off like there's
no there's no there's nothing in the
chain that says I need more of that
so stop acting like you're on an equal
platform with a disabled veteran you
know let's give a service dog to
everyone if you need a dog get a dog I'm
not offended you have a dog I don't
think you need a pot belly pig I think
you're being obnoxious with a peacock I
think when you brought a bowl with fairy
shrimp in it you're just being an ass I
mean we we could differentiate between
the people that need to be put on a
pedestal and the people that just want
to be acknowledged for being different
they wanted to serve they love our
country they love our family we're all
different walks of life
but that doesn't mean that we're not
proactive to people that are obviously
trying to get in the way of the this
family tradition today if you're joining
the Marine Corps of the armies because
your dad did it
because your uncle did it
why isn't this a decision everyone is
making
you you have an obligation to go to
college everyone has an obligation well
you got you're not going to college
what's wrong with you
what do you mean you're not going to
college there obviously you're not
serious about succeeding in life it's
ridiculous and then you think to
yourself
why isn't every single 18 year old
saying I'm going to do my two years and
find myself
I'm going to learn about people and be
uncomfortable and be different and
sacrifice and see the world and see
different people and be surrounded by
diversity and difference
I don't have to force the diversity it's
already there
there's diversity everywhere right and
it's in the military it's in every Walk
of Life there's diversity embrace it
it's beautiful but it's different and
you have to be exposed to that different
to grow I don't understand why every
able-bodied person is insane I want some
of that
I want to be better I want to take care
of myself I want individual ruggedness I
want to be tough I want to survive
right and and you've got a generation of
of website Developers
that that you know I mean seriously if a
zombie apocalypse happens I look at
there was a time when you know a person
said I want a partner who's gonna be
there for me
when it all goes down
and now that decision isn't I want
someone who who what look I understand
that you know things have changed we
can't change we have to be the same
yesterday today forever in the military
cannot adapt uh to this schizophrenic
nature of hey today we believe the
following individuals
you know are a protected class today we
believe the following individuals can
reproduce today we believe the following
I mean you want to kick out 15 000
people for vaccinations what did you do
with Anthrax did you dishonorably
discharge them
what did you tell them you said you
don't want the anthrax well you know
you're not going to defend your country
with all the people you trained with for
a year
why don't you take the anthrax
that was the choice am I going to not
deploy with these men
that I consider family to me because
what I don't know what Anthrax is
if anthrax was naturally occurring
outside of training grounds in San Diego
would people not resp you know
this vaccination thing to me is is a is
a is a a object lesson
and how we have completely decided that
we want our universe instead of our
universities becoming more like our our
military we're deciding to make the
military Plug and Play to everything
that's happened in society and
unfortunately the enemy gets a vote
and the enemy doesn't give a damn about
inclusiveness or feeling good
the enemy wants to kill you they want to
kill you as quickly as they possibly can
and I don't want a military that feels
good at the end of the day about who
they are I want the military to feel
good about who they are because they
dominated the battle space and Americans
don't know what a mortar incoming or
outgoing sounds like
right that's a problem yeah I mean um
the military has one purpose
and that's to be able to fight destroy
the enemy that's what it is and if if
you're doing things in the military
that don't enhance that capability
it's a problem
and if you know you said that the enemy
doesn't care what they're doing what
we're doing actually they do care what
we're doing and they're trying to
encourage it as much as possible they
want us to be as weak as they can
possibly make us they can get drugs over
the Border they can put uh programs on
your phone that that fill your brain
with a bunch of stuff that makes you
think things that are not healthy like
that stuff's actually happening that's
actually happening
so
hopefully well I'll tell you one thing
these books that you've written
um
in my estimation any
15 to 23 year old male that reads these
books will be encouraged to move in the
right direction
because they lay out what it means
and and like I said they're they're
incredible this incredible Arc between
the two books
and they're incredibly powerful
and and this is these are stories that
need to be told these are stories that
need to be told so people understand
what it takes and what it means and what
a Brotherhood is
inside of a military organization and
what
sacrifice really is
and we can never forget these things and
you would think you would think the way
the civilian populace sometimes behaves
you'd think that these wars didn't
happen
they happened a couple years ago you
know it happened a couple years ago yeah
and you know what
they're gonna happen again
and there's there's there's always going
to be War there's always what
conversation do you have
if that if that does go down in five
years you're talking to an 18 year old
and they're like
did you foresee this coming
how what you go to universities I know
some people don't touch the the you know
Vassar giving the talks on the circuit
but one of the things that young people
in college will always ask you know
a veteran is what can we do to prepare
for the future
and sometimes the answer of you need to
be prepared to kill 20 communist Chinese
is you know 20 million people want you
dead there's a way that we can say to
the Chinese government the people of
China are not the enemy the people of
Russia are not the enemy the people of
Iraq or Afghanistan are not the enemy
but no Venezuelan leader or mullah and
Iran or or forever leader of China
is is going to dictate what the world
how the world behaves
so I I don't think the I would have told
you at the end that I hung up my uniform
that the world was better and safer
and I'm I'm disgusted that you know as
we grow into our Twilight
our kids are going to have to learn to
shoot move and communicate
and that's heartbreaking and and and I
don't know what how do you have that
conversation there's only one thing
that's more heartbreaking than that and
that is if they don't learn to shoot
move and communicate because if they
don't learn to shoot move and
communicate
that will be overrun I mean at some
point you have to be able to back up the
way you want to live you you don't just
get to walk around the world doing
whatever you want without being able to
defend that way of life and if we don't
maintain that ability to defend the way
of life that we often take for granted
here it'll go away yeah
it'll go away
all right
books coming out
November 8th everyone buy it immediately
remember the ramrods where can people
find you right now what are you doing
right now
so um we are uh
odyssey.com the David bellavia show five
days a week four hours a day uh tons of
content that is not really meant to
upset anyone uh pretty PG-13 stuff uh
but I gotta tell you I find
that what I'm trying to do with my radio
show is to have discourse I you know I I
don't see the world the way a left-wing
Progressive sees the world
I respect them I want them I need them
in my culture and my Society I don't
want to cancel them I want to learn
but I need you to understand that if we
disagree we need to discuss how to
disagree and there's a way that you can
have a discussion with someone that you
disagree with and leave it with respect
and we have no ability to have discourse
in the in the country today and so what
I try to do in my little piece of the of
the of the world is just facilitate
quality
critical thinking and discourse this
isn't how you I disagree with X Y and Z
inflation energy oil this is what I feel
about abortion marriage wonderful I
don't care what you think it really it's
boring to me what you think how do you
think why do you think that that's far
more interesting because it always is
going to come to a selfish exercise I
feel this way because I robbed a bank
and I would like to be reformed no bail
right it's always like there's always a
story that makes you have why are you
against you know pan-Asian trade well
I'll tell you I have a tire company and
my intellectual property was it there
there's always a reason for it so what
you think no one cares about why you
think it and how you think to me is the
is the secret sauce and so what I try to
do in a talk show is get 80 year old
people and 20 year old people from all
different walks of life to tell me you
know you're transgender tell me what do
you what would what motivates you to
call into a talk show what do you want
people to understand because I don't get
it and I don't mean disrespect I don't
understand it help me understand it no
I'm not here to help you understand it
I'm here to tell you you're wrong okay
well I do have a problem with that
because if I'm asking you to help me
understand something and you refuse to
that's where everyone shuts down and we
label each other and we're you're this
or you're that I'm just saying I want to
know
what where are you coming from and why
is it important that I give a [__] about
what you where you're coming from
because I bet you you don't you don't
care
right I could bore you for four hours
with the Buffalo Bills secondary and why
the Tampa two you're gonna be like no
one cares dude no one gives a damn I do
why do you care so much about it why are
you so into a football team is there
anything else going on in your town
maybe there isn't got chicken wings
they're cool you know be fun Wick is fun
Logan Berry why do you feel this way why
is it important that I understand where
you're coming from and if I can't get
your respect enough to see me as a
person then I I you're not even all
you're doing is uh is is
annoying people no really and we we have
to stop annoying each other and just say
look where are you coming from why
because I'm a veteran does not make me
better than a person that isn't a
veteran and for a long time I thought
that way in my heart of hearts I'm
better than you right
that's not true I've learned in my Elder
years that that's ridiculous your
patriotism has nothing to do with what
you did in the military out of the
military right I just would like you to
love the home team
I think that's you know just love our
team
and and be supportive of it and at the
end of the day if you can respect people
and disagree with them man I think we
could solve all of our problems right
it's fun it's a little frustrating but
it's fun how long is the show it's four
hours a day five days a week
and it's I the it's I get a lot of
Canadians you know the Canadians go
we're close to Buffalo is close to
Toronto the Canadians know more about
the Constitution than we do and the
Canadians have nothing but like
state-run information they don't have
choices so they'll be like listen let me
tell you about the Second Amendment why
it's important you know the Articles of
Confederation it allowed us for a
standard Army of like where are you from
Brampton
you're not supposed to know any of that
you know your prime minister needs a
haircut like
it always it's always an education and
it's super fun and I think it's a great
service to just say hey
uh we we have to be better we can be
better optimism is great it doesn't make
you naive be hopeful look forward to the
future but it's all about the way we
conduct ourselves and our discourse and
how absolutely toxic it can be by just
saying nope you're one of them
I don't want to hear it and nothing gets
done after that
uh to find you David bellavia.com
and go to odyssey.com
used to be intercom did they change the
name to Odyssey what about your social
media do you actually have it I don't
really do I mean I just for the book we
started a DG bellavia uh at DG bellavia
Twitter and uh Facebook one but what
happens is you get all these like uh
Nigerians and people that create you
know I'm I'm on like dating sites like I
need money to get out of Iraq you know
could you help me can I just get a
thousand bucks I'm trapped and you know
in Nepal it's like no that's not me
that's not but there's a lot of those
out there but uh so you're not so are
you on Instagram too or no it's I'm On
Everything But DG DG bellavia David
bellavia Instagram uh David bellavia on
Facebook uh all that stuff but DG
bellavia because there's so many
accounts on Twitter but uh that's that
Twitter but for the most part I don't
really really do the social media thing
is just Maine do you are you nuts over
there I'm not nuts on it but I'm I'm on
it yeah and uh how long how long I see
with the the time right right with the
you know working out and stuff yeah
um do you get a good response from that
or do people get
I don't know I mean some people chime in
yeah people people chime in do you read
any comments oh you know I'll look
through the comments sometimes but um
you know I don't get I don't get all
hyped up about
what anybody says I mean if somebody
says something cool I'm stoked but if
there's someone that wants to you know
say something negative it literally
doesn't bother me at all
um I just kind of like oh cool you know
it's a bot uh you know what a bot is
right right so it's just it's just a bot
but there's people that get really spun
up about that stuff
I just look at him say that's a bot what
are you what are you getting spun up
about it of computer program in Russia
or something that's putting that
information into you uh but no I've I've
found social media to be
mostly good I've connected with some
incredible people I mean I've had people
come on the podcast that were you know
Vietnam uh World War II that I that I
connected with them through social media
so that's been awesome I get great
feedback from people
um the what we the some of the stuff I
make I'll get feedback hey you should
make this you should make that I'm like
oh that sounds like a good I didn't
really think of that
I think if you go into social media with
like a a positive mindset as cheesy as
that sound of like okay there's gonna be
some good stuff in here you're gonna
find it if you go in there worried about
a bunch of negativity which there's
definitely going to be uh it'll drive
you crazy so I don't get wrapped around
any of it what did it take for you to
get to that that Enlightenment was it a
man I was on Joe Rogan's podcast and Joe
Rogan's like hey dude you know like at
some point he goes hey this is the first
time I was on this was 2015. and he's
like dude you know when this comes out
don't read the comments
it's like a warning right
uh and I think you know in the military
you get thick skin right and so I would
say I I definitely had thick skin so
they came out and I sat I remember I sat
in my daughter my daughter's room my
oldest daughter and I we were reading
the comments and I was laughing
hysterically because some of them are
pretty freaking funny about you know I'm
a neanderthal and obviously I could
barely string a sentence together and
all these things and I was just laughing
and it seemed funny and so I think from
day one a from Rogan's comment like hey
don't read the comments I didn't take
that literally what I took it was is hey
look there's gonna be people that are
[__] and when you read [__] from
people that are [__] just say yeah
Roger that and and some of them like I
said some of them are pretty funny
um so that didn't take me long at all
didn't take me long but you know it's a
thick skin you're in the military any
weakness that you show is immediately
getting pounced upon by your platoon
mates and you're gonna get torn apart so
it's literally the worst defense in the
world is to say
please don't ever mention my goiter it's
gonna come up 85 times I've got I've got
something in the world that really
bothers me and I've never told anybody
what it is ever and I never will I'll
probably leave it in my last will and
test Testament say hey y'all in my
platoon that did this at some time or if
you wanted to really piss me off if you
would have done this it really would
have bothered me but I'd never let you
bastards know so I don't tell anybody
you know so I started telling young
people
that you should be the same way about
your dreams
I think everyone should have a fake
dream that they give no don't tell us
how do you utilize this don't ever share
what you really want to do in life
it's no one's you have to protect that
it's what you want what do you want to
be in 10 years why the hell am I telling
you
there's I don't want school of thought
of that is like when I say hey man I'm
gonna lose 30 pounds and I posted on the
internet hey everybody I'm gonna lose 30
pounds and then you're like oh I better
lose it or else I'm gonna look like a
shitburner hey I'm gonna run a marathon
and I'm gonna run it on this date and so
there's I forget there's a name for that
do you know what the name for that is oh
something along the lines of public
accountability public accountability so
that's the thing where you say hey my
dream is to you know uh create my own or
write a book right and so you tell
everybody and now you kind of get
pressured so what's your reasoning
behind not telling people I don't I
think you should protect you have people
in your life trust is everything right
so you have people in your life that you
trust these are your life partners and
everything else that's what that
relationship is all about right together
we're going to raise a family we're
thinking about buying a sheep farm
outside of San Diego that have raised
them together in harmony all right that
when the moment you go out and start
telling people this is my ambition why
would I want to expose what I want or
what I meant I'm not manifesting I don't
need accountability from people if I'm
losing 30 pounds again this is I think
we we as a generator we're the same
roughly yeah I think the social media of
we are the ones that screwed up social
media it's not the young kids it's the
it's the Gen xers that you know in the
old days
um I would drive by your house and be
like you're a loser right out the window
and now I I stop at the driveway and I'm
like let's wait for a comment
it's not enough to scream you're a loser
now I gotta wait in my car to be like
who's gonna come out and debate me on
whether or not I think you're a loser
and we put things on social media that
are just like were thirsty for some sort
of response that I'm proud that you're
losing 30 pounds good for you you need
to you know what that's healthy who
gives a damn either you're doing it
because you want to do it or you're
doing it because you want people to
think you're doing it at the end of the
day if you have a dream to be a 50 year
old law school graduate shut up
they work they should find out about
your r b album the day you drop it now
that I'm in the studio what you doing to
me because all you can do is You're
Gonna Hear for three months what the
hell are you thinking chocolate's got a
cookbook that's awesome
let's see the day it comes out why am I
telling everyone busy in the kitchen
today so we're working on the new recipe
so there's where I think now now I see
uh I I'm capturing or I see I see a
similar vein with people where they get
Satisfaction Just by saying you know hey
I'm I've always wanted to write a
cookbook I'm going to come out with a
cookbook and they get a boost from that
they get a what is it an endorphin a
dopamine hit they get a dopamine hit by
telling you hey man I'm writing a
cookbook right now and that's enough to
make me feel good right that I don't
actually do anything right right as
opposed to me not getting that instead
of going and freaking hammering on my
computer with my steak recipes would you
would you rather have four 27 inch
biceps or would you rather have
vegetable oil in your arms it looks like
no honestly you could look way you would
look and if you were that Iranian Hall
yeah yeah that guy who those are the
guys you invite him to move and he can't
lift the couch he can't do anything he
he's he has so that's the equivalent for
you of telling you what my dreams are
don't I don't I'm just rejecting what is
it what are they injecting their biceps
exactly Charles biceps experts what was
the last did you have this in the seals
if you had a new girlfriend or a wife
would you ever show anyone a picture
of someone that you were romantically
connect
[Applause]
how long was I romantically I connected
to said woman you the only time they
should ever see your partners in person
because that is the dumbest thing
why would you do that I want to show you
who I'm dating
and then you wait for like what is the
response supposed to be like oh my is is
she okay where is she from Chernobyl
that's just weird too bro don't be
asking using a picture of my girl I'm
not even if that if that's your friend
and you're like oh I heard you're dating
somebody new like yeah what tell me I
don't know I feel like that's normal I
had a I I knew a guy who had a picture
of his family and and all you know his
daughter and his wife they're in bikinis
and I just said Hey listen man you got
no you got to take this picture down
because it's it's not only inappropriate
there's no way this is safe this is not
safe for anyone they make a comment
they're weird they don't make a comment
they're probably normal right but why
would you even do that don't ever in the
military rule number one if you never
show a picture of anyone you are
involved with because there's no point
to it it's weird now that you're putting
it together it's a horrible thing to do
that was one thing when I was reading
your book and you or no when you were
talking today and that's also in your
book like one time my wife asked me I
was on deployments in ramadi and my wife
says oh the kids want to see a picture
of where sleep you know and I had like
we had some old Saddam building and we
had you know built a little plywood
freaking beds in there and stuff like
this and so I'm like cool and I would
email my wife like once a week you know
a little update you know hey Ciao's
great uh miss you blah blah blah how are
the kids and so I went to take a picture
of where I slept at night and I realized
there's like no picture so I went until
like my went to my freaking Walker
pulled out pictures of My Wife and Kids
pinned them up took a picture took them
all down put them back in the folder put
it in the drawer and shut it because
that's smart yeah just like you were
talking about like the last thing I
needed to be thinking about over there
was My Wife and Kids absolutely and and
that seems like a
maybe that seems like it's not healthy
but I think it's completely healthy you
got guys depending on your decision
making without a doubt it doesn't mean
that you don't love it's like whenever I
see a Facebook profile it's like Joe and
Kim Jones and like oh no
oh something happened you know what I
mean like they're you don't want to be a
two-headed monster you gotta have
autonomy but you also have to have trust
yeah I hate the luxury of my wife being
very I've described emotionally
dependent so she didn't need me to be
like telling her you know hey I hope
everything's great and she was like hey
I got this I got the home I got the
freaking water heater when it breaks I
got the whatever the toilet when it gets
stopped up you handle your you know what
your business overseas and I'll take
care of this stuff and that was pretty
very lucky yeah lucky to be in that
scenario but to me it and and it's the
ultimate in in just you know being
making those choices and putting those
barriers up because there's in today's
you know private sector in jobs today is
an absolutely no I mean you know you
bring you bring your lunch to work you
don't make lunch at work you know
because you don't get in the kitchen and
start constructing a meal like what the
hell is wrong with you you know it's
like I have one the pet peeve that
drives me nuts is the wet hair what's
the wet hair anyone that shows up with
wet hair like is it raining out no you
have no time management there's just be
late be late and presentable this is
coming from a guy that bought a blow jar
you know what I learned lessons in life
but there's no reason why someone should
be running into work brushing their
teeth you know doing it's just I'm gonna
be late and then I'm gonna show up and
I'm presentable I'm ready to go this
isn't a meeting with you know tribal
Elders the first 45 minutes we're just
gonna waste time talking about the
weather show up be ready everything's
cool you always got that guy that's
going for that cubicle to cubicle asking
how you doing what's going on
we have no line of like what's personal
what are you what are you doing this
weekend none of your damn business Bob
get my my expense sheets done you know
what I mean like what we're buddies you
want to be friends I don't want to be
friends I want to just get the get the
job done you know what I mean with dry
hair while we're at it yeah Echo Charles
you got any questions do not sometimes
Echo throws that curveball in the end
man
dopamine sure yeah it's a thing's real
it's real David any any closing thoughts
no I want to say honestly uh what you do
is uh it's important to our generation
and a lot of people look up to you and
it's rare that you meet someone that's
worthy of that there's a lot of people
that get that have the pedestals uh the
products this is what I want the world
to see this is the person I want to be
and the perception and you're legitimate
you're you're who you are you who you
there's no difference with a microphone
is this on by the way
good question
when Mike's job with the bikes odd it's
the same and and that's it's refreshing
I really was afraid that I was gonna
meet you and I was gonna be like oh man
I wonder what that guy would be like
who's that guy what's that guy like if
you've never done that we met someone
and you really really thought they were
just totally squared away this is
someone I could look up to as a mentor
and then he was just like no I have done
it but I'm just wondering [__] Jocko
would be like like who's that guy am I
like uh whatever what would I have been
cold I don't know what would I be doing
Jocko
is that your ulterior well I had covered
a couple times it was no Factor I
remember when that V when you cut a
video that you had coveted there was
like there was controversy it's like oh
what what did he do yeah well I tell you
you told people at covet people like oh
he must be you know I was doing events I
like during covet there was times where
I went to like the first live event that
I did with kovid when kovid was a thing
and I went to this thing it was in
Arizona and I forget what month it was
but I went and
I was thinking like oh how freaked out
is everybody going to be
and I wasn't freaked out of covid um
because I was like young and healthy and
anyways I went to this event and and
then they said hey some can people shake
your hand when you're done I'm like yeah
cool and so I stepped down off the stage
and they all line up about 500 people
out of a thousand or whatever and the
funny thing was was there was sneeze on
jocker there was a few people there's
probably 10 people that had masks on as
they approached me right so they caught
they come up to take the picture they
shake my hand they take their mask off
to take the picture or we may get close
to me I'm like I just you know so uh
yeah I got covered I mean maybe that's
the the evil Jocko well you would figure
if you're going to be a a person it's
usually when you're sick or you don't
sound mine but but those those were the
viral Jocko
videos are not what you expect them to
be
they're not like that there's not it's
not controversy
it's just something that happened to you
that people make viral because I can't
believe it's happening like as if you
had coveted it was a declaration like
you wanted to talk about your vaccine
status there was a time when that
question was asked some people didn't
want to talk about it some people did
some people said it's none of your
business but the assumption that you had
covid it meant something about
vaccinating status we now know it's
ridiculous it's ridiculous the Yankees
Aaron judge he got covert everyone's
like I can't believe you didn't get
vaccinated I still do that by the way
when I hear that someone gets coveted
I'm like why wouldn't you want to get
vaccinated that's so weird
like you should know better you're the
vice president of the United States
to get back it's safe and effective like
do it everyone's doing it
but I'm telling you it kills me I I love
that I remember that moment specifically
when everyone was was asking like what
was he doing yeah well as you know from
doing radio four hours a day you can't
pretend to be someone for four hours a
day and just like on this podcast you
can't come on here I can't come on here
and talk for hours and hours and like be
in some character mode where I'm
pretending to be someone that I'm not
but there's a lot of MMA guys a lot of
guys that just are not
I mean look I I love the sport and I
think those guys are Tim Kennedy is one
of the coolest guys totally I mean I
love that dude he's funny he's just a
maniac yeah
but there are a lot of people that just
aren't tough people
the the the facade is they're tough but
they're not tough you know what I mean
and I just think that that's it's cool
that there's no you know you don't you
don't have to put that out there it's
this it's genuine and it's real and you
don't have to to you don't have this is
not a podcast it's an interview show
the podcast format is like this is how
Jocko sees the world
let me tell you what I like I like fart
I like fudge I like cookies and I like
pumpkin pie and then you do a podcast
about just you you're sharing this
platform with a lot of people giving
opportunities
um putting the light that's on you on
other people helping people sharing
ideas being consistent it's important
it's appreciated I don't know if you get
enough but I really do appreciate this
and I appreciate you you letting me be a
part of it and everything you continue
to do because it means a lot seeing
people that you emulate turn out to be
honorable and decent is awesome so thank
you you I don't know about them nobody
does on the [__] fence that dopamine
thing scared me he had that way too
quick it's called dopamine yes sir
well man uh uh
it's you know I've said this a couple
times in on this podcast I mean if you
could sit down and talk with
John Basilone for three four five hours
like what I wouldn't give to be able to
do that so he's from Buffalo yeah I love
it so to be able to sit here and talk to
you for you know however many hours
we've been going
um it's just an honor and I know that so
many people are going to learn so much
from this so thanks for coming on thanks
for the Lessons Learned
[Music]
um
thanks for your service obviously thanks
your leadership and thanks for the
example that you set for
for everyone in the Army and and
everyone in the military and really for
the citizens of our country of
how to be
how to be honorable
that means that means a lot and I really
appreciate that my last question for you
and I'm Gonna Let You Go
if you could do it over again
what
what Elite branch do you think how would
you rank them
the the all the branches in each one of
the elite branches they all have great
guys who's the one group though that you
worked with that said and you thought
these guys are like that were equals
well I worked with special forces guys
that are better than me I worked with
marines that were better than me I work
with uh whom I missing I work with Army
Rangers that were better I worked with
I've worked with guys from 101st that
were better than me guys from the 137
that were better than me there's there's
studs in all these groups I've also
worked with every one of those groups
that with guys that were not as good
with guys that you didn't want to go on
a mission with you so to me there's
great incredible guys in in in all units
and
and then there's also in all units
there's people that are are crap but
just as as
institutionally Delta you've got the you
know uh Mars you got the uh Air Force
specialized right individuals there's
going to be good and bad but the one
group that you looked at and said wow if
I wasn't a seal
I'd want to be that that's if I was in a
seal if you weren't a seal it can't be a
seal I mean there's you didn't get the
vaccination they kicked you up yeah
actually they let them all stay in thank
God uh
if I wouldn't if I wouldn't have joined
the Navy I most likely would have joined
the Marine Corps uh just because like
every well like most
of the young men I grew up with when you
looked at the Marine Corps you thought
hey it's the Marines yeah because they
do such a good job with their culture
and with their image and and the Marine
Corps is an outstanding group and so I
probably would have ended up in the
Marine Corps and if I wouldn't end up in
the Marine Corps I would have been in
the Army because the same thing uh let's
see I'm dodging and now I'm feeling like
I'm dodging your question I don't think
so who I would ask would you what if
your daughter said she wanted to go what
would you suggest
if my daughter said she wanted to go
into Special Operations no she wanted to
just join the military what branch would
you think would you want your daughter
in uh the Air Force you know no I
which lines
why is that well uh my I'm just my
oldest daughter came to mind um she's
very analytical she's really smart I
think that she could bring a lot to the
table in that kind of environment
probably being an Intel officer she's
really good at assimilating information
and she'd probably be really good at
that job
so there you go yeah
I would be horrible at that job
no just being being an Intel officer in
the Air Force I don't think it would be
a good fit for me do you think have you
ever been could you be a pilot are you
are you too big to be a pop uh because
they're kind of like jockeys a little
bit yeah they're a little bit like
jockey's uh one of my really good
friends is a is a Top Gun pilot be
Marine Corps and I had I had no desire
whatsoever to be a pilot none zero I had
no desire and you know even like riding
in a Bradley I never liked riding in a
Bradley I always felt like I wasn't in
control like it was this machine and I
couldn't really now look I wasn't
driving the Bradley I was always sitting
in the back like you were freaking
sweating my nuts off and wondering where
the hell I was right right no situation
so I'd rather be in a Higginsville yeah
as you can see where you are yeah that
was so so but being a pilot for me I
never had any desire I'd watch a movie
and I didn't care I wanted to see what
the grunts were doing yeah I always
wanted to be on the ground and more
specifically I wanted to be some kind of
a Commando of some kind I wanted to like
put Cami paint on and sneak over beaches
and kill people that's what I wanted to
do that's the only that's the first job
I remember wanting like when I've
realized I'm gonna grow up
and I had to do something I wanted to do
that something where I put a a cami cork
on my face you know because we used to
burn the Cork and then put the black on
our faces when we were little kids I
wanted to do that over the water into
enemy territory and kill bad guys that's
the only thing I remember wanting to do
so that's why if I want to join the SEAL
Teams it would have been the Marine
Corps because the Marine Corps was in
the water and I knew that much even as a
young kid
but pilate was never was never was never
into it never even thought about it for
a minute
so I I always wondered that because when
I think about like the um even when I
watch Avatar I I'm rooting for the
Marines in that I know they're the bad
guys but that I don't like the blue
people are the ones that like I like the
I always watch the movies for the guys
that I I can identify not that you know
they're evil they hurting the you know
the wonderful blue people but I'm just
saying I get it I understand that in the
Navy the guy every time you watch a Navy
Seal movie there's a guy comes out of
the water and like gets ready to hold
the body oh yeah is that a real thing no
no that's the the move that movie is
called Act of Valor and yeah that's not
real no it doesn't no that's not real
they that's like a that movie's like a a
hour and 30 minute music video of the
ABC classic with a real bullets yeah
they uh you know it's a big recruiting
thing it was a big recruiting thing and
they got some guys to play the roles in
the movie they they hired these guys
they hired this production company to
make a recruiting video and the guy guys
said hey we can make a recruiting video
a 30 second or a one minute recruiting
video or we can make a 90-minute feature
film what do you want and they then the
naval special Warfare at the time said
well we need people uh let's do it and
so it was a big recruiting tool and you
know and the Navy benefits from that
because because no one basically no one
makes it through SEAL training it's a
very small number of people that make it
through Zeal training so the Navy gets
all these dudes and
I it that's one thing that's that's
horrible about trying to go in the SEAL
Teams is that if you don't make it
through the Seal team if you don't make
it through basic SEAL training you're in
the Navy and if you're the type of
Personality that wants to be a machine
gunner you're gonna end up on a ship in
a engine room turning wrenches or
changing oil or whatever and look that's
a legit like that's a legit job for some
people some people love work turning
wrenches some people love being at Sea
on a ship some people love that kind of
job that's what they should do and they
join the Navy to go do that which is
perfect but if you join because you want
to be a seal and you don't make it
you're gonna end up in that job that you
really don't want at all see what's nice
about MARSOC or special forces in the
Army if you don't make it through
Special Forces selection cool you're an
infantry line yeah you're you're still
in an awesome spot you can go back later
you'll learn more same thing with the
Marine Corps the SEAL Teams is rough in
that aspect man you don't make it
through SEAL training you're done you're
doing a job that you most likely don't
want to do and that's fascinating that's
a good point
so be careful of that man be careful
that young people out there that's why
go in the army go in the army become an
infantryman pick your own MOS yeah there
you go anywhere and you could be extra
special I love an x-ray
awesome man thank you so much thank you
appreciate it
with that David bellavia has left the
building
um
Crazy Town Crazy Town yeah it's
honestly if you're listening to this
right now get these books and read them
they're really powerful
and there's so much
there's like I said during the podcast
there's entire story lines that are in
these books that I don't didn't even
come close to mentioning today yeah we
even get we didn't even get close to
that part of the story which is a this
story runs the whole thread there's
other stories in there the whole time
there's so much going on he does such a
great job capturing it the house to
house book
you can tell when you read it that he's
a couple years off the battlefield but
his mind is not off the battlefield yet
his mind is in the game when you're
reading that thing yeah it is very
intense
it is very raw
and and then you get to read remember
the ramrods which is what almost two
decades later well I guess 15 years
later
15 years a long time yeah
in a man's life 15 years a long time and
you learn a lot and you see a lot and
you go through a lot more and you get
perspective on stuff
so
it's a really incredible read
both these books so check these books
out they're awesome
there was a
couple of things that he mentioned and I
was like I really put into perspective
in a crazy way where he where he
described a sniper that they found and
he was attached to like IV just to stay
there the whole time and what did he he
said there was a hole in a table yeah
so he didn't have to go to the bathroom
or nothing just right there through the
hole in the table just staying there for
just days and days and days to be a
sniper yeah that is committed that is
committed person committed
insurgents that are ready to die for
their cause did you notice he said
something super small
kind of a side note but like he uh
he goes when he was anticipating maybe
the Battle of Honor scenario and
someone's like oh there's also a tape
out there
and then he was like oh there's a tape
let's show me the tape and then he said
what's in the box yeah he said show me
what's in the box and then he kept kind
of talking to her yeah do you know what
that's from what's in the box I do know
what it's from it's from the movie Seven
right which is interesting because again
because he's now older yeah
first of all he knows he's forgotten
things second of all you learn
eventually that your perception of
what's going on in combat isn't the same
as what's really going on in combat so
he now now at this age he knows that
like oh there's a video I wonder what
I'm you know he he knows he knows what
he thinks he did he knows what he thinks
he said he also at that age knows that
what he thinks he said and what he
thinks he did may or may not be on there
it may or may not be perceived the same
way by everybody else so that's why he's
like what's in the box that was to me
that was a pretty much Perfect movie
analogy it's very impressed yeah what's
in the box he wants to know but he don't
want to know it seems that kind of deal
I liked it yeah so much respect for that
as well yeah again and if you get that
you can watch it on parts of it on
YouTube I didn't know that there's he
mentioned a 29 minute version so that
would the entire the entire event
probably from the time they get to the
house they go in the house they get
everyone out of the house they wait for
the Bradley's brother like that whole
thing is probably 29 minutes there's one
clip that I've watched which is maybe
like five minutes long and it's
basically from the time they're getting
to the house the last time when he's
gonna go in and kill everybody
that's on video on YouTube that you can
go and watch and look it's not like a
movie because most of it's just black
like flashes noises explosions you don't
really know what's happening
you now once you've read the book and
now you hear the podcast you can be like
okay that must be what's oh okay that's
what and but then you see you know at
the end of it here they are dragging
these bodies
out of this house that this guy went in
there and killed
and yeah it's
it's definitely wild in that movie by
by where the the movie The
only the Dead
it's definitely a fascinating movie to
watch and and you get you have to
understand his perspective a little bit
it takes a little getting used to
because for me
you're watching it like oh wait this
guy's with mujahideen forces that are
attacking Americans like I hate this guy
like what are you doing you're embedded
with like I hate you yeah like why don't
you stop them
and so but then you realize hey he's
trying to figure out what's going on and
so you end up understanding what he's
doing even though at the time
and there's some I I actually I need to
watch it again because there's some that
dichotomy is brought out in a way that
is makes it easier to understand because
let's face it if you're freaking sitting
there while Musa Deen forces are getting
ready to kill Americans and you're not
doing something to stop them I got a
problem with you you know and I think
some of it is like he's with them and
he's like oh [__] they're doing an
attack and he kind of just he knows if
he says anything they'll just kill him
um and yeah it's it's a really but then
and then at a certain point in the movie
he basically stops embedding with the
Moosh because he realizes that they're
evil and he starts embedding with the
Americans but he has got a glock he
passes a lot and he passes a lot of
Intel to the Americans and especially to
like David bellavia and his platoon he's
given them exact Intel about who they're
fighting and it he it's really clear in
the book how helpful he was from that
perspective
but who knows maybe at some point we can
have Michael where he's he's got all
kinds of crazy stories from his all the
insane things he's done and it's weird
you know like
I guess the the
the the
highest degree of of explaining all that
would be a documentary right but at the
same time a documentary is only going to
be an hour long and you know you got
limitations and what you can put in
there and how long you wanna whereas if
he's come and explain some of that stuff
on the podcast and maybe a little bit of
a longer format you could get down to
some some good information that may not
be
conveyed properly in the
in the in the hour and a half long
documentary yeah
hey how hard like wait have you ever
done Jiu Jitsu like with full gear on
like the full gig how is it a lot
different like it feels like especially
just even how he sort of mentioned it
seems like dang that might be a lot
harder actually no no it's it's not it's
not a lot harder it's not a lot
different
it's a little harder it's a little
different it's not a lot of either I
feel like
then again then this is more of a
question like the bottom game would
feels like it'd be a lot more different
than the top game wouldn't be that much
no but they're both about the same
different oh for real yep yep that was a
excuse that got used by people
when it came to training martial arts
and Jiu Jitsu in the SEAL Teams it was
like well you know Jiu Jitsu you just
wear a ghee you don't wear all this gear
or Jiu Jitsu you just wear a rash guard
so it's unrealistic and you're not going
to be able to fight when you have gear
on and which is they would say the same
thing about you or or I would make
comparison to parachuting because when
you parachute with military equipment
it's this big parachute and you've got
you could potentially have a weapon with
you and could potentially have a
rucksack with you and you're gonna
protect potentially have your web Gear
with you and you have all these things
on so it's a lot different than me
running down to San Ysidro or wherever
and doing a civilian jump where I'm just
like literally wearing a pair of short
sneakers and I jump out a little back
little little uh
parachute on my back and jump out throw
out you know it's just real easy and
slick and cool yeah
but here's the thing if you're really
good at those slick cool civilian jumps
and you put a military rig on you're
gonna be really good same thing with
shooting
sometimes guys be like well you don't
want to learn the bad habits of
target shooting or three gun shooting
which is a certain competition type of
shooting you don't want to get the bad
habits from that
but if you take a guy that is a three
gun shooter a competitive and now he's
in combat he's just going to be
infinitely better now look are there
certain little things you got to watch
out for
yes there are certain little things that
you got to watch out for
you know I don't know if you've ever
heard the story but there's a shootout
in Florida I think it was in Florida and
the cop
when they the cop got killed and when
they did like the investigation he had
the shells from his revolver in his
pocket which meant that as he was
reloading instead of just dumping the
shells from his revolver he was catching
him putting him back in his pocket which
is a habit that he got from being on the
police range and you don't want to have
to bend down and pick up your brass so
you just put him in your hand you put
them in your pocket so he had lost
whatever three quarters of a second or a
second and a half on every reload yeah
because he had this habit so you do have
to pay attention to what bad habits you
may or may not get from doing these
civilian activities that are
complementary to your military career so
for instance there are positions in jiu
jitsu
where it may not be the best thing to do
because oh you got a sidearm right or
like let's say you're a police officer
there's certain positions you want to
use because it doesn't expose your
weapon it doesn't expose your weapon to
being grabbed so you want to do certain
things that are a little bit different
now would I rather be a cop that's a
purple belt in jiu jitsu
that might have one bad habit or some
cop that has no experience in Jiu Jitsu
which is going to get the [__] beat out
of you
you're gonna get the [__] beat out of
you that's what's gonna happen yeah so
so
Jiu Jitsu with gear on is slightly
different slightly harder
but very very similar and it's and it's
similar enough that it's going to make
all the difference in the world in one
of these scenarios and yes and keep in
mind even if it was like a lot bulkier
and a lot harder it's still better than
no jiu jitsu and which I've always
thought or whatever but I was wondering
at the time you know you obviously you
know he tells the story all good so I'm
like thinking about it like how that
looked and how that felt or whatever and
like I kind of Imagine like trying to
choke someone and you know like you ever
like maybe if you have the Geon and
they're fighting your choke or whatever
and maybe they're not even fighting that
good but it's easier to fight a choke
with the Geon versus with no Gee right
because you can just grab any part of
that thing or whatever so with the bulky
gear on chest plate helmet like all this
stuff it's like kind of hard I would
think it'd be harder so I'm like shoot I
wonder how freaking hard even if the
dude is untrained I'm under how much
harder that would be
it'd be the same as training versus
untrained like a jiu jitsu fighter yeah
someone that doesn't know Jiu Jitsu is
lost yeah and I feel like sometimes well
a lot of times anyway people don't do
Jiu Jitsu maybe they'll do another
martial art or maybe they'll advocate
for another martial art they'll do the
straw man thing where they'll be like
yeah you're gonna pull guard in the
street or whatever like I think it's
pretty common knowledge that someone who
knows Jiu Jitsu and they get in a fight
with a guy on the street or in a kill
house or whatever they're not gonna pull
guard on the guy they're gonna use it's
like hey let me basically what they do
is they look for the most inappropriate
move of Jiu Jitsu and they say what
you're gonna do that move on the most
inappropriate time or whatever when the
the reality is no jiu jitsu is like a
bunch of moves actually infinite moves
and you know a certain amount of those
infinite moves and you're gonna do
literally every single time that you
possibly can the most appropriate move
for the appropriate time and pulling
guard is one of the many moves that's
more yes geared towards the training
scenario like with another Jiu Jitsu guy
or with you know know a tournament
scenario whatever yeah but that's not
like a
yeah that's not a self-defense or a real
fighting no unless
you know like for for bellavia this dude
comes out of the closet if he would have
just like like hit him and knocked him
to the ground and all of a sudden David
bellavia is on the bottom oh yeah and
that's not pulling cards that's very
different but you are on the bottom and
you are gonna need to get out from the
bottom or at least control the guy from
killing you and you better know God so
you better know guard at that point yes
so and you know that's exactly what what
he said too you know and look you got
you got all your friends you got a
machine gun all your friends got machine
guns you got a pistol all your friends
got pistols you got a knife all your
friends got knives
you'd think there's a pretty slim chance
you're gonna have to actually
kill someone with your hands or with
your helmet or with your knife it's
pretty small chance but there you go
there you go
so keep training everybody keep training
uh awesome honor to have him on uh with
that speaking of training when you train
you're going to need to fuel your system
it's true
it's true jock off you so
again I know this common knowledge or
whatever but this is one of those deals
where you know you can get plenty
supplements from Plenty places you know
but you want to get the for real clean
one the one with only upside no downside
yeah that's what I had to add that's
true so the drinks
the energy drinks which have no sugar in
them
the energy drinks which have no chemical
preservatives in them this is what
everyone else is feeding you the stuff
that has sugar in it the stuff that has
chemical preservatives in it the stuff
that has chemical flavoring in it we
don't have any of that this stuff is
literally good for you you can get it
get milk
get the ready to drink milk by the way
we had a little uh Jocko fuel board
meeting today we started discussing how
much Mulk ready to drink we should make
and I'm listening and there's comments
being made you know it's going to be
this investment it's going to do this
thing we got to do it this far in
advance important information like what
how much should we boom we're going back
and forth and finally I said hey
make as much Mulk as you can make as
much as you can
where like we have it at the gym we hear
Victory it's selling out in like a day
it's gone so everybody loves the ready
to drink milk so we are going to make as
much as we possibly can
to get it to everyone because it's the
best it's just the best it's just so
good so good for you so convenient now
look do you get the powder milk yes yeah
I have the powder bulk that's my dessert
but sometimes you need that midday
hitter and tell me what you think man
it's gonna take me four minutes to make
a mulch no no not gonna it's just gonna
open up an RTD ready to drink did you
are you familiar with the term RTD yes
sir is that a normal uh
term to be familiar with is everyone
familiar with that term ready to drink
you know what I think it's a I think
it's a industry term yeah you know
actually RTD like a normal person
doesn't say that
ready T oh I might be thinking MRE oh
yeah that's me already ready to eat yeah
all right oh this is different but it is
a drink and it's ready well it's kind of
interesting yeah very similar uh so hey
check it out for Jocko fuel stuff look
you can go to jockoffuel.com
you can get the drinks at Wawa you can
get all the stuff at Vitamin Shoppe it's
all at the military commissaries it's at
the Hannaford supermarkets
up there in the Northeast Dash stores in
Maryland
wake Fern and ShopRite
Circle K in Florida we're at HEB you
know that Texas
if you're in Texas go to HEB I know
you're going to AGB go to HEB go to
Jocko fuel get what you need
that's why we got it in there for you
apparently kicking ass down an HEV so
thank you go get some and Murphy's down
in the Southeast that's where you can
get Jocko Fuel and if you don't have
those retails stores in your area
dockerfuel.com
go get some
what else well that origin can't forget
about that American made stuff started
with Jiu Jitsu geese yes we did but now
now there's a lot of other stuff jeans
boots new washes of the jeans by the way
I got all three oh yeah wait a second
time I didn't get them yet I'm sorry
some people got it these things some
people don't know uh it's okay but yeah
Amanda Roberts about that Amanda Roberts
I know you're listening right now
you know what I need I don't want the
light I don't know well no send me all
three send me all three because I was
gonna say I don't need the super light
ones but Pete was reminding me Pete said
he was driving his motorcycle yeah and
it was hot it was a sunny day and the
the really light jeans they don't absorb
the heat did the job yeah
so yes Amanda Roberts
please okay brother send
all three washes of jeans to my house as
soon as you can I I did agree agree with
you there though I you don't strike me
as the light washed jeans wearing type I
would that's what I I hesitated on it
but then I remember what P Roberts told
me functional P Rob was something
functional like when I'm out in the
desert heat I don't want to wear a black
pair of jeans you want to wear a nice
pair of light with light ones you make a
good point all of them fit the same just
like functional functionally sound 100
by the way yeah so yeah jeans boots some
belts the belt even it's a it feels like
a subtle thing very impressive very very
impressive if you're gonna make it make
it real good that's the kind of the
overall concept right yes sir all made
in America by the way yeah well that's
not even a by the way yeah that's a Hey
listen up made in America
if you care about human beings
don't buy stuff that's from other
countries
because they're not taking care of their
human beings
they're they're enslaving human beings
to make you your product they don't care
about the environment they don't care
what they do with the dye when it's done
dying whatever they're making they just
put it in the ocean put it in the rivers
kill all the animals
they put it the crap in the atmosphere
so if you care about
people
if you care about planet Earth
and if you care about America
then go to origin USA and get some
Morgan usa.com that's what we got big
time also the store it's called Jocko
store so we can represent the path
discipline equals freedom
good we've seen that video before we
know that concept good you want to
represent that's where you can get it
also we got the shirt Locker which is a
new shirt every month subscription
scenario
new shirt some cool designs on that one
good feedback on that one but yeah
that's uh you can get that at
jockostore.com as well uh subscribe to
the podcast don't forget about Jocko
Underground
don't forget about
the YouTube channels right the Jocko
podcast YouTube channel I do a lot of
assistant directing and let's face it
when I do that it's kind of a big deal
you do good work yes sir uh also origin
USA has a YouTube channel if you want to
see what's happening at originusa check
that one out we're showing kind of
what's going on behind the scenes there
psychological warfare
I've been saying I was going to make
another one of those for like five years
yeah slowly we're kinda
being creative with some of that stuff
in life
[Music]
it's good all right so uh psychological
warfare if you want to get a little MP3
activity for yourself when you have a
moment of weakness flip side canvas
Dakota Meyer
kind of interesting today
speaking of Dakota Meyer
I asked David bellavia hey what what
flavor drink do you want I said we got
this we got that he goes uh let me try
that black cherry vanilla and I was like
cool ran down gotta go by the way that's
that's Dakota Meyers drink that's his
signature flavor he's like hell yeah so
I should have got a picture of that yeah
god I'm an idiot well you know what I
bet you can pull some off the camera off
the video yeah when he's taking a drink
right of course yes sir you can do that
right yep and then we can send it to
Dakota it'd be like hey Dakota
birds of a feather
a bunch of books hey these two books
remember the ramrods
an army Brotherhood in War and Peace and
then house to house both of them by
David bellavia uh just outstanding books
if you have any interest in history in
combat in war in human nature in the
limits of mankind on an individual level
of bravery
get these books
they'll both be available on our website
but sometimes people go hey what what
book should I read they're all on the
website oh yeah they're on the website
go to jockopodcast.com go to books on
the podcast there's a tab is that the
right one yes sir there's a tab
and you can get those get get only cry
for the living by Holly McKay
final spin I'm bummed David bellavia
talked to me for 10 minutes about how
much he freaking loved final spin it was
great blah blah and we and we didn't we
weren't recording we weren't recording
Echo Charles next time which is great
good job that's my battery yeah one job
two jobs what was the other one and a
half
uh yeah so so check out final spam check
out all these leadership books I've
written the kids books I've written
um miking the dragons way the warrior
kid one two three four about face we
talked about that today
I wrote the forward to the new version
of that so get in there extreme
ownership dichotomy of leadership
on front
have a leadership consultancy
a leadership consultancy where we work
with companies all over the world
teaching them leadership principles that
we learned on the battlefield if you're
interested in that for your organization
go to echelonfront.com and if you're
just an individual that wants to come to
an event wants to learn these principles
face to face you can also go there check
out our events we also have online
training online training for leadership
and life look leadership is a mindset
that's going to help you in every aspect
of your life it's not necessarily oh I'm
in charge of 42 people and these are the
leadership principles I need to know no
it's like oh I'm in charge of me
I'm in charge of my two kids
I'm in charge of the three peers that I
have at work I'm in charge of my Group
of Seven friends or whatever it is if
you're interacting with other people
you are leading people
so learn how to make your life better
and by the way it all starts with you
learn to lead yourself learn a
decision-making process for the things
that you do
you eat all that
through courses and through live
interactive training on Extreme
ownership.com
go check that out and if you want to
help service members active and retired
you want to help their families
you want to help gold star families
check out Markley's mom mama Lee She's
Got an incredible charity organization
if you want to donate or you want to get
involved go to America's Mighty Warriors
dot org
and also don't forget about Micah Fink
who is taking vets up into the
wilderness
so that they can search and find
themselves Heroes and
horses.org and if you want to connect
with David bellavia go to
davidbellavia.com he's on Instagram
sometimes David bellavia reluctantly
uh he's also got that radio show
Facebook is David bellavia radio so
check that out as for us we're on
Twitter we're on the gram on Facebook
of course
and we kind of got in this discussion
don't buy into it all it's not all good
social media can it's just like fire
right it's fire fire can be good it can
cook your food keep you warm
social media can give you connect you
with people give you some good
information fire can also burn your
house down and kill your whole family
guess what social media can cause a lot
of significant mental problems as well
so be careful that's what I'm saying
yeah
uh once again
thanks to David bellavia for coming on
here
for sharing your story and
we will not forget what you did we won't
forget you're proud 2-2 ramrods
Duty first and thanks to everyone else
in the Army the Navy the Air Force the
Marines the coast guard for your service
and sacrifice thank you all for being
the best military in the world and don't
lose sight of that
thanks as well to our police and law
enforcement firefighters paramedics EMTs
dispatchers correctional officers border
patrol Secret Service all First
Responders thank you for protecting us
here at home and everyone else out there
there's been much
sacrifice
for our freedoms
let's make sure that we live to honor
them let's live
like Lieutenant Ed
won
from his epitaph
Ed who lived every moment
stood in the rain
heard the Thunder
danced to the lightning
and believed in rainbows
go live every moment
and until next time this is zeko and
Jocko
out